later sunday night at eight eastern on
american history tv on c-span three
each week american history tv's real
america brings you archival films that
help tell the story of the 20th century
[Music]
one of washington's most distinguished
throngs is at the national gallery of
art to welcome a distinguished visitor
president and mrs kennedy with french
cultural minister andre monroe and his
wife pay homage to the first public
appearance of mona lisa the leonardo da
vinci painting that has captured the
fancy of generations for 400 years the
president expresses the gratification of
the nation
[Music]
mr minister we in the united states
are grateful for this loan
from the leading artistic power in the
world france
in view of the recent meeting at nassau
i must note further
that this painting has been kept under
careful french control
and that france
has even sent along its own
commander-in-chief mission roll
and i want to make it clear
that grateful as we are for this
painting
we will continue to press ahead
with the effort to develop
an independent artistic force and power
of our own
scores of cameramen record the event as
the presidential party leads a tribute
to the lady who will play host to many
many thousands in the next three weeks
the enigmatic smile acts like a magnet
to both art lovers and the curious the
next day the gallery is jammed as the
crowd passes by the painting for abreast
it is estimated by a curious
statistician that each viewer has from
three to five seconds in front of the
painting some stand in line repeatedly
for just one more glimpse of the smile
that has launched a thousand arguments
the painting is being exhibited under
stringent security measures and its
wooden panels are protected from damage
in a temperature humidity controlled
case
[Music]
nearly 10 000 people filed by mona lisa
the first day making her by far the most
popular hostess in washington
everybody wants to meet the new girl in
town
this year c-span is touring cities
across the country
48 hours of non-fiction books all
weekend every weekend
on book tv
the two books pictured here are
biographies of english writer virginia
woolf and artist leonardo da vinci the
books are published by penguin putnam as
part of their penguin lives series
recently nigel nicholson author of
virginia woolf and sherwin newlin author
of leonardo da vinci talked about the
subject of their biographies and
answered questions it's about an hour
and ten minutes
tonight we are here
in part to celebrate a truly wonderful
series of books the penguin lives series
of biographies
as a child i had a wonderful
series of brief biographies
of great famous men and a few famous
women um uh
and i cherish that series for some
reason i'm no longer in possession of
that series i have to talk to my mother
about that uh but uh there are marvelous
books i can still picture them on my
shelf uh jumping directly from
from davy crockett to marie curie um in
that wonderful fashion that those series
did and for us adults uh the penguin
live series has really um
uh at least for me uh brought back a
truly nostalgic feel tonight we are
celebrating the publication of the two
latest editions in this marvelous series
and the first of our speakers tonight is
dr sherwin b newland who has written a
marvelous biography of leonardo da vinci
and i think the highest praise that i
can extend to this book is that he
brings to it
um
a a real passion for inquiry and a love
of science that i think his subject
would have recognized and appreciated
wholeheartedly
sherwin newland is the author of the
best-selling how we die which won the
1994 national book award for non-fiction
as well as the mysteries within a
surgeon reflects on the medic on medical
myth
doctors the biography of medicine and
the wisdom of the body published in
paperback as how we live
he is the clinical professor of surgery
at yale university where he also teaches
medical history and bioethics
and he has come to us tonight from
hampden connecticut and we are extremely
pleased and honored that he could do so
please join me in welcoming dr sherwin
newlin
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm so sorry
[Music]
i'm actually davey crockett here to talk
to you about marie curie
you know i love being in cambridge
because it's so much like new haven but
without the crime
i think without the crime
the history of my being interested in
leonardo may surprise many people what
may surprise really many people is that
leonardo
beyond being an artist and all the other
things that he was was primarily an
anatomist and when i say primarily i
really mean primarily
it's my notion as i've been studying his
life for the last 25 years that what he
really wanted to be was a scientist and
not a painter and of course he never was
a sculptor but not an architect and not
a city planner
but he wanted to be the first great
anatomist and indeed he was and i hope i
can convince you of that in the next 20
minutes or so
probably the most
remembered thing that's ever been said
about leonardo da vinci is this
statement that said when freud made
in the early part of the century he was
like a man who awoke early in the
darkness while all others were still
asleep now that's familiar
to many of you but there is something
else that he said that i not he said
someone else said walter peter actually
that i think is more cogent and more to
the point about the leonardo that i have
come to know over this period of time
peter who is the great late 19th century
critic essayist said this
he seemed to those about him as one
listening to a voice that was silent for
other men
he seemed to his contemporaries to be
the possessor of some unsanctified and
secret wisdom
it's this watchful intensity that's
conveyed by the life of leonardo that's
captured my imagination
and that word specifically unsanctified
leonardo was probably the first of the
great western thinkers
during the middle ages renaissance as a
matter of fact
to separate god from nature
not to seek the answers in god's hand
but to seek the answers
in ways that any human being with enough
sense with enough willingness to work
could find out for himself we don't even
know what leonardo believed in in his
time he was thought perhaps to be a
heretic or whatever it was but it was
his belief that if he worked hard enough
everything would be available to him
we don't know much much more about him
than that
it's astonishing how much we talk about
this man how much we write about him and
how few facts we have and let me give
you an example of this
in
and this is the way really i start the
book in the eighth year of my
idolatrous fascination with this fellow
i decided finding myself in florence one
day on a trip with my wife i decided i'd
like to go visit vinci because i wanted
to be at the great man's birthplace so i
went to a local natural history museum
and i asked how to get there so i got on
the train to empoli and then i got on
the bus da vinci and you get off the bus
in vinci and there are these huge signs
with arrows and the signs say
casa de natale de leonardo the arrow is
this way of course the arrow should be
this way because it's three kilometers
straight up in the air
so we start walking we start walking up
this hill and we try and we trudge and
we trust we come to the top of it and
there's this old renaissance ruin
with two old italian ladies selling
postcards
and some other tourists sort of kind of
hanging around languidly and what an
anti-climax it was what an essential
waste of time it was we didn't feel any
sense of enchantment it didn't feel
right
it was reason that it didn't feel right
it was a tourist trap
and i didn't find out for years that no
one knows where this fellow was was born
we don't even know if he was born in
vinci we knew his father lived in vinci
but he may not have been born there in
fact we had walked out of vinci into
another town called anchiano which is
the town beyond vinci some people think
he was born there and that to me is a
kind of a metaphor for trying to find
this person
who one of his
one of his biographers has called see i
almost said autobiographers because when
we write about leonardo we write about
ourselves you know everybody has a take
on him tells you more about himself
than he does about leonardo which is
what leonardo incidentally did in the
mona lisa but we'll get to that later
so here's
what i write about my experience that
day
leonardo is not to be found in that
place in fact he's not to be found in
any place he's not a creature of places
or monuments or even of permanence he
flashed across his time and was gone
leaving a vast body of work almost none
of which except the paintings could be
fully appreciated until centuries after
his death and far away from the house in
which he was almost certainly not born
but it's his anatomy
it's not his life
it's not his study of the perspective of
the eye it's not really the mona lisa or
the last supper
that has kept me attracted to this man
as a surgeon obviously
but it's the fact that almost from the
beginning of his career
his objective
was to study nature using the human body
as the medium by which he could
understand even the celestial bodies
because to him the human body was the
microcosm
it was the distilled essence of the
entire universe the macrocosm and if he
could understand the body and the way it
worked and why it worked he would
understand everything
including whatever it was that he
conceived of as the divinity
not only is it the anatomy of leonardo
that has obsessed me but his elusiveness
as well
struggling to the top of a steep hill in
vinci or ankiano and finding nothing
more than a perhaps
seems symbolic of the problem faced not
only by the professional leonardo
scholars but by the rest of us as well
struggling to comprehend who he was the
dates the facts the known events are far
fewer than we need if we're to
understand
how such a being could have existed the
enigma of the mona lisa smile is not
less than the enigma of her creator's
life force or perhaps that smile is in
itself leonardo's ultimate message to
the ages and here i put words in his
mouth but i think these words are
justified
there is even more to me than you can
ever capture
though i've spoken so intimately to you
in my notebooks even as i have spoken to
myself i have kept final counsel only
with the depths of my spirit and the
inscrutable source that has made me
possible
seek as you may i will commune with you
only so far the rest is withheld for was
my destiny
to know things you will never know
and the more one studies leonardo the
more one comes away without
with this
perception
that we will never understand him but we
ought to keep trying
because it's enormous fun if nothing
else
my take on leonardo is so different than
the take of so many people
who have examined the few known facts of
his life
was he even a renaissance man people
think of him as the ultimate renaissance
menu today you read about a baseball
player
who's a gourmet cook so they say who's a
renaissance man
or a physics professor who plays the
violin ah a renaissance man well listen
here's a guy who's a painter an
architect an engineer a philosopher a
mathematician a scientist an interior
designer a city planner
and of course an anatomist
i say he may not have been such a
renaissance man because in fact when we
think of what the renaissance
represented a return
to the to the classics or return to the
classical period and a love of nature it
was only the love of nature as a matter
of fact he knew very little about the
classics
he was what he called himself an
unlettered man here's what he wrote
those who study the ancients and not the
works of nature are stepsons and not
sons of nature which is the mother of
all good authors and he specifically
included the aristotles the ptolemies
the galen's the great
the great sin equinone of medicine at
that time he was born illegitimately
he was his father was about the fifth
generation of notaries they were very
prosperous people his mother
was a girl of the town the town was
vinci indeed she apparently could have
lived in vinci or on keanu where he was
born nobody knows much about the first
five years of his life
he appears the date of his birth appears
in a notaries register written by his
grandfather in fact and five years later
it is noted that there is an
illegitimate child
living with the family of ser pierro da
vinci in vinci so at least at age five
he was in his father's house and his
father apprenticed him eventually
to a great artist of the time whose
nickname was verrocchio meaning true eye
verrocchio was an artisan he did all
kinds of
commissions in metal work painting
whatever
leonardo stayed with him till he was 25
or 26 years old and from then on
he was on his own first five years in
florence on his own and the rest of his
life is peripatetic although he stayed
in different cities for different
periods of time milan initially for
about 16 years then florence then rome
then back to milan then back to florence
again back to rome again and eventually
dying as many of you know in the small
french city of amwas
always
moving
when things got bad
when the money supply ran out
when the ruler
let's say the duke of milan so-called
ludovico sephorza
was attacked by enemies and leonardo he
was leonardo's patron leonardo realized
he had no money he did not stay with the
duke in his bad times he went back off
to florence and and you would think
that this might be a condemnation of his
memory and the fact is
that leonardo's only reason for living
was to be leonardo that's all he wanted
he attached himself to the borgias to
the medicis
to some of the most vicious and violent
people of the time nobody was worse than
cesare borgia
he became cesare borges military
engineer at one point accompanying him
on all the maraudings and slayings and
murderings
just so that he could be free
to get back to the hospital to dissect
corpses the few lovely paintings we have
of his were accepted as commissions
believe it or not and i'm convinced of
this
so that he could have the money to get
back to the hospital and dissect the
corpses as he got older there was more
and more dissection he started
dissecting when he was
about 21 or 22 because verrocchio said
if you want to understand the way the
human body works you've got to go to set
corpses in the hospital
and that was his initial motivation but
as time went on
he thought
why does the muscle work this way what's
going on inside that for example makes
me feel noises or makes my heart go tip
or tapper
oh i like that tipper tapper
anyway
so he became the very first man in all
of history to dissect within the body
with the purpose of finding out anything
about the body
i have a couple of wonderful pictures in
this book showing that the anatomy
drawing that was in every student's
textbook there was one textbook that
every european medical student used
which the in which the anatomy is simply
symbolic they didn't care what the
anatomy was everybody got sick because
they're black bile or yellow bile
they're phlegm their blood was out of
whack or something who cared if there
was a spleen or a liver or a gallbladder
but leonardo cared and suddenly he
appears with an almost perfect
anatomical drawing of the entire body
which he created in time because he was
not content to know and learn only
about
the function the structure rather it was
the function it was why things work
that what one must do in art is to
capture a single instant of time
and in that single instant portray what
he called the passions of the soul it's
a term that he's used several times in
his writing
during that first milan period he
painted the last supper which some of
you have probably seen it's now been
restored
the moment in time represented by the
last supper is the moment after jesus
has said to those 12 men one of you will
betray me and every one of those faces
is different and every one of those
faces is thinking something completely
different and now that it's restored you
can almost tell what their what they're
thinking what each of those people is
thinking
he was intrigued by function he was
intrigued by energy he was intrigued by
movement and forces and the epitome of
all of this was flowing water flowing
water to him
symbolized the movement of the body the
movement of thought and the passions of
the soul leonardo was intrigued by
motion and the forces involved the
continuous flowings of energies in
nature and in the life of man are a
constant and even a central theme
running through his manuscripts like the
streamings of waters to which he so
often eluded
moving water in fact is his symbol for
those flowing energies it is vital to
his conception of the universe
to him the study of structure was only
the beginning of the study of function
and the mechanical forces that made it
possible he developed further a notion
he had long held about the pictorial and
scientific capture of a single instant
wherein the whole of an event or person
is elucidated both in art and in science
he argued one should arrest that instant
and examine it because it holds within
itself the past and the future just as
it is a thing of the various
present
the art historian sidney fridberg has
said of the mona lisa that it is quote
an image in which a breathing instant
and a composure for all time are held in
suspension
he has this image that he comes back to
again and again you put your hand in a
stream of water and everything on one
side of your hand is the past and
everything on the other side of your
hand is the future and the place where
your hand is is that instant that you're
trying to capture and the more one looks
at the mona lisa the more one recognizes
he has captured an instant
in her life or is it her life who was
she
who is in that picture is it indeed this
woman
mona lisa whose name has been carried
down through the ages she's a 24 year
old wife of a man in his late 30s who
was a
nobleman of the time
it was one of many many commissions
leonardo took
and
of course one of the few that he ever
finished because what he used to do was
take these many commissions begin work
and stop work and people would get so
fed up with him they wouldn't even ask
for their money back so what would
happen would be he would pocket the
money he never did the work he wasn't
trying to cheat anybody he just wanted
to get back to his anatomical work
for example at the time he was painting
the last supper there he is in milan he
has met a hundred-year-old man and they
get to be kind of friendly and one day
the 100 year old man drops dead he's
living in a hospital that was before
hmos you could live in a hospital
and he said i'm going to dissect this
100 year old man's body and by
coincidence
what happens is that a few months later
a baby of two years dies and he dissects
that body
and he's struck by a difference which to
us of course would be very obvious but
to people of that time would be anything
but obvious the old man's arteries
are hot as rocks they're twisted and
they're bent you can't get water through
them and leonardo starts to think why is
it so different from these arteries in
the baby which are straight which are
soft i can blow water through them it's
perfectly fine
and the answer comes to him as the
answer to another question he's been
wondering about why do all people die
without fever now this is a time when
the average life expectancy was about 38
37 years of age and what did they die of
they all died of infectious disease so
everybody died of a fever but the few
people who would live into their 60s 70s
80s would not die a fever they would die
of things that we recognize stroke heart
disease perhaps dementia
this is the answer he says what happens
is
that the blood can't get through to the
various organs particularly to the heart
because he had discovered the coronary
arteries
100 years before anybody thought of it
he discovered the coronary arteries and
realized that blood was not getting to
the heart so these organs are dying and
that's why all people die without fever
but that wasn't enough for leonardo he
had to know why it happened
he didn't know about dna and telomerase
and all that sort of stuff
why do these arteries get thick and
there must be something in the blood
there must be something in the blood
that comes out of the blood and deposits
on the inside of the arteries
this is uh 1492 14 you know columbus is
sailing along that's a long time ago
what is it that comes out of the
arteries that the pot that comes out of
the blood that deposits on the artery
it's something we eat it's something in
this rich diet of ours here's a man
talking about cholesterol
400 more than 400 years before anybody
even knows how to spell the word
this is typical of what he did i can't
go into the details of a particular
discovery he made about the aortic valve
the valve just above the heart but it
wasn't rediscovered until 1969 and
leonardo had identified it in about 1502
or 1503
his life story
is full of things like this and he wrote
them down wrote these facts down amidst
these thousands of drawings that he made
with his left hand
there are approximately fifteen thousand
manuscript pages of which we only have
five thousand the the rest have
disappeared we don't know where they are
every once in a while something turns up
the madrid codex was found in the
library in spain in 1965 we will
probably not find any others all the
anatomical work was put into a single
box
about the time
of
charles the first of england it was
locked someone cut charles the first
head off as you remember people forgot
about the box 150 years later someone
chopped it open and there are all of
leonardo's drawings which people have
been studying ever since
what is this writing what is mirror
writing if there are any lefties in this
place you can do it very easily
it's the natural way for a lefty to
write
lefty to inscribe i should say
he had his own
way of writing words we all have our own
ways of keeping notes you have to
remember to buy a pitcher of beer
so you don't write picture of beer you
write pit b or something like that you
you have a code for yourself he had a
code for himself there was nothing
mysterious about it his words would run
together sometimes a long word would be
divided into three he used no
punctuation he used mirror writing and
numbers one two three and four he made
up he had different
different kinds of orthography than our
ordinary arabic numerals but anybody who
studies it can read it and a good number
of people have read it and taught us
about it let me just read a paragraph
about the notebooks
had leonardo set out to record a volume
of the principles by which he lived his
life or a book of aphorisms for which he
wished to be remembered or a compendium
of his interpretations of the universe
in his relationship to mankind had any
of these been his intention he could not
have accomplished them more effectively
than what he did in what would appear to
be a scatter shot miscellany of random
thoughts sprayed over the pages of his
loose sheets and notebooks amid sketches
architectural plans scientific
observations mathematical constructs
quotations from other authors and
records of daily life he exposes it once
his inner most musings and the overt
thrust of the message he devoted his
life to transmitting that a human being
and this is the message that a human
being can be understood only by turning
toward nature that the secrets of nature
are discoverable by observation and
experiment free of preconception that
there are no bounds to the possibilities
of man's understanding that there is a
unity between all elements in the
universe that the study of form is
essential but the key to understanding
lies in the study of movement and
function
that the dynamics of nature
are what is important that the ultimate
question to be answered about all life
and indeed all nature is not how but why
the great difference in the few
paintings of leonardo and the many
paintings of michelangelo is that
leonardo was attempting to show you what
his subjects were thinking
we can't figure it out but that's what
he was attempting to do michelangelo
wanted to show you how they were moving
this is most epitomized in the mon lisa
who has like leonardo himself
eluded our perceptions for these many
many years who is she everybody agrees
she is a maternal figure
there's a lot of psychoanalytic
interpretation obviously based on his
relationship with his two mothers his
real mother and the woman who brought
him up which was his who was his
father's wife albierra his father's
first wife
but i think it's more than that
you know
one of the
psychoanalytic and the psychoanalytic i
should say interpretation of
homosexuality
is that the young boy for a complex of
reasons begins to identify with his
mother
freud was quite clear in saying that
there are biological reasons too and he
didn't want to deny or gain say the
biological reasons but as he studied his
homosexual patients the identification
with the mother was very very clear
and his thesis was that not only does a
child identify with a mother but the
love for the mother is extreme so he
is
basically in adoration not just of his
mother but since he identifies with his
mother of himself too
this gives rise to enormous narcissism
and
he
actually
has not freud has not used the
narcissism to explain mona lisa
but i have tried to do that to try to
tell who this person is
that he has
become so renowned for painting
my notion is that just as this woman
is his mother this woman is also
leonardo
and
the interesting thing is that more than
one writer who has written biography has
pointed out
that whatever a biographer may do
whether he gives you an accurate
portrait or she gives you an accurate
portrait of the subject or not what they
really do is give you an accurate
portrait of themselves
so my argument is that leonardo and
painting them on lisa was giving us a
biography and an autobiography at the
same time
but
the audience is too hushed so i have to
amuse you and i want to read you
something from leonardo's anatomy which
i think will amuse you
and then i can turn the evening over
to nigel nicholson
he had many fascinating notions about
anatomy that turned out to be right that
were not rediscovered for years and
years but there was
a fascination he had as you can imagine
with sex organs
he was revolted
by the notion of sexuality in general
there is no evidence from writings about
him
that he had any sexual experiences of
any kind he was surrounded at all times
by beautiful young boys and young men he
kept them in his household he supported
them but apparently there was no real
relationship with him the notion is that
his libido was repressed and suppressed
into what freud calls the investigative
impulse that that is the secret of his
great productivity we all sublimate our
libidos to some extent and this is why
we can do the things we do
his libido was said by many
psychoanalytic observers to be
completely suppressed into the
investigative impulse so he was revolted
by the sexual act but he was fascinated
by the sexual organs
not unexpectedly he was more fascinated
by the male sexual organs by the female
which in some ways repelled him
and he writes this this
little screed about how
awful
sexual activity is if it weren't for the
elevated emotions involved the physical
act would be too disgusting for anybody
to carry out and then very shortly
thereafter
he writes this
about the penis
about the penis he starts off about the
penis
you don't need leonardo to tell you this
but i'd like you to hear it in his words
the penis this confers with a human
intelligence and sometimes has
intelligence of itself
and although the will of the man desires
to stimulate it it remains obstinate and
takes its own course
and moving sometimes of itself without
license or thought by the man whether he
be sleeping or waking it does what it
desires
often the man is asleep and it is awake
and many times the man is awake and it
is asleep
many times the man wishes it to practice
and it does not wish to
many times it wishes to and the man
forbids it
it seems therefore that this creature
has often a life and intelligence
separate from man and it would appear
that the man is in the wrong and being
ashamed
to give it a name or exhibit it
now listen to the rest of this
here's a man who is revolted by
sexuality
ashamed to give it a name or exhibit
seeking rather constantly to cover and
conceal what he ought to adorn and
display with ceremony as one who serves
so the great man is as human as the rest
of us i i suspect that that most of the
enjoyment of this evening
is to come so i just
well that was not a pun i swear was not
and this is boston
i just want to leave you oh i'm so
ashamed
i just just want to leave you with with
one thought and it goes back to peter it
goes back to walter peter in perhaps
1880 or whenever it was he wrote this
it's got to do with that watchful
intensity
leonardo the great student of the eye
leonardo the great student of pers of
perspective leonardo the great visual
student of anatomy the watchful
intensity that enabled him to develop
anatomically scientifically
over through the years and he was as
walter peter called him the possessor of
some
unsanctified and secret wisdom thanks
very much for
hearing me out
oh just wants to have a reading that
doesn't get back to the penis um
okay um we'll regroup uh fortunately
time hopefully time permitting will have
an opportunity to ask some questions of
dr newlin he does have a commitment uh
back in uh new haven later this evening
so
we um we will hope for the best okay um
what an evening uh it is uh it is
remarkable to have with us uh tonight uh
two such distinguished guests such a
surfeit uh
um i think that only one other author in
the penguin live series has had the
distinction of knowing their subject and
i believe that was douglas brinkley who
wrote about rosa parks but remarkably
our second guest tonight nigel nicholson
uh knew as a young child and as a young
man virginia woolf and it is that
knowledge that lends um
such a remarkable personal quality to
this uh to this biography and uh allows
him i think to so effectively evoke
not only um the the
the life and the sensibility of virginia
woolf but of her time um nigel nicholson
is the author of a portrait of a
marriage a biography of his parents
harold nicholson and vida sackville west
and of long life which are his own
memoirs he's also written books on
politics and the arts and the whitbread
prize winning history of mary curzon
a member of parliament for several years
he's the co-founder of wiedenfeld and
nicholson publishers
and he has come to us tonight from
sissinghurst in england which is now a
national trust property and we are
extremely honored and pleased that he
could join us tonight please join me in
welcoming nigel nicholson
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen i must first of all
apologize to you
for my late arrival
we had left one hour to be
here from another part of boston
but it took an hour and a half
and
i pity you
if this congestion occurs every night
but i can assure you that it's far worse
in london
and that your people are infinitely more
courteous
no honking no shouting no cutting in
people behaved with exemplary courtesy
and that did something to mitigate my
distress at being late for you
and
i'm very well aware
that later this evening
there will be competition
to any event like this
and so promise
not to exceed 15 minutes
and to release you
to hear something much more important
than i what i have to say
but dr newland and i have
each contributed to this series of short
books
each of us on
a genius
and i concede that his genius was more
of a genius than my genius
because there's never been a man rarely
in all history who has accomplished more
than leonardo
but
the shortness of our books
doesn't in any way i
hope you will come to agree
diminished
interest or importance
they are of a length which you
can read happily in a lonely evening or
on a long flight
and
when you consider
that in the
boston globe and other national
newspapers here
obituaries appear every
day almost
a thousand words long
from which you can gather
the
significance and importance
of a person's life
well our books are 50 times longer
but
in
writing about virginia woolf i had
a particular
an unfair advantage perhaps
because apart from quentin bell who
wrote the first life
of his aunt as she was
i am probably the only biographer of
this woman
who knew her personally
i knew her simply because
she became
the
intimate friend of my mother vita
sackville west
and in my childhood she was a frequent
visitor
and we greeted her visits with
a delight
oh good virginia's coming back again
what fun
and when she came she would
interrogate us about the simple
details of our boyhood lives
she would say
what woke you up this morning
well it was the sun the sun coming
through our window
what sort of a sun
angry son
friendly son
and then
we
had to go through the whole process
of dressing
which sock did you put on first the
right or the left
and then breakfast and so on and so on
until we came into the room and found
out that
it was a sort of
she was gathering copy i think in a sort
of way
as all novelists do
particularly about uh
childhood which
the virginia wolf was a sort of strange
experience
children are
eccentrics
they
talk strangely they do odd things
and so they are very interesting
and secondly i think she was
teaching us boys my brother and myself
a lesson
to observe
and to record
what we observe in writing
she once uh said to me
nothing has rarely happened until it's
been described
and another saying of hers i remember so
well
is when she said
if you don't
record fleeting ideas
you will soon cease to have any
and she meant
on facts said that
we must keep a diary we must write
letters to our friends
in order to practice
what she was preaching
the
putting on paper
in words
our daily experiences which of course is
something that she always did herself
well she's not just famous for talking
to little boys
she's famous as a novelist she wrote
eight or nine novels
many of which have become classics in
our time
some of which particularly her
masterpiece the waves
difficult for us to comprehend
requiring more effort sometimes from the
reader
as they did from the author
but she's also
famous
for
two books that she wrote
non-fiction books
in which she advocated the course of
women
they were called a room of one's own and
three guineas
and a room of one's own in particular
is put into the hands so i'm told of
every student in every university of the
united states
it has become the bible of the feminist
movement
and
we in in britain
are flattered by this attention to our
author
but rather surprised
our virginia
has become your wolf
and i'm not the same person
virginia woolf to us
was of course a novelist of particular
genius nobody denies that
but in her more political writings
about feminism and about war and
the attitude of men generally
we feel that she overstepped the mark
she used to say i have very many men
friends
but men in the mass are awful
why what does she mean about by that why
does she dislike us so much were quite
innocent people
she meant
that when men get together
in an army
in a school in a university
as judges or people who
preached in court
or even in church
all these all the worst
characteristics of men come to the
surface they become arrogant they
delight in their uniforms their robes
their wigs even
and they exclude women from their
activities
well now of course that has been true
for a very large period of history until
possibly the beginning
of the 90s of the 20th century
the women were disgracefully excluded
and virginia will
set ourselves to contest this tradition
of course
and this was one failing that we see in
our argument
she was only talking about people like
herself
that very very small group of women
in the upper middle classes who came
from cultural homes
she wanted them
to be
able to do things that men did not fight
battles
but at least enter the professions
to be doctors
to be
teachers
but there was a limit even to what
she wanted to see women doing
there was a woman who was a great friend
of my own family and known well to
virginia woolf
but unknown to most people
her name was hilda matheson
and she became the first talks director
of the bbc
she was brilliant at her job
she had to invent an entirely new
technique
this was in the late 20s and 30s
and she managed to persuade the most
imminent intellectuals of the day
h.g wells
bernie shaw
bertrand russell
virginia woolf
to take part in the programs of talks
which he initiated
but virginia in spite of agreeing to
contribute
saw something in hilda's
pussiness as she described it
her ambition
something distasteful
she thought she was hard when she wasn't
she thought that her ambition was
extraordinarily unworthy
she said to my mother whose great friend
hilda matheson was how can you consult
with somebody of that nature
and so
my conclusion
is that she hadn't really
thought
through
her
advocacy of women's rights
she wasn't
interested of course in anybody below
her own level
hilda was at her level
but people below
didn't really count in her estimation
or didn't figure in her ambition for
women's rights
she never thought that a woman whose
business it was
to clean another woman's house
should buy her own efforts
rise
to become a woman for whom other women
cleaned
she never thought rarely
that
a secretary in an office
might again by her own abilities become
a director of the firm for which she
worked she wasn't interested in that
she was enter interested only in the
higher echelons of the professions
so
that is
one thing which we in england
find wanting in virginia's arguments
and another
is her attitude to pacifasm and war
of course she thought that
wars were generated entirely by men
indeed they are to great extent and
fought by men
and that if countries have been ruled by
women there would have been no wars
but it's not true is it
from helen of troy to margaret thatcher
women have used wars and instrument of
policy
in the world war one it wasn't
men who handed to those they thought
were malingering white feathers but
women who did so
women who admired the courage exhibited
by men in combat and despised the coward
now this is no criticism of women
but it is
a criticism of virginia i think
that she overstated the argument
she
said in this last
second book
which one could call semi-political
three kiddies
that she felt that she had no duty to
her country
because our country had done nothing for
her
can that be true
she thought that any element of
patriotism
was sentimental and wrong
masculine
but when it came to war in 1939
she found herself with this dilemma
that we were engaged in combating
something which he considered
fundamentally evil
but how could you combat it
except by fighting it
she said to her husband leonard
when more broke out
isn't this terrible
we all said that
and leonard replied
of course it's terrible
but now that it's begun
we better win it
and virginia
like other pacifists of course had no
true answer to that
and slowly
she changed her mind
as the war progressed
remember she died only in 1941
so there wasn't very much of a war for
her to experience
but she did feel almost i suppose for
the first time
a stirring of that patriotism
of wishing our side to win
she felt
almost
for the first time admiration for a
politician
winston churchill
and there was a great moment which he
recorded in her diaries
when she walked out from her house in
sussex onto the darns
on a lovely summer's afternoon in 1940
during the battle of britain
an overhead streamed a flight
of spitfires of the raf
in order to combat over the english
channel an incoming flight
of uh
messerschmitts of the german of germany
and luffa
and she said in her diary looking up at
the
spitfires
i couldn't help but wish them luck
now that was a turning point surely and
it is so sad
that she only had
another year to live
let me conclude by saying something
about her
her death
she drowned herself in the river
near that
same house in sussex
she
wrote a
letter
to her husband leonard
which is in my book
which i think is one of the most moving
letters that any woman has ever penned
to a man
saying that she felt that she might go
mad again
and
how she didn't want to ruin his life
she was too
much trouble to him he couldn't work she
said
and so she felt that this action she was
about to take was the kindest
and most suitable end
and there was so there was that element
of it she felt that she was going mad
again
she could hear voices
but when she did commit suicide she was
not mad
the coroner's verdict was
she killed herself
while
her mind was out of balance
but it wasn't true
she was perfectly sane
so could there have been another reason
well
i edited virginia woolf's letters in six
volumes
about 15 20 years ago now
and i had a
collaborator a fellow editor who was an
american woman
joanne troutman
and she and i
sat over
these suicide letters
the last that we'd come to after
reading and editing 4 000 and puzzled on
this question
wasn't any other reason
of course there were superficial ones
the strain of the war and the inadequacy
of the current
diet
at the time but it wasn't that it was
she felt that she had lost her gift for
writing
her last book
was between the acts
and it was published after her death
but she told her
husband and her doctor
that she felt that it was so inferior to
what she'd done before
such a trivial book such a silly book
in fact it's the opposite it's a
wonderful book
there's
there was no point rarely in going on
living or no point in the life which she
couldn't describe
and so she decided
to kill herself
well of course
it was a
terrible blow to everybody
we felt that we had lost a woman
of extraordinary genius
a woman
who may have committed some unkindnesses
during her life
but then geniuses are not always kind
and she left behind her
such a massive documentation in her
letters and her diaries and her memoirs
in other people's memoirs and in
biographies to which i've made a small
contribution myself
which will bring her into sharp focus
before us
a woman not only of a splendid mentality
and courage
but of infinite worth
thank you
[Applause]
we'll be happy to take some questions
now um
in the back my dad what was the effect
of her suicide on you
well of course i was i was 21 years old
and i was in the army myself i hadn't
seen her for about a year
and
it was the effect upon my mother
who was our most intimate friend
far more than on my mother's sons
because by that time we were occupied
with the war itself in our own
careers in a way
and
i suppose that when i first heard of
this but i don't remember the occasion
when i heard of it it must have come as
a very great shock
but i wasn't then in the position really
to speculate upon the reasons for it
my understanding is that virginia woolf
was depressed almost always at the
conclusion of a major work such as a
novel and that she frequently felt
that the novel she had just completed
was not particularly worthwhile and she
always gave it to her husband for a
response
that was evaluation
was this different
from those other times
this woman special that uh notes that
virginia woolf often felt depressed at
the closure of a novel uh when she had
finished work on a novel she's wondering
and if um this suicide marked or this
last period of depression marked a
particularly profound period of
depression might have affected her side
i explained when i was talking
the
profound effect
of
her writing between the acts
was upon her mentality
and
i think otherwise
her novels really had little effect upon
her mind
you remember
that although in early youth and
childhood in fact she had been insane
there was a whole period of 25 i think
30 years
in her middle life
when she had no attack of insanity at
all
and she wrote these novels
like to the lighthouse mrs dalloway the
ways the years and so on
in no way at all affected by what she'd
gone through she does describe it once
in
mrs delaware
where in which occurs a figure who does
go off his head
and there must be some
connection between her own experience
and what she wrote about him
what a pair the two of you have
have written about it it's really
extraordinary da vinci and wolf
um i was wondering
about da vinci i remember tj clark
describing him as a militant and
disgusted vegetarian which was a phrase
that i liked very much
i was really wondering whether you
thought that da vinci had a reverence
for life or was it really more of a
fascination with
how things worked
and if he was a vegetarian what were his
well he was a vegetarian because of his
reverence for life the actually the only
speck of anything that might be thought
of as religiosity or faith in him
is the reverence for life as it
represents the work of the creator other
than that there is absolutely nothing
he was a vegetarian for that reason he
would not kill any animal once in the
entire five thousand manuscript pages
that we have there's an example of him
pithing a frog to study the nervous
system and a very sophisticated study it
was if he had been willing
to kill animals or vivisect them dissect
them while they were alive he would have
discovered peristalsis the movement of
the intestine he missed that completely
he thought that food was passed along
the intestinal tract
by the pressure of the gas above and he
thought the appendix which incidentally
he discovered was a pop off valve for
the gas yeah
so he was prevented by his reverence for
life
from finding out something about life he
would otherwise have discovered
this may not be fair but i wonder if uh
conduct new surgeon i'm used to unfair
doctor newland can answer a question
raised by mr nicholson
can we make it the other way
somebody referred to virginia woolf's
depression and mrs nicholson refers to
her madness
it's now 50 years later i've always been
curious to know if there's any kind of
clinical diagnosis for her mental
disorder
at this point we have a clinical
diagnosis for the
disorder that virginia
she did of course have doctors but
given this
state of the science of
mental disturbance in those days
she got no help from any of them
because they didn't know
what is wrong with her
and how to cure it
i have doctor newland can speak much
much more authoritatively about this
than i can but i would have thought that
if she'd
been alive today
she would have had help wouldn't she
and perhaps cured of her
drama traumas
psychotic people usually do not commit
suicide it's people who are severely
neurotically depressed who commit
suicide and
my first
my first act tomorrow morning will be in
will be to begin nigel nicholson's book
which i hope to have finished by
noontime and maybe i can come back and
answer the question but it's always been
my impression that what she had was
episodes of severe neurotic depression
and she was not in fact mad and anybody
in this audience who has ever had
depression as i have as a matter of fact
and recovered from it knows that the
first premonitory signs bring back
memories that are inconceivable to
anyone who is not depressed and i'm
going to guess
that she was beginning to feel the first
premonitory signs was in her perfect
right mind but couldn't tolerate the
possibility of going through this one
more time and i'm fascinated by the
notion that she became depressed after a
novel or a book any of us who have
written a book know what postpartum
depression is
and i suspect that was a major factor
and i'd be interested in your thoughts
well dr newland speculates that it was
something like postpartum depression
when when virginia woolf would finish
will i accept your judgment
and yet yes sir yeah
maybe our our fine speakers would
contemplate how
virginia woolf and leonardo da vinci
would have got along if they'd met each
other
well
she once meant met
einstein
and she told me this she was introduced
to him and she didn't know what to say
you see none of us were what do you say
to einstein
so she thought up something and she said
professor
where you go to some school only did it
come later
and she told me that
he just turned away with
boredom and contempt
well i think that probably it might have
been the same with leonardo
she wouldn't really have had a great
deal in common with him
because am i right in saying that with
all his very many gifts and skills
he wasn't really a writer was he he was
a magnificent writer this was the most
extraordinary thing about him and uh
obviously it sounds like repetitive
books but you must read this book to
read exactly
oh do you know what you get with the
book you know that picture on the front
of the book
you know who drew that picture of
leonardo da vinci
leonardo da vinci
it is a self-portrait an answer to my
part of the question and i have to catch
a train so i'm leaving in a minute right
sam
i would say that in all of leonardo's
writings there is almost no mention of
women at all he had no truck with women
he had no use for women he lived a
completely male life
it's fascinating to notice his absolute
captivation by the female genitalia
by the female by the uterus by the
development of the womb
and many commentators about his life
have talked about the two polls but
which they call attraction and repulsion
and again and again we have examples of
that which attracted him so much
repelling him at the same time
and this is not the time or the place to
talk psychoanalytic talk but it's one of
the many reasons that the psychoanalysts
are convinced convinced
that his homosexuality was indeed
the re and the need to repress libido
was indeed the reason for his great
achievements in addition obviously to
the intellect
and on that note i'm going to catch the
805 to new haven
and hope i don't get mugged at the
station thank you
are you getting old now
we haven't been able to talk
[Applause]
but perhaps we could take a question or
two more
uh yes please
mr nicholson could you comment on
virginia woolf's marriage and whether
you think it was happening that was one
of the questions i did here
i'm sorry for this
elaborate system of this judgement
having to repeat because as i'm getting
older i don't hear so well
but i heard that
would i comment upon virginia woolf's
marriage
yes i'm very glad to because
it has been put about by some scholars
not only
in my country but over here
that leonard was in fact unkind to
virginia
and discouraged her was jealous of her
didn't care for her might some person
even said have driven her to suicide
it's totally untrue
and let me tell you a story to
illustrate that
i was
as a boy of course
taken to the little house in the country
by my mother
and
there were only four other people there
leonard virginia
and maynard keynes
and his wife lydia nopakova the
ballerina
and i forget what the talk was about but
he grew very animated
and virginia was standing up by the
fireplace in this little room
talking
very excitedly
and
i saw leonard rise slowly from his chair
and touch her on the shoulder
and without inquiry or reproach of any
kind
she went with him out of the room
and upstairs
and they returned together in about a
quarter of an hour
now of course my mother and
the other two there
knew exactly what had happened
then it had seen in her animation
dangerous signals
that she might
overstep the bounds of sanity again
and had taken her away to calm down
and recover
well
when i think of that incident
and the
almost biblical tenderness
with which he touched her on the
shoulder
and her instant submissiveness to him
a submissiveness that she would never
have accorded to any other person
then i think i wish that these critics
who said that he ill-treated her could
have been now with me
maybe one or two more
[Music]
i'm sure a lot of people in the audience
have read their father's diary so i hope
they don't mind if i
asked you to comment on your
recollections and memories of him rather
than virginia woolf
your recollections and memories of your
father he's interested about that polish
dies yes
were you asking about my father's
diaries
i've read them and i'm a fan of them i i
mentioned to someone today and i was
coming here that 2000 years from now
when people want to get a glimpse of
inter war and post-war europe that could
be one of the half-dozen things they
read
so um you might get the question at the
end
he would actually just like you to
comment about your father about his
writing and about about his talents in
particular
he kept
a diary all his life
and
when he
entered public life because he was in
the house of commons with churchill and
intimate of churchills
all through the war period
his diary of course has become one of
very great importance and significance
historically
but it was also a diary which
[Music]
was
very human
and it's a mixture of his private and
his public life his reflections upon the
books he read and the people he met and
so on
exactly the diary which
virginia woof encouraged me to keep
and which indeed i've tried to keep
myself
and my father's studies which i
published in
three
volumes
in the what was it the seventies the
sixties to nineteen sixties
uh of course is only a twentieth part of
the whole
the entire diary is three million words
long
and it the the original of it
is now it oxford in one of the college
libraries there
i think it's one of the
best diaries the most interesting
informative and amusing diaries
of the last century
i'm now interested in the diaries in
that part of the of hal nicholson's
diary that hasn't been published and i
wonder it seems to me what's interesting
about
um what you've written about your mother
and father that we do get a sense of
your mother's intimate life if you like
but
i've never been able to get a sense of
harold nicholson's intimate life of your
father's and and um intrigued by that
and and
the different the different people we
know in that sense and and do the
unpublished diaries tell us more about
that
the woman is wondering about the the
portion the unpublished portions of the
diaries whether they reveal a little bit
more about the intimate life of your
father well
of course there was um there were
passages which i
uh
did not publish showing for reasons of
discretion
uh but there were others which were
less interesting as in everybody's
diaries the times of trains the minor
illnesses and things like that
or
long accounts of committee meetings
which will cease to have a great deal of
importance now
so i left all those out i mean when i
was only
doing one twentieth of a hole i had to
be
i don't think if anybody were to go
through it
unless they had a very special reason
like writing the biography of somebody
who my father knew
they would find much
more of interest than i published myself
but
of course people
whose feelings i was saving by not
publishing things about them have now
died in many many cases
and so if i was rarely unkind i would
publish a supplement
well at this point let me invite you to
visit with mr nicholson individually up
here we'll have a opportunity to have
some books on dr newland did sign all
our copies of leonardo da vinci before
he left today so we do have those in the
back of the room and please join me
again in thanking mr nicholson
[Applause]
the two biographies pictured here by
nigel nicholson and sherwin newland were
published by penguin putnam as part of
their penguin lives series
[Music]
48 hours of non-fiction books on tv
25 years
cable's gift to america
in soulmate flesh author carl zimmer
looks at the way the brain has been
perceived throughout history this talk
from the stanford university medical
school is an hour
[Applause]
well uh thanks to everybody for coming
i'm very happy to be here
and um
what i thought i'd do as i start with
this
now speaking at a medical school
obviously i would assume most of you
know what this is but
what i find interesting is that
even if we were outside of a medical
school most people would know what this
is they would recognize a brain
they know what a brain looks like um
everyone does and yet um how many people
outside of a medical school have
actually
uh seen a real brain actually held one
in their hands
while i was working on soulmate flesh i
went up to the columbia medical school
to participate in one of their brain
cuttings because i wanted to actually
have that feeling and it's quite intense
but
i didn't need that experience of holding
a real brain in my hand to know what a
brain is
there's something kind of strange about
this because i mean no one ever sees a
brain in their real life and and not
only
do we all know what this is but we sort
of all agree on what it represents
what we're looking at
is
a collection of cells these neurons that
are
forming networks
and trading signals
and out of that exchange emerges our
emotions and our thoughts our
perceptions and our actions who we are
is
contained in in the flesh of the brain
we are
quite familiar uh
in medical schools and outside of them
with images like this one where
scientists will be scanning mental
activity
and being able to locate
the parts of the brain
that form these networks to do all of
these incredibly abstract things like
for example
mathematics or
memory
now the funny thing is that
this while this all seems kind of
obvious to us
in the history of western thought it's
really new and for a long time it was
not obvious at all
and to really give you a sense of what
i'm talking about i want to show you
this quote from the philosopher henry
moore
henry moore
in the 17th century you probably
couldn't find a greater philosopher in
terms of just pure brilliance maybe
descartes baby lock
that's about it
and in 1652
he declared very categorically that
referring to the brain
this lacks pith or a marrow in a man's
head shows no more capacity for thought
than a cake of suet or bowl of curds
so
how is it that he could say something
like this how could he hold the brain in
such contempt
well
uh one reason is is really
quite simple uh
you know if
like like us um he he would rarely see a
real brain and um if anyone were to try
to look at her brain in 1652 say in a
cadaver
the thing would have become been so
decayed and such a mess that um really
literally what you would be looking at
would be
a bowl of curds
it would hardly be the stuff for for
carrying out what would then be called
the work of the soul
but
also
henry moore is
standing at the end of a very long
tradition of thousands of years of
western thought
that put what we would call the life of
the mind in a totally different world
and with completely different different
explanations they're very hard for us to
understand today
it's fascinating to understand how
people would think in this different way
what i think is even more fascinating is
that
henry moore says this in 1652
20 years later
no one would say this 20 years later
everyone has agreed on the basics of
what the brain means they would agree
with us about what the brain is what the
brain represents
there was this incredible switch that
happened
and this switch actually i think has a
lot to tell us about
what i think is a second revolution
going on in neuroscience today
so
if you are a 17th century thinker in
europe
you have a couple different
major sources that are really dominating
the way you're thinking about what we
would call the life of the mind
there is of course the bible
everything that you talk about
in terms of uh
the way people are in terms of human
nature is going to have to square one
way or another with the bible
now the bible is obviously not a
neurology textbook um
what it really talks about is is the
soul particularly in the new testament
saying that we have this this immortal
soul um that uh will be you know saved
or faced damnation in the afterlife
now it's not entirely clear in the bible
sort of how that soul connects to
our bodies to to the to the world at
large if you will
there are but there are some
interesting ways in which there's this
connection so for example
from the bible there is a long tradition
of considering epilepsy
we consider neurological disorder to be
possessioned by demons or by spirits so
jesus
is in a sense a sort of a neurologist of
his time because he's believed to be
able to cure epilepsy by
ridding a person of their demons this is
a 13th century painting of
of just this event
people believed that
that people called epilepsy as a seizure
because they really believed that there
was something some force
that was seizing a person and shaking
them around and so you had to get that
force
out of that person's body
now
to get
more
of a detailed understanding of
of these things um
a european thinker like a physicist or a
natural philosopher say
or even a theologian would uh go back to
the greeks
now greek thought was um
was incredibly powerful um throughout
the middle ages the renaissance and into
the 17th century
for some really astonishing reasons
one is that
one is that uh
people believed that the earth was just
a few thousand years old
and um
so
what this meant was that
people who lived in ancient greece or
rome were living very close to the time
of creation
and
adam had perfect knowledge and so the
greeks because they were so much closer
to adam had
knowledge and understanding that was so
far superior to our own
so that there was no point in thinking
for yourself because aristotle and galen
um the roman physician they were all
there before you
so what you had to do is you had to go
back into these books which are being
translated from
from arabic and
being sort of put together into
latin translations that people could
actually read in europe
and try to piece together what they knew
now
what they knew
what they thought they knew was that the
body was made of four humors
these humors are fluids that are
different combinations of the four
elements
so you've got um
black bile yellow bile
blood which is not what we think of when
we say blood and phlegm these are the
these are the four things that dominate
a person they don't only dominate your
body but they dominate your your
temperament your personality
so for example um if a person is just
naturally has a lot of
black bile and latin melancholy they're
melancholy
and if you have um an imbalance
of this uh if you have too much
melancholy in your system um you might
become
extremely depressed or even stark raving
mad
so you had to keep people's
humors
in in the proper balance now of course
for a doctor in the middle ages
you know what they would do they would
basically you know
take blood out of people
bloodletting was basically the cure for
everything
but they had these very elaborate
explanations about how bloodletting
would help to bring humors into balance
this is a diagram from from the middle
ages
with illustrations from the middle ages
showing
the um the different kind of
personalities
so the melancholy person is in bed very
sad and
and melancholy
now
this was very powerful uh for many
reasons uh and one of them is
that
to be par to be made up of four humors
linked you to the cosmos
uh there was there was no um
kind of dividing line between your body
and yourself and and the cosmos because
the four humors were the made of these
four elements and not only that but
different
constellations were believed to be
connected to different humors and
because different organs had different
humors in them you would look to
different constellations to understand
what was going on in for example in the
head or in the liver or so on
and that's why doctors would
it was very important to cast a
horoscope
in order to treat someone
then
there were a lot of thinkers who took
this even further
and they kind of followed up on some
ideas of plato and they would say that
we are actually a miniature version of
the cosmos as a whole we are a microcosm
of the macrocosm
so
in a sense this is a very comforting
idea it's very resilient this is an idea
that can last for centuries and it did
very well
now
um the
the cosmos actually was believed to have
a soul and and we were all believed to
have a soul
but
we tend to just talk about the soul
singular when we talk about people's
souls
in the middle ages in the renaissance it
was believed that people had three souls
um
the most important was the the rational
immortal soul which was sort of the
business of the church
um but there was also a mortar soul in
the liver
um now this soul
was believed to produce uh blood it was
also believed to produce our appetites
and our desires
in addition the heart
was believed to have a soul of its own
and this soul this vital soul
gave
the body its life
supporting warmth it sent out what we
call vital spirits
to do its bidding to keep to keep the
body warm and alive and not only that
but it produced passion and produced
action um it was even believed to have
some powers of perception
um aristotle even believed that that the
heart was completely responsible for um
sensation and and action um
and so in the middle ages
uh when um people taught anatomy
they what they were really doing was
they were demonstrating how the body was
arranged for these three souls this
wasn't really what we would call
scientific this was a really
a religious
um kind of
demonstration that was being done this
is a picture of how anatomy was
typically done
you'd have a cadaver usually have an
executed criminal and then a surgeon
would be cutting it open and the
anatomist is up in a chair
reading from galen and telling you
what's in there
um the anatomist would never dare
to go down and actually look for himself
because what was the point galen knew
everything already could explain
everything his knowledge was perfect so
he would simply
use galen's anatomy to explain how the
body was was arranged for these three
souls
now as as weird as this is for us to
think about um it really left a very
deep impression on western thought so
for example
we talk about being heartbroken or
knowing something in our heart
this all comes from this this soul in
the heart this vital soul
and it influenced christianity as well
so there you have the the phenomenon of
the sacred heart
it's very interesting and very telling
that
um
that when jesus is is revealing himself
in these sorts of images
he's not showing us his brain he's
showing us his heart
now it wasn't that people weren't
interested in the head it's just that
they weren't interested in the brain
so here's a diagram from 1504
what really mattered were
what were believed to be
these three giant spherical holes in
your head these are called ventricles
we do have little spaces in our head
they don't look anything like three uh
three circular spherical holes
but people were convinced that they were
there and what they believed was that
the vital spirits of the heart would mix
with air
and then go into the head and become
what we call animal spirits
and they would swirl through these holes
these ventricles and they would produce
a memory or or imagination
and then they would go into the rest of
the body
now
as you can see
what we know to really matter the brain
is just the background in this picture
it's just those little sort of squiggles
um in this picture
uh it's considered completely
unimportant
and it was believed that that
whatever it was doing
its only purpose was to keep these holes
um
enlarged in life
of course when people would cut open a
brain after life they would see see
these kind of funny deformed little
holes but they said well that's because
the person's dead though
they're not being sort of held taut and
open um the way we know that they are
so just to give you an idea of um
how powerful an idea this was um you
consider the case of leonardo da vinci
now here's one of the greatest thinkers
of all time and also a great anatomist
he's does wonderful drawings himself
of
all sorts of anatomical details
now
when he drew the head this is what he
drew
and as you can see
you have this big empty space and then
these sort of very kind of schematic
holes that are supposed to be connected
in a chain
um so
you got to give leonardo da vinci credit
he said to himself okay i want to really
understand what these ventricles are
like so what he did was
he took some hot wax and he injected it
in the brain of a dead ox freshly killed
and
the wax hardened
and then he cut open the head and went
look to see what it looked like and
where it was situated and how it
connected to the nerves and for example
for example
he got a total mess when he opened up
the ox's head um
these these holes were just in all sorts
of crazy directions and um
he he um he was good enough of a
scientist to say all right i'm going to
draw it the way i see it
but then i'm going to try to connect
them and connect them to the nerves
because i know that they're connected i
know that these ventricles are what
matter here
so
so even leonardo da vinci was still prey
to these ideas
now things started to change a bit
um
in the mid 1500s
thanks in large part to the great
anonymous uh andreas veselius
what he did was um he was uh actually
looking at bodies on his own and
realized that galen had been
had made all these descriptions based on
oxen or monkeys or all these animals
and no one had bothered to realize that
he had never looked at a human ever uh
you know maybe he had looked at them
when he was
you know tending to a wound but that was
it so versailles
drew a new anatomy um with these
spectacular pictures um and really sort
of made anatomy a science the way we
think of it in the terms of you know of
something that you could discover
something new about
now vasalis also looked at the brain
what he did was kind of crude to say the
least he would cut off
the top layer of brain and look down and
see what was there and then he'd cut off
another layer and look down and see what
was there he wasn't doing this in a nice
refrigerated room or anything he didn't
have any preservatives so it got to be
quite a mess by the time he was done
but he still did a very good job
considering
and
you know he was really struck by how the
ventricles did not
conform to what the church said they did
and he brought up the subject and
he said maybe we should be thinking
differently about the head and maybe
about the brain but then he stopped
and he literally said that he did not
want to be
taken for a heretic he did not want to
get into trouble
um
so
the
things are stood like that
until there was a kind of a fresh
shock to the system as it were
and it came from a surprising place it
came from the cosmos
it used to be believed that
that the earth was at the center of the
universe at the of the cosmos
and aristotle gave very good
explanations for why i mean
because for example
if you picked up a rock a rock is made
of the element earth
and
the element earth has a natural motion
to go to the center of the cosmos so
that's why when you pick it up and you
drop it it falls back down so this
wasn't just astronomy this was physics
this was just a whole way of thinking
about about the world at large
now in the same year that versailles
publishes his anatomy copernicus
publishes his book
saying that no the sun is at the center
and the earth is just another planet
this doesn't
just throw astronomy into question it
also brings physics itself into into
question
it wasn't until the early 1600s when
galileo really started to to think
carefully about
these two um
implications and try to bring them
together
and uh so
his famous
studies with the telescope
were along these lines he would look up
in the sky and he would see that the
moon was not a perfect orb
it was just a it was a battered rock
made out of the same kinds of materials
that were made here on earth
and so
whatever laws are governing governing
its movements they're also governing
governing movements on earth
so he started to try to think of a new
kind of physics
a physics made of forces
to take aristotle's place
so
there's a natural implication what about
the body
what if instead of these
these mysterious souls and their
mysterious spirits
what if we are dealing with um
just a system of levers for example with
with machines
this is what becomes called the
mechanical philosophy
it's not about building cars it's about
trying to explain the world and
ourselves with physics
now rene descartes the french
philosopher
takes this the next level
um
he is trying to come up with a whole
system of physics to explain the world
and and he's not going to stop at the
body he's going to go right into the
body as well
and he says that you know we really do
not need
to
be talking about
these these souls in the heart or in the
liver we're just going to do without
them we don't need to because everything
that the body does can be explained just
through the
movement of particles sort of bumping
into each other and and producing these
different actions
so for example um when you look at
something it's not that your soul is is
um receiving the form of of an arrow for
example
it's just the physics of it all it's
it's the geometry of your eyes and the
way that the light bounces off of the of
the arrow and goes into your brain
now um
you'll see that little sort of teardrop
uh sort of space there um
i'll i'll get back to that in a second
this is this is where things get a
little funky with descartes
you see it here again this teardrop
shaped space
this illustration is showing how you
could have a reflex movement
without any need for a soul so why is it
that we pull away from a fire is it
because uh some sort of soul perceives
that there's a fire and and produces
this movement no he says it would just
be this automatic system in which
the particles of the fire would
press against the nerve in your foot and
then pull on the nerve
and the nerve would be would sort of be
like a bell rope and it would open up a
hole in the ventricles
and then that would let spirits flow
down through the ventricles and down
through the nerve and then they would
swell up the foot and create a muscular
contraction
it's
obviously a bit crazy to describe but
it's quite brilliant and it really is
the first way of thinking about uh
involuntary movements
now what about that funny teardrop up
there um
that was basically uh the ventricles um
and descartes believed that
the
the rational soul was located in a tiny
little thing the pineal gland which he
thought was located just above the ven
of the ventricles so that
even though the rational cell was
immaterial it could sort of jostle
around
and sort of shunt this this uh animal
spirits in different directions
and uh and that would be able to produce
voluntary movements
um
unfortunately
um
descartes uh anatomy was
really wasn't there to back him up um he
really took great pride in his anatomy
he when people would say um
would ask to see his library he would
take him into a room
where he would have a calf that it was
he had half dissected just lying there
on a table and he would say these are my
books
unfortunately he wasn't reading those
books very well i mean this is his
drawing of a sheep brain i mean we're
not talking about versailles here
and that sort of
kept descartes from really kind of
launching what we would we would call a
real science of the brain of what we
call neurology
it was this man who would do it
thomas willis
is
the person who coined the word neurology
who wrote the first major book on the
brain and the nerves and who established
a lot of
our basic understanding of
how the brain works
most people haven't heard of him
you may have heard of him because of a
set of
blood vessels that were named after him
called the circle of willis
but other than that he's
unfortunately one of the forgotten
heroes of science
i um
i talk a lot about thomas willis in the
book
he was born in 1621
outside of oxford his parents were um
were were poor
and he was able to get into oxford
on what we would basically call
scholarship he would make meals for a
professor
clean up after him um he also worked as
an apprentice to the professor's wife
who was sort of a
an amateur doctor
making various drugs for people who were
sick in the neighborhood
he was very loyal to the
the church of england and to the king
and so when puritans and parliament rose
up
against the king
he took up arms to defend king charles
the first and
oxford actually became
charles's headquarters
and became besieged by parliament um
oliver cromwell would sort of stand in
the hills and be trying to figure out
how to crush the army there in oxford
and thomas willis was up on the walls
defending his king and his church from
from from these uh from these onslaughts
while he was there
william harvey was there as well and
william harvey would have a huge
influence on him
harvey of course um showed that the uh
that blood circulates around the body um
which uh and through is pumped by the
heart which was uh an incredibly radical
idea at the time
and what was even more radical was that
he figured this out and demonstrated it
with experiments so this is an
experiment where he
binds someone's arm and then kind of
moves the blood in their blood vessels
to show
the direction in which the blood is
pumping through the arteries and the
veins
so thomas willis takes from him this
idea of
of anatomy and physiology being these
experimental sciences things where you
can actually do something yourself
what's also very important to consider
is that he was an alchemist
um alchemy sort of has a bad reputation
these days is sort of being on the
losing side of scientific history
but really um
before modern chemistry got started
alchemy was
about as close to what we would call
science as you'd find
in in some cases alchemists were quite
rigorous and they made some really
important discoveries
willis would spend a lot of time in sort
of his um
his own personal laboratory trying to
make
different explosive compounds things
other than gunpowder because gunpowder
was very valuable
and we wanted to find a new new way to
um to you know be able to launch canons
or bullets or so on
um but he also was interested in alchemy
as a doctor
medical alchemy was a really important
tradition
how could you make um drugs that could
transform the body in the same way the
philosopher's stone was supposed to
transform lead into gold
um
the important thing out of all is all
out of all of this is that thomas will
start thinking of the body chemically
descartes tend to think of it as just
all these particles sort of knocking
into each other but
thomas willis was interested in the
transformations the chemical
transformations what he would call the
ferments that happened in the body and
you would think about them in terms of
the brain later on
um
the the
uh the king of course lost the civil war
got his head cut off
and people like thomas willis um
became outcasts so thomas willis worked
as a as a doctor in oxford but had
almost no clientele at all for some
years um and he us
all the
old supporters of the king at the
university were thrown out and lots of
puritans and other people were brought
in
um thomas willis
was sort of a quiet rebel he hosted a
church in his own house
where people could carry out the rights
of the church of england
which was totally illegal at the time
what's important here is that you know
for for
what i would argue is the first
neurologist
religion was central
it was paramount for him and you can't
sort of divide him into sort of science
and religion in the 1600s
that would be meaningless
now what was interesting
about um
the years after the civil war was that
all sorts of interesting people came to
oxford because of all this upheaval and
a lot of them were very much influenced
by francis bacon um the thinker who had
had
he really was the first sort of british
thinker who had argued for what we would
think of as a scientific culture of
national institutions like museums and
hospitals and so on
and he thought of a sort of a utopia
where
scientists would be able to test
hypotheses and and discover new
knowledge and
you know infinite wealth would be
discovered and infinite health as well
um
so among the people who came
were just an astonishing group um so
christopher wren came as a young student
we think of him as an as an architect
but
at the time he was just an extraordinary
prodigy doing all sorts of things he
would build new kinds of telescopes
he developed new kinds of microscopes
and he and robert hook would make these
beautiful drawings
of for example a fly's head things that
people had never really seen before
and
they would make the an argument that
this was a very good argument in favor
of
of life being composed of atoms not of
aristotle's four elements but of atoms
uh different kinds of atoms perhaps but
you know if a fly's head is so
intricately uh designed
then surely
god must be using atoms to do it this
was the kind of language that they would
use
another person that thomas willis got to
know is robert boyle
pretty much the the um one of the
founders of modern chemistry and
he was trying to turn alchemy into a
real science and at the time he was
experimenting with vacuum pumps for
example and showing all sorts of strange
things like for example if you put a
candle in a pump and then pumped all the
air out the candle would mysteriously go
out how would you explain that
so
you have all sorts of incredible things
going on at the time and out of all of
this
thomas willis would invent the science
of neurology
how this happened was that in 1660
king charles ii was restored to the
throne
and everyone who had defended his father
was now
redeemed
so thomas willis was immediately made a
professor at oxford the puritan who had
had the job before was fired opened up a
space and he took over
now he was supposed to go back to
teaching aristotle and all the nice old
stuff that had been um all pretty much
set in stone before uh all the chaos of
the civil war broke out
but he wasn't interested at all he would
teach all of his new ideas that he had
and he did something more he decided
that this was an opportunity for him to
do
something that he said was mapping the
anatomy of the soul
so why did thomas willis do this
it's partly medical and it's probably
religious
willis was a had seen hundreds and
thousands of patients
and had
seen a lot of cases of what we would
call neurological or psychiatric
disorders
he would see people who were hysterical
he would see people he said were
convinced that their bodies were made of
glass or convinced that they were wolves
people he
he wrote about who fell asleep with food
in their mouths
and he was he was this wonderfully
gifted observer
he really gives some of the first
descriptions of say narcolepsy
falling asleep with your food in your
mouth or migraine uh wonderful
descriptions of migraine headaches and
all sorts of other things
and he wanted to cure these disorders
not just to sort of alleviate the pain
that people were suffering
but to save their souls because um
according to his religious outlook um
you you were it was possible for you to
achieve salvation through good acts in
this life but you had to be rational
about it you had to know what you were
doing so if some sort of disease was
clouding your reasoning then
um your soul might not be saved
now wills also knew that all of the
conventional medicine that he had been
taught was all wrong
and he was very excited by all of these
ideas that the scientific revolution was
bringing out
so
so he took harvey's kind of experiments
he took the atoms of alchemy
he used the new instruments like the
microscopes that christopher wren was
using
and he started dissecting brains because
he thought you know i think that brains
need a second look
this is from the
cover of his book that he wrote about
the experience it's called the anatomy
of the brain and nerves and it was the
first book
written about the brain just about the
brain and the nervous system
um
the the the cadaver that you would see
there it might not necessarily be some
executed criminal because thomas willis
could do something that previous
anatomists couldn't he would dissect his
patients after they died
and he would actually be interested to
try to figure out if you could find
anything in their bodies
and in their brains in particular
that he could link with some disease
that they had suffered
so for example
hysteria was literally believed to be
the womb moving up in the body
and as a young doctor thomas willis had
believed this but then he started
dissecting people and finding that
women who had been hysterical had
completely normal uteruses and so that
and other reasons made him think that no
it's not this old explanation of the
womb moving we have to look somewhere
else we have to look in the brain is
where he said
so
um
he was also able to
preserve brains
by putting them in alcohol
and
injecting them with dyes christopher
wren had invented this syringes for for
making injections and so
he was able to see brains in a way no
one had seen before and this is actually
christopher wren's illustration that was
in his book
because christopher wren among other
things was a great medical illustrator
so here you have this gorgeous
illustration um that's so far beyond
anything that had come before
and thomas willis is able to trace out
all the structures of the brain and able
to see how incredibly complex it is not
just on the outside but on the inside so
he sees all sorts of hidden structures
as well
and so um what he decides is that you
know these ventricles just don't matter
he even does experiments where he
injects um
dyes into the ventricles to see where i
go they don't really go anywhere um
and so
he looks at the brain itself
um
he argues that it's the brain itself
where we need to look for for the the
business of the soul
now
what willis argued was that while we
still have this immaterial immortal soul
um we also have what he called the
sensitive soul which um does a huge
amount of stuff
and and when you read willis talking
about the sensitive soul you almost
start to wonder well what's the rational
soul
there for
what do you need it for because the
sensitive soul
which is the brain and the nervous
system can do so much
and willis talks about the spirits
moving around different parts of the
brain to do different things some parts
of the brain are responsible for
involuntary movements he says and some
are for voluntary movements
all these ideas that we sort of take for
granted now but
this was all completely new
and thomas willis also
dissected lots of animals uh dissected
lobsters and oysters he dissected sheep
he dissected dogs lots of dogs
and he could see lots of similarities
between the nerves and animals and
humans
and it was really astonished to see that
monkeys had brains that were very hard
to distinguish from humans
and he being a good scientist said this
means that their sensitive soul is a lot
like ours the more that their brain is
like ours the more they are like us
now obviously we look at it from the
point of view of evolution now
that these are all the products of
common ancestry monkeys have a very
recent common ancestor
with us compared to lobsters for example
now
willis wouldn't go that far
but he was sort of laying the groundwork
there
um
this to to he was still quite
revolutionary even in his own time
and and to get a sense of it i just
wanted to show this this wonderful
picture
this shows the sympathetic nervous
system
um
that the sympathetic nervous system
connects to all the organs of the heart
and the stomach for example and um it's
it's
uh
you can sort of think of it as being
producing what you call your gut feeling
among other things it's
um
these sort of mysterious ways in which
your stomach could turn or your heart
would race or your face would become
flushed um
in the 1500s in the renaissance people
would talk about it
as a sort of a sympathy
between different organs and between the
organs and the rest of the cosmos that
there is this interplay going on
a very mystical kind and that's where
the term the sympathetic nervous system
comes from
we still call the sympathetic nervous
system but we don't think of it the way
they did and that's because of thomas
willis thomas said no it's not this this
mysterious connection
uh this uh this mystical union it's a
network of nerves and he could trace
them and show
how these different organs were
connected both to to each other and then
to the brain
and so
that meant
that
you could also cure people by by
thinking of them as
being a brain and a nervous system with
chemical spirits not some sort of
mystical spirits in them but real
chemical particles that you could
manipulate
um so for example epilepsy
was not being seized by a demon
it wasn't even an excess of some sort of
one of the humors it was
explosions
that were out of control that were that
that were happening at the wrong time in
the wrong place and creating unwanted
seizures
um
a person is melancholy not because they
have too much melancholy in them willis
would say there is no such thing as
melancholy as black bile as a substance
there's something going on chemically in
the body and so if we can alter it
um
we can
cure melancholy
so um i'd argue that you know if you're
looking for where prozac and all that
comes from um it comes from here uh now
obviously thomas willis um
you know he didn't know about prozac i
mean his
unfortunately his medical uh treatments
were pretty awful um even after he made
all these breakthroughs he still led a
lot of blood and um he believed that you
should use a sort of a steel syrup to
cure people of
of melancholy
and in some cases he would come up with
very
modern sounding explanations that when
you think about it really very weren't
very modern at all so hysteria for
example
it used to be believed as i said that
the womb would rise up so traditional
doctors would put a belt
around the body
to keep the womb down
now when thomas willis would treat
hysteria he sometimes would put a belt
around people's body but what he said
was that he was taming these animal
spirits that he was controlling their
movement around
through the nervous system
so um so same cure different rationale
and
i think that that among other things is
an interesting thing to think about in
terms of um
how people today go about
dealing with
with mental disorders and neurological
disorders
um
thomas willis was incredibly influential
and not just in these particular ways i
was talking about um
he
he really sort of made this the brain
the sort of agreed upon thing i mean
everyone very quickly came to say well
yeah the brain is this and the
ventricles
just started to become very unimportant
um you know for us you know death equals
brain death uh that kind of
centralness of of the brain
is thanks to willis and and to sort of
illustrate um just how agreed on the
brain became i like to show this picture
this is from the 1700s
it's a cartoon by by the artist william
hogarth attacking
methodists
methodists at the time were basically
considered insane fanatics
by the ruling class
so here you have an illustration of a
methodist church and the congregation is
swooning
you have the minister
dangling
a witch in his hand to try to scare
people and make them hysterical
there are all sorts of symbols of
hogarth's contempt for these methodists
what's really interesting for me
is what's down in the lower right hand
corner and i'll just zoom in here
what it is it's a brain
there's no little tag saying this is a
brain he doesn't need to put a tag on
because everyone knows what it is
everyone's agreed on what it is and it
really and it has the same position as
christopher wren's brain which sort of
shows you how influential it was
the difference though is that there's a
little thermometer stuck in it and so
this is sort of um
this is reading the the the um
the the fanaticism of these methodists
and you have this scale going from um
from despair to agony to lust to madness
so the methodists are up to madness now
um this is this was a you know the
thermometer of course was a very much a
scientific revolution of reason over
fanaticism um and so hogarth felt
totally um
uh
totally correct in showing this thing
um which gives you a sense of what the
brain had come to represent um i mean he
the the question becomes
would you call a methodist insane
now obviously we would not you would not
go out and do a study of methodists to
see what was wrong with their brain
why is it that we don't do that now and
they might do that then
it's a very complicated issue
and one that's worth thinking about
we have to be careful about what we read
into the brain when we look at the the
image of the brain what do we see there
and thomas willis is a great uh lesson
in this he um made huge mistakes
uh as well as great insights so for
example um he believed like everyone
else
you know every other member of the elite
in england that um
that peasants were [ __ ] um they
wouldn't use that word but they would
say that they were fools or idiots that
they really couldn't understand um
theology or or philosophy or anything
like that
and um they uh
and so thomas willis
would cut open people's brains in order
to understand why this fact was
why it was that peasants were idiots and
so he cut open this is actually an
illustration by christopher wren of
the brain of a boy that willis described
as a fool
from birth and after he died well let's
cut him open and tried to look for signs
of why it was that
that people were stupid
and he came up with lots of elaborate
explanations about how
the brain
had a distorted shape or or that it was
the spirits had a difficult time cutting
paths through uh through the brain
which made perfect sense to him but but
obviously not to us
um
so
so i i think that that um
that that this this remarkable time in
history has has lots of lessons to teach
us and
um you know today
uh we're looking at a really remarkable
kind of mirroring of what was happening
in thomas willis time so instead of
knives
and injections people are using fmri
scanners
but
we still have to be on our guard
because we shouldn't be reading images
reading into these images what we want
to see
these studies are continuing to redefine
what was called the soul in many ways
and in many ways in which we don't yet
understand
so
thanks very much
[Applause]
that was uh every bit of marvelous as
your book itself
we have a few minutes for
questions um actually uh
the c-span is kindly taping this and so
they had asked me if you could uh give
your uh give you a question at the
microphone right behind you
this is very formal huh
well thank you very much for a very uh
erudite and certainly entertaining talk
and accurate in the last 400 years the
history of neurology but i think you
really should change the ancients badly
and let me tell you why
people should know i teach history
medicine in this institution so allow me
to say a few comments people ought to
know that
from ancient times from the time of
classical greece many people thought
that the brain was the most important
organ in the body it was not just from
the 1600s on
and they knew
it's amazing that a lesion the right
side of the brain causes paralysis on
the left side they knew about the
accusation of these fibers in the lower
encephalon
and i think
more important of all you omitted
hippocrates i mean to have a man who in
400
more or less bc is going to write the
following men ought to know that it's in
the brain and the brain alone that we
have our fears our pleasures what we
like what we dislike through it we hear
we see we feel
that's very very important and then he
goes on to say the brain is the most
important organ of the body and then
last but not least that wonderful
statement in the sacred disease where he
says and therefore i assert that the
brain is the interpreter of
consciousness i don't think any
neurophysiologist today at the beginning
of the 21st century could put it better
so i would like to make those comments i
hope you forgive me for being frank but
that's absolutely true and you know that
i mean i'm sure
and
that
should be mentioned yes no i i agree
completely that that should be mentioned
that um yes that that there were that
there were amazing discoveries in
ancient greece and um
uh and and many things that we can look
upon now as being
brilliant insights into into the working
of the brain um
and i do do talk about that more at
length in the book so um
but
a couple things to point out is um one
is that unfortunately a lot of
as
unfortunately a lot of that was lost in
terms of people's understanding in
europe
um that much of that was not appreciated
or followed up on
so the beautiful experiments that galen
did um
did not lead to an experimental science
of of the nervous system it led to a
sort of a very rigid doctrine in in
europe
for centuries
um and
and the other thing is that
in some cases it's easy to read in
uh i i would argue that in some cases
it's tempting to read in to
some of these statements more than
what is there in the sense of
for example
there
uh
there was a whole sense of there being
um
uh pneuma
the this sort of the greek word for for
spirit which is is very different from
from what we understand and um
and so
and and that was really sort of the
central um kind of principle of how
what they would call the brain worked
and um
and and sometimes the connections are
not quite quite there but but your your
basic point i completely agree with and
and as i say i talk about more in my
book
yes
well i also want to thank you for
talking about or bringing to people's
attention the accomplishments of willis
who's one of my personal heroes but but
i think that the story is very
incomplete without at least mention of
the two other great figures of that
moment
which are sydneyham and locke
and in fact
you mentioned the beginning that will is
perhaps unjustly has gone into eclipse
but the reason he went into eclipse is
mainly because of the rise of empiricism
and it shouldn't be mentioned that locke
was both a student of willis and of
sitting ham and he switched his
allegiance from willis to sydney ham
precisely because sidney ham who was
considered the father of modern clinical
medicine
focused on the living and on the
observational powers rather than on
this attempt of willis's to link
alchemy and theory and religious
concepts with um you know the physical
body and i think that perhaps if one
reads willis's
notes of his clinical experiences you
know he kept notes of his on his
patients it's amazing as you pointed out
how little of his findings
uh in the laboratory and in his uh
chemical lab in his chemical experiments
actually translated into practice
in fact the opposite as you mentioned
what hysteria which is he also you
should mention that he was also the
first uh dis discoverer of diabetes for
example
so it wasn't just brain but my point is
that um well this represents a kind of a
blending of a scientific and clinical uh
exploration which has now become the
model for the modern academic clinician
uh which we now have a problem with also
but which you should you know mention uh
the the concept of science versus uh
clinical practice but but sidnerham
simply told locke when he um came to him
after having
been a student of willis at oxford as
you mentioned he was this professor of
neurology at oxford and in fact the only
uh lectures available to us from
willis's time were through lots locks as
a medical student taking these um
classes what i'm making the point now is
that lock who of course became one of
the great philosophers of of empiricism
uh and humanism uh learned those lessons
not from willis but from sydney ham and
when sidnerham first
saw locke as a medical student and locke
wanted to do an apprenticeship with him
he said the first thing you have to
forget is these anatomists
in at oxford who only study the dead we
study the living and if you read the
dictionaries of scientific descriptions
over the 17th and 18th century you will
find willis being
you know demonized for for misleading
the world into the wrong pathway until
of course the modern era so i just
wanted to make that statement i totally
appreciate your your your your spotlight
on willis but willis cannot be seen in
isolation from the rest of it
well just just as thank you very much
for your comments i mean and just as i
had in my book i talked more about sort
of the understanding of the brain in the
ancient world my second and last chapter
in the book is all about
john locke and seidenham
i go into a lot of detail about that
because it is quite remarkable that
you know that thomas willis is so
forgotten i mean i i went to westminster
abbey where he's buried and um
you can go to his stone which has been
um fixed up by some neurologists who
were concerned that had gotten old and
cracked
and i was just sort of standing there i
sort of watching people going by and
nobody even stopped once they didn't
even slow down they were just on their
way to see darwin or newton or all these
other people
and um and i think john locke is in
large part to blame for that you're
right um because he john locke a student
of willis's um
was one of the architects of the
enlightenment and a lot of what he said
was we have to be
totally empirical um and and purely
observational and you know when i talk
about the mind i'm only going to talk
about ideas i'm not going to talk about
where in the brain this all takes place
what's ironic though and i try to point
out in the book is that
john locke sort of took it as a given
that the brain worked in the way that uh
willis said it did he just said well you
know we all agree on that i'm not going
to get in any more detail about that but
then that becomes sort of a
a fundamental foundation on which he
then builds all of his own philosophy
so even as thomas willis gets
sucked under
in the tides of history his ideas really
live on
one last four questions
um
so thank you very much um please i don't
think this is on but
um
in any case um thank you very much i'm
i please forgive me if i've missed
anything um i i didn't hear all of your
talk but i did notice that
um dominant themes in your history and
include a very male centered as well
as a very aristocratic sense of the
development of the science
and i'm very concerned in so far as um
i i understand and i perceive as a
medical student a lot of the culture of
neurobiology as being a fundamentally
about control
and so i'm concerned that um
this doctrine of control and greater
control over ourselves and over our
bodies
has arisen from what is predominantly a
male centered as well as aristocratic
lineage and i'm wondering if you could
comment upon that or perhaps
speak to
a more diverse origin
of this history um and see or to comment
perhaps upon the our modern perception
of science and how um
it it plays upon that
the question in case you weren't able to
hear was that um
just commenting on how this is a very
sort of
controlled uh oriented um
aristocratic-based um
uh i should say ruling class based kind
of uh uh
birth of this science um
and male yes um and you know
that that's all true and that's all um
it's all sort of a
you know the this science is a product
is the birth of the science is a product
of its time and in this time women do
not go to university women do not have
the opportunity to do these things um
and so that and and the scientific
revolution was all about control we will
control the world we will control the
earth we will control our bodies we will
control everything and this is also a
time of course when um britain in
particular is becoming a great empire
we're going to control our colonies
we're going to control our slaves we're
going to do all of this scientifically
for you know for great profit um and so
the all of these ideas are all kind of
there at the beginning and um
some of it's not you know some of the
aspects of that are not pretty and and
may be in need of some revision i mean
another part of the book that i wasn't
able to talk about
addresses your question which is there
was a fascinating exchange that thomas
willis had with one patient of his name
anne conway who's a wonderful figure she
was a great philosopher in her own right
but
but you know had no formal education
she went on to influence
leibniz and other philosophers and she
was a patient of willis's she had these
horrible migraine headaches that he
observed and tried to treat couldn't
help her um
and these headaches actually helped her
to sort of come up with an alternate
philosophy of her own
um she did not divide the world into
just the way descartes might into
soul and sort of dead matter she
believed that everything was soul just
different degrees of soul and um and
that so and it was a a completely
different way of of understanding the
body and the mind and the world um and
you know she said her
this wonderful point she made in a book
she wrote which was
um
long forgotten unfortunately was um
you know
essentially the point she was making is
if if the soul is so distinct from the
body in the world then you know why do i
have these horrible headaches why do i
have to experience them um there is
there's more of a connection
there and so i just find it fascinating
that thomas willis
the founder of a certain kind of uh
way of looking at the brain and the mind
and and conway actually spent a lot of
time together as doctor and patient
thank you very much thanks so much
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
carl zimmer is the author of soulmate
flesh it's published by free press an
imprint of simon and schuster visit
simonsays.com for more information
[Music]
da vinci's michelangelo's rembrandts and
vermeers some of the artistic treasures
stolen from europe by the nazis during
world war ii
robert edsel tells the story of the 350
servicemen and women who were
responsible for protecting and
liberating these and other masterpieces
in his new book rescuing da vinci
this talk from the army navy club in
washington d.c is just over an hour
thank you for being here i want to
certainly thank dan as well as jane
cradoville and chad
for their
wonderful help in getting us all set up
and it's quite an honor for me to be
here for a number of reasons not the
least of which when i sold my oil and
gas exploration business which is best
we can tell was life too
my first life was playing some
professional tennis tournaments and then
i had a period of retooling living in
europe for about seven or eight years
where i was studying art and really just
getting away from all the years i'd
spent building a business and taking
time off and deciding what my next great
uh passion and journey was going to be
and i'll mention a bit more about that
in a minute but i was reading
incessantly it's amazing how much
reading you can do if you don't have a
job
and i was reading about 10 books a week
and one of the books i was reading were
some of the memoirs of of president
eisenhower general eisenhower and it
really in some way impacted me in this
journey that i've been on because i was
at the time about 41 42 and struggling
uh after having taken some time off
trying to figure out how i was going to
get re-engaged from a career standpoint
what i was going to do i was determined
to do something different and i read
with great interest uh his reflections
as a 48 year old man as uh chief of
staff for general macarthur and uh
feeling like he was stationed in the
middle of nowhere and he was so good at
his job general macarthur didn't want to
let go of him and he he kind of seemed
to almost make peace with the fact that
this is what was going to turn out with
his career and then of course uh shortly
thereafter he came back to washington
and the rest is literally the stuff of
legend and
it was an extraordinary experience for
me when i thought about it because it
was a great reminder that uh it doesn't
really matter how old you are there's
still a chance to pursue things that you
love
and follow your great passions and so
there's a great particular affection on
my part about being here this evening at
the eisenhower institute
uh without any further delay let me just
say i sold my business 11 years ago and
when i did i had no idea the path that i
was going to follow the the journey that
i would find in fact i'm not as sure
that i found it as much as it found me
and uh i couldn't have seen the
the profound changes that would occur in
my life from really asking just a few
questions which began
as i was living in portofino
we're going the wrong way here hang on
bear with me one second
i started off in portofino having sold
my oil and gas business and took some
time off and ultimately moved to
florence and i was standing on the ponte
vecchio i'm sure many of you all
recognize this and i went down there one
day
and i was overlooking the panasonic and
for those of you that have been to
florence you may be aware that all the
bridges there in florence were destroyed
during world war ii by the nazis as they
fled the city with the exception of the
ponovecchio and i had this moment of
epiphany where i wondered how in the
world did all these extraordinary works
of art and great monuments in europe
survived the destructiveness of the
greatest conflict in history in fact who
were the people that saved them
and it led me onto this quest that
followed really out of a desire to find
out the answers for myself the book was
an absolutely unintended consequence and
in my effort to try and find information
i was so frustrated and i didn't want to
ask anybody because i felt like i was
going to look like such a fool that i
didn't know what the answer was and
after gathering some information with
great difficulty i did start asking
people and over and over and over again
i had them say to me i don't know who
did save it and it really reinforced for
me the an anonymity of these
extraordinary people known as the
monuments men
of course my journey is not dissimilar
from the journey that these great works
of art took during world war ii you all
of course recognize the mona lisa
perhaps the most famous
image in the world much less work of art
but the mona lisa was moved on six
separate occasions between 1939 and 1945
by museum officials in paris trying to
keep the work of art away from the
invasion of the germans
in fact it was moved initially out of
the louvre it was the only work of art
that had its own form of transportation
it was moved in an ambulance and it was
sealed up inside so tightly with the
curator from the louvre museum that when
they arrived at the first chateau in
chambour the painting was in perfectly
good shape but the museum director fell
out of the limousine fell out of the
ambulance almost had suffocated from the
uh from the absence of any oxygen
well we're going to take a look at those
again
so we have the situation of this work
being moved
and of course this fantastic other work
by leonardo da vinci there are only 14
commonly accepted paintings by leonardo
this is the last supper uh painted on a
refectory wall of the santa maria della
grazia refectory in milan italy
and this painting of course couldn't be
moved or protected
so local museum officials placed
scaffolding on it
prior to the war and in 1940 an aaron
allied bomb landed in the courtyard
destroying three of the four walls of
the refectory leaving the painting
behind the scaffolding this is a photo
of what it looked like prior to the
final boards being put on the front and
i'm frequently asked by people well tell
me what's the connection between your
book and this other book out there that
makes reference to da vinci and i said
well it's very simple
if it wasn't for the rescuing there
wouldn't be any coat
the story that we're going to talk about
tonight involves a lot of the greatest
the greatest theft in history the
greatest uh treasure hunt in history
and in my view really the most uh
outstanding untold story of world war ii
and it's hard to imagine especially for
all of you all who are so literate on
world war ii to imagine that there's any
untold story about world war ii
especially of any magnitude but
i think you'll see
as we go along that this is something
that's been buried here in front of all
of us the story begins really with the
rise to power of adolf hitler and the
nazi party adolf hitler saw himself as
this great artist uh wanting to be
recognized uh and he along with herman
garin had these great ambitions to steal
artworks throughout europe now we know
today these great works of art
rest safely in the great museums of
europe such as the grand gallery in
louvre but it was a very different
situation in 1939
with the news of the non-aggression
treaty between russia and germany museum
directors set into action plans that
they had for years in advance to try and
prepare for these events and in a matter
of 14 days or so museum officials at the
louvre packed more than 400 000 works of
art to try and move them to nearby
chateau and countryside villas to try
and protect them from the germans and
this was the scene that you would have
seen extraordinary works of art such as
the wings of samothrace were wheeled
down the steps
of the louvre
and crated up and moved out
in many cases by local officials as well
as
just volunteers
the extraordinary painting the night
watch by rembrandt at the rights museum
was rolled up like a carpet and moved on
a number of occasions before finally
being placed in a area near moss street
holland
in florence paintings at the pt palace
in the uffizi were packed up much as
they did at the louvre and taken to
nearby chateau and villas however the
david due to its size and weight
couldn't be moved and so local officials
found an extraordinary innovative
solution they entuned it in brick
leaving
this view had you visited the academia
in 1941 the slaves as they're known by
michelangelo and the david entirely
entombed
and in st petersburg this is the scene
you would see today in the dutch gallery
but it was a very different setting in
1941
with the news of the german invasion
into leningrad as these paintings were
packed up more than 2.2 million items
at the hermitage were packed in a matter
of weeks half of them were taken to on
trains to siberia where they set out the
war but the other half had to be
protected at the museum due to the speed
with which the invasion took place it
was too late to get them out
and even at the national gallery in
washington d.c less than a month after
the bombing of pearl harbor museum
officials here were concerned about some
of the great works of art at the
national gallery and 71 works were
packed up in the dead of night and taken
by train and truck to the biltmore
estate nashville north carolina
where they sat out the war
and all this took place because of the
great ambition of one man adolf hitler
with his rise to power
hitler was determined to use art as a
weapon of propaganda he looked at art
and
determined certain artists in his view
were painters of degenerate art these
were jews slavs immigrants
painters that he believed couldn't see
nature as it existed and he was
determined to remove those works of art
from the german museums many of which
were sold many more were destroyed
all in an effort to try and reinforce
these racial theories of hitler and the
nazi party
this is a painting that's in the fog
museum today a self-portrait by van gogh
that was purchased by an american
collector at one of the sales of these
works of art that came out of the german
museums now hitler was a fairly
pedestrian artist he had some talent
this is a watercolor that he painted one
of many such paintings but imagine this
painting at the time of the great german
expressionists that were painting a
kandinsky uh modigliani other painters
feinger and it didn't have the the
cachet and the interest that people had
and hitler had applied as a young boy a
young teenager to the academy of fine
art in vienna and he was rejected by a
group of jurors whom he believed were
jewish
and it no doubt fueled his rise for his
towards anti-semitism as well as his
determination to show the world what a
great creative mind he had so one of the
paths that he intended to pursue was to
redesign the town he was from in lynn's
austria and at the centerpiece of the
city would be the world's greatest
museum known as the fuhrer museum this
is him working with architects drawing
an actual drawing by hitler that they
then designed scale models after
and of course the world's greatest
museum would have to have the world's
greatest works of art and therein began
the foundation for the
theft that took place
hitler at less than a month before his
suicide this is a color photograph taken
of him and his bunker staring at the
scale model of lens and the museum and
he would look at this thing with the
sound of russian artillery pounding the
right chancellery hour after hour and
explained to guests and visitors how
excited how extraordinary this museum
was going to be right down to the bitter
end
his
interest and knowledge of art really
started with these state visits that he
would make as fewer first to venice in
1934 and then later to
florence rome naples in 1938 and then
again in 1940 this is a photo of him
with mussolini in the villa borges in
1938 and he went on to the the uffizi
palace and walked through the uffizi
with mussolini behind him and mussolini
was heard to be uttering under his
breath tutti questi quadri in italian
all these pictures because he'd seen it
so many times before but hitler and the
others that were with him were really
quite fascinated
this is a book that i held in my hands
when we were doing some of the research
in krakow poland that says in german
artwork safeguarded and you learn very
quickly in doing research that's
safeguarded as a word that you see used
over and over and over by the germans
that stands for robbed stole threat
and many of the other forms that they
used to try and legalize their process
of confiscation and these books would be
assembled by german museum directors and
other organizers that were involved
whose responsibility was to steal these
works of art and they would include in
them photographs of works of art that
had been stolen and they would send them
to hitler and he would flip through
these things much as a male or cat a
mail order catalog making decisions
about which paintings he wanted to have
his in his own collection and the fear
museum of which paintings might go into
some of the new regional museums that
would be built all in an attempt to try
and diminish vienna's cultural hold over
austria this of course is a painting of
the lady with an air mine one of the 14
paintings by leonardo da vinci and the
painting on the front cover of the book
rescuing da vinci
gearing had this great ambition to be
seen as a as a renaissance man and one
of the things that strikes me so much
about this story is
i've yet to come across a photo of
seeing general bradley general pat
general eisenhower in civilian uniform
out doing or civilian clothes out doing
anything and you see gary so many times
in his multiple number of uniforms or in
civilian clothes out shopping is is this
the case in 1940 in amsterdam
shopping for watches
he made 22 separate visits to
the zhidupon museum in paris adjacent to
the louvre where artwork had been
assembled from all the jewish households
and other families who'd had artwork
robbed by a group called the er it was a
formalized group of the germans that was
had as its responsibility stealing works
of art
and their excuse when later on pressed
to provide explanation was well we
didn't steal these things we safeguarded
them and in the process of trying to
explain that they said there were all
these jewish households in paris where
the inhabitants were gone and there was
no one there and of course they were not
safe there so we confiscated them and
took them for protection well of course
the jews weren't there because they had
loaded them up and placed them on trains
to take them to concentration camps and
they considered these things ownerless
objects so they passed laws to say that
ownerless objects were things that
they were entitled to take to try and
make it legal
artworks over the course of time became
the preferred gift among nazi leaders in
fact
all of the leadership of the nazi party
was encouraged to collect artwork such
as this painting that hitler and gary
are sharing
enjoying but their ambitions so quickly
exceeded just artworks it included more
than 5000 church bells from churches
throughout europe that the allied forces
found
taurus scrolls more than a thousand
taurus girls piled ten feet high this is
an american chaplain
standing on these sacred parchments
trying to understand what they are and
where they came from to begin the
process of trying to figure out what to
do about it
stained glass from cathedrals throughout
europe this is stained glass from the
extraordinary cathedral in strasbourg
that was taken and found an assault mine
by
monuments men in heilbrunn germany
thousands of libraries millions of books
from libraries throughout europe and
russia
common household items millions of
pieces of furniture that were shipped
back to the eastern countries and even
the trolley cars from the city of
amsterdam that were placed on this
flatbed train and ultimately found by
the allies and returned to the city
so very quickly the scale of the theft
really turned out to be staggering
so it leads us to this story about who
were these people who were the monuments
men who were the people that saved all
of this
and this is really where the story has
taken such a personal interest for me as
i've continued to dig into it
and get to know some of these surviving
people
and in 1941 in march at the dedication
of the national gallery of art president
roosevelt had the following to say
to accept this work today
is to assert the purpose of the people
of america
that the freedom of the human spirit and
human mind which has produced the
world's great art and all its science
shall not be utterly destroyed
now president roosevelt and the other
allied leaders including general as
eisenhower and patton and marshall
general ma eisenhower and marshall in
particular understood the importance of
having respect for and appreciation of
different cultures and
it gave rise to the creation of an
organization called the roberts
commission named after supreme court
justice owen roberts and general
eisenhower in 1943 issued an order to
the field that said today we're fighting
in a country which has contributed a
great deal to our cultural inheritance a
country rich in monuments which by their
creation helped and now in their old age
illustrate the growth of the
civilization which is ours we are bound
to respect those monuments so far as war
allows
and that was issued just before the
invasion of sicily
and general eisenhower general marshall
both understood the power of impressions
and the importance
of it appearing that we were sensitive
in trying to protect these things museum
directors and curators in the united
states early before the united states
entry into the war gained access to the
white house and explained the potential
pitfalls for the united states and
sooner or later having to enter this war
and the invasion that would occur the
damage to cultural monuments and the
prospects of us winning the battle so to
speak and losing the war of public
opinion by destroying so much of western
civilization so it gave rise to the
creation of this commission the roberts
commission and a group organized called
the monuments fine arts and archive
section or mfa a the people that were a
part of it were known as uh the
monuments men by their fellow gis and it
was a group of museum directors curators
and art historians who volunteered for
service during world war ii there were
about 350 of them from 12 nations about
70 percent were american they included
women
and they were brought in because of
their experience and having worked with
art many of them were already
some were naval reserve officers that
were called up
and it was the first time in history an
army had attempted to fight a war on the
one hand and mitigate damage to cultural
treasures
on the other
and they began by taking aerial
photographs of the great cities and
important
places in europe and designate
targets that had to be avoided by allied
bombers this is a photograph of the city
of florence and you see the arno river
running through the city and you can
probably see the various bridges
crossing it
they also did other things they were out
there on the field on the front line
these weren't back office people they
were at churches such as this church in
belgium helping belgium helping to to
restore glass that was damaged helping
to recover monuments that were blown off
the top of churches in the normandy area
in many cases by allied bombing but as
these damages occurred these monuments
men were there on the spot trying to
work with local townspeople to do what
they could do to affect temporary
repairs
they uh arrived at battle scenes such as
this this is monuments man walker
hancock on the front left side helping
the local townspeople in laglese belgium
remove this sculpture called the madonna
of locales which was taken out of a
church there was an artillery round that
went straight to the side of the church
during the battle of the bulge and they
took this thing out and put it in a
place of safe keeping so these actions
engendered so much good will towards the
people in europe and of course
ultimately return so many of these works
of art this is a scene of americans uh
the monuments officers returning works
of art to the piazza cenoria in florence
uh works that had been taken out of the
official pity palace by nazi soldiers
the propaganda of the nazis was
extraordinary there were masters at it
in fact i'm not so sure different than
some of the things that we see today in
our struggle to fight uh
terrorism and
this is a pamphlet was put out by the
germans called laguerre controllarte the
war against art and it characterizes
americans as barbarians arriving on the
shores to try and steal the cultural uh
patrimony of europe and so i think it
was understood by the american
leadership the importance of trying to
combat that kind of propaganda by making
earnest effort to protect these things
the focus of the monuments men of which
there were only a couple there were only
a dozen or so by the time of the
landings in normandy uh was on initially
trying to protect monuments in buildings
and churches but by the time they
arrived in the great cities in germany
beginning with the town of aachen this
is the cathedral in aachen the the scene
of devastation was so severe that the
focus shifted towards movable works of
art
and they started to find these things in
the most extraordinary places more than
a thousand hiding places in salt mines
and castles and caves this is a photo of
british monuments officers in barton
road of germany
i'm sorry in grassland in germany
finding
hundreds of paintings lying on the floor
of the salt mine that had been placed
there by the nazis
now you may recognize this castle it's
in nuschwanstein in southwest bavaria
and it was the model for disneyland but
during world war ii it was a
chief hiding place for so many of the
great works of art that were stolen out
of paris by the nazis
you turned the volume up
[Music]
i was a great part of the ark treasures
stolen by the nazis
not content with robbing people of their
freedom and their lives the nazis tried
to make off with their symbols of
culture
[Music]
the scope of the theft that has been
going on became more and more and more
aware
in knowing schweinstein it was just
one room after another of paintings
household items
silverware
number of objects that had been
taken from the victims
in france
were measured into the thousands
that's monuments man harry etlinger i
call him the baby of the group he's 82.
harry's a fascinating guy he was the
last boy to have a bar mitzvah in
karlsruhe germany before crystal knocked
and his family came home and said we're
moving tomorrow and they came to the
united states and in 1943 he was drafted
into service in 1944 he went to europe
and fought as a young man and then when
they realized he was a native german
speaker they pulled him out and put him
in the monuments fine arts and archive
section he became a monuments man
fascinating guy
and this was the scene this is on the
steps of the castle at nishwenstein the
man standing there in the center is jim
rohrmer who later went on to become the
director of the metropolitan museum of
art in new york city and so many of
these monuments men and women had
distinguished careers not just before
the war but after the war in addition to
these remarkable things that they did
during the war so this was the scene
that was faced with and it was really an
extraordinary experiment it was the
first time anyone had tried to to
protect cultural treasures like this
there weren't really any handbooks the
ingenuity and creativity of these
monuments men and women were their guide
and those who were able to act were
empowered to do so so they began by
removing these works of art now so many
of these things aren't they aren't
obscure works of art they're things
everybody knows this is of course
botticelli's extraordinary prima vera
painting which is at the affected
gallery that was found on the floor of a
villa
and it was unable to be stolen by the
nazis because it was so large it
wouldn't fit into the truck this is
monuments man dean keller standing next
to the painting
of course i've mentioned leonardo da
vinci's lady with an air mine one of
three portraits one of fourteen
paintings which was found on the
possession of one of the nazi generals
when we arrested him and it was
ultimately restituted to krakow poland
to the family from whom it was taken and
this is monuments officer carroll
striker a polish monuments officer and
standing on his left to your right is
monuments man
frank albright and that took us about
six months to find out and identify who
that guy was
he had a
interesting career as a museum director
after the war we had to enlist the help
of a genealogist as we continue to do
this research we still don't know the
names of the soldiers on either side and
we continue this is the book's done but
the research continues on we're trying
to find out the names of all the people
in these photographs and all the
monuments men and i know someday
someone's going to come up to me and say
that's uncle bob
and when i ask them why they haven't
told us they're going to say because
nobody ever asked
so part of our process is visibility to
find these people and the answers are
out there this of course is a
self-portrait of rembrandt that was
found in the salt mines in heilbrunne
heilbronn germany by monuments man harry
etlinger that's him there standing on
the right and monuments mandal ford on
the left
one of two paintings by vermeer stolen
by hitler
this is the artist studio which was
found in assault mine in out also
austria about 45 minutes from salzburg
the extraordinary
gint altarpiece by john van ike from
ghent belgium which was stolen by the
nazis
and it was found also in altas a by
monuments man george stout that's the
central panel there and you see the
other pieces leaning up against the wall
these salt mine entrances i've been in
they're about this wide in some cases
not quite as tall as i am and it they're
back a mile deep into the ground it's
just extraordinary to imagine how they
were able to take all these things in
really
in many cases uh very hurriedly and the
difficulty our guys faced and trying to
figure out what do you do in a situation
like this there was no handbook for
trying to rescue and recover art found
in these kinds of circumstance and this
is a sculpture by michelangelo the
bruges madonna from bruges belgium which
was found wrapped in a burlap sack
along with more than six thousand other
paintings and works of art destined for
hitler's museum also founded although
say that's monuments man george stout
there in the center
now they didn't find just works of art
they also found gold in fact they found
a lot of gold this is the salt mine in
murkers germany
and
lead forces general patton's army found
some old women walking down the road and
they heard them talking hurriedly about
the comings and goings in the middle of
the night by some german soldiers and
they went over to this assault mine
entrance and saw it had recently been
mortared up and they knocked a hole in
it and stuck their flashlight in and
were almost blinded by the reflection
off these gold bars and what they found
was the equivalent of fort knox buried
underground the entire reichsbank gold
reserves paper currency silver etcetera
along with many of the great art
treasures from the berlin museums which
had only months before been evacuated
out of berlin this is one of the great
works by eduard manet that was found by
american gis and placed on top of this
salt cart and you really get to see an
idea of the narrowness when you look how
narrow that card is but this was
repeated over and over and it leads to
the photograph
of the generals as we refer to it
in my office generals eisenhower bradley
and patton who on april 12th
left uh shafe headquarters at the
schoolhouse and reams
a month before the war is over and
started their day visiting the first
concentration camp liberated by american
forces at ordruff and then went to
murkers because they wanted to see all
of this for themselves and of course
later that day came the news in europe
of the death of president roosevelt so
it was quite a day april 12 1945.
who are these monuments men how in the
world have we made it this far without
knowing anything about them and i
certainly am the first to put my hand up
in the air and say i knew nothing about
them either
this is monuments man langdon warner and
you all probably don't know who he is
but you're probably going to recognize
who portrayed him in a movie
and langdon warner was this really
interesting guy was a professor and
museum
director he really didn't like being in
the office he liked being in the field
he lived in china japan over in asia and
he was very interested in asian art and
was responsible for
forwarding various pieces that could be
bought back when these things traveled
more easily to some of his students that
worked at particular museums at the
nelson atkins in kansas city in the
great museum in cleveland which accounts
for their extraordinary asian art
collections
but he went to the war department in
1945 and explained the importance of two
cities in japan nara and kyoto that were
the cultural historical centers of the
country and the fact that if we had any
hope of japan ever getting back on their
feet when the war ended we had to avoid
destroying those two cities and in fact
efforts were made to retarget those
cities away from some of the fire
bombing that was taking place
that's not a good sign
and
and in both of those cities there are
monuments to langdon warner for having
saved the cities so he was a really
really important fellow
but there were other monuments officers
and uh those of you been to new york to
the new york city ballet
oh we just had it unplugged that's a
simple solution we hope new york city
ballet anybody been to new york city
ballet
monuments man officer lincoln kirsten
was the founder of that he was a private
first class who was empowered much as
these monuments officers were to be able
to post various buildings as with no
bulletin signs in fact general patton
had this great desire to have of all
buildings in munich that weren't
destroyed
the nazi party headquarters and hitler's
office were two buildings that survived
the bombing of munich and he had a great
desire to have that uh that'll work from
there to have that for his office and
this private first cast lincoln kirsten
was able to post a no building sign on
it and prevent general patton from
having access to the use of this
building because they had plans to use
it as one of the collecting points where
all this art was being brought in that
was being found in these salt mines
rose valla an extraordinary heroine from
france who was a museum curator at the
louvre and was assigned to the jedopov
museum and unbeknownst to the german she
spoke fluent german and during the day
when she would see all these works of
art come in from more than 50 000 homes
that were looted in paris she would go
home at night and enter into this secret
diary that she kept paintings that she'd
seen and what families they came from
and ultimately turned that over to some
of the american monuments men when they
arrived and they proved of invaluable
help in tracking down many of these
great works of art in some cases she
even had the shipping invoices
carol streicher one of the great polish
monuments officers holding the lady with
an air mine
jeffrey webb who was the senior adviser
to general eisenhower he treated the
monuments uh section and the protection
of artworks no differently than he did
the management of the war he made sure
that his right hand person to cultural
issues was a british soldier jeffrey
webb as well as this photo which i love
dearly of leonard wooley one of the
world's great archaeologists standing on
the right
this was a photo i'd run out of pages to
use in the book i came across it late in
my research and i was determined to use
it so we shrunk the print on the last
page to find a way to fit it in there
this is a photo that was taken about
1913 in mesopotamia modern-day iraq and
it was on a dig that took place and the
fellow standing over on the left is is a
t uh is lawrence arabia
t.e lawrence that is exactly right
lincoln kirsten i mentioned founder of
the new york city ballet tom howe
the director of the museum of legion of
honor in san francisco both before and
then again after the war
otto whitman director of the museum in
toledo
lawrence sickman director of the nelson
atkins in kansas city sherman lee
director of the museum in cleveland
sherman lee was a monuments officer who
served in japan
andrew ritchie was the director of moma
james roarmer i mentioned director of
the met
and charlie parkhurst who is one of the
senior curators here at the national
gallery of art in washington and a
recent photo from my visit with him a
few weeks ago
now i've
been traveling around meeting these
monuments men as we find them i go and
talk to them and i interview them and
i'm always interested in hearing their
stories so much of which we have i
showed the clip of the film earlier
we'll have one other clip that is a
courtesy of this outstanding group of
filmmakers i've worked with in
california called actual films and
they've been involved in helping uh
they've they've been the the key in
putting together a documentary uh based
on uh one of your uh citizens here lynn
nicholas who wrote an outstanding book
called the rape of europa in 1994 and it
was one of my objectives to time bring
that story to life and and tell it
through the power of photographs in film
and uh they were kind enough to make
available some of this footage that we
could include today this is monuments
man ken lindsey on the right and also on
the left he was involved in the recovery
of artworks that went to the collecting
point in wiesbaden and the bust of
nefertiti one of the most important
works of ancient times that was in his
custody
so i ask often times the questions of
these monuments men as i interview them
and the question i'm really eager to ask
is is art worth a life is it worth the
efforts that we've been through to try
and protect these things i've spent so
much time reading
other interviews they've given and doing
a lot of research in many cases some of
them being older or don't have a lot of
recall about the specific events but
they're all quite able to tell me their
views on that such an important topic
like that and in 1941 4243 during the
horrible 900 day blockade in in saint
petersburg and leningrad at the time
with all the deaths the museum directors
and curators had to live inside the
museum at one point there were several
thousand people living inside the museum
and this is a plaque that's on the
employees stairway stairwell wall
in tribute to the 46 employees who died
during the blockade trying to protect
the great works of art at the hermitage
in fact many of them died of starvation
and due to the horrid circumstances of
the winter and the hardness of the
ground and the constant artillery coming
in from the nazis many of them had to be
laid in the courtyard
during winter time until the spring thaw
came and they could be taken to the
cemetery
there were two monuments officers that
lost their lives during world war ii one
was ron balfour
and he was a british officer that served
with the first canadian army and on the
news of his death uh one of his senior
officers wrote it's a great and
unexpected blow he had written only the
day before so cheerfully delighted with
being at the front that he was killed in
action
we're actually engaged in saving some of
those works of art which he loves so
much
the other fellow killed was walter
hutchhausen walter hutchhausen was in
germany he was in april of 1945 went to
find a report of looted art and found
himself disoriented and behind enemy
lines and uh some machine gunners jumped
up and shot him and david finley who
later became director of the national
gallery wrote to his mother the american
commission has learned with the deepest
regret of the death of your son captor
captain walter hutchhausen captain
hutchhausen was in the opinion of this
commission one of the outstanding
monuments officers in the field
and his work in the valley of the loire
and at aachen will remain as a signal
contribution to the cultural
preservation of europe his knowledge of
germany made him uniquely fitted for the
work there and his loss is an
irreparable one now just to give you a
sense of how
this story is a living breathing story
the other day i got a letter from a lady
named
mrs keck whose husband was a monuments
officer since deceased sheldon keck one
of the great restorers in this country
and what i told you about walter
hutchhausen's in the book that's what we
knew when we uh went to press and she
told me about her life living as a
student in nazi germany up until 1932-33
and she told me that her husband sheldon
was walter hutchhausen's best friend and
how one day
he and her husband sheldon had gone off
to check out a report of stolen art and
walter was driving and he'd gotten
disoriented and found themselves behind
enemy lines and some german machine
gunners jumped up and shot at the
vehicle and killed walter in walter's
body shielded her husband's body and
saved his life
and that's a story we didn't know
so this is the kind of of things that
happened to us pretty frequently with
people contacting us telling us stories
that unfortunately will go with them to
their grave in and of themselves
sometimes they're not critically
important but each piece helps provide
the fabric of the overall story and
we're so interested in hearing it now
i've also talked to monuments men about
this issue of his worth of life and i
asked harry ettlinger one day you know
is art worth the life and harry looked
at me and he said
cathedrals
and i said cathedrals i love this coming
from a jew could you please explain and
he said well think about what happens in
cathedrals and i said okay walk me
through it and he said well families are
created in cathedrals people get married
there's baptisms people take safe haven
in cathedrals and i said okay i'm with
you and he said well
because they had to fly lower and i said
i'm still not following he said because
the american pilots and allied bombing
pilots started flying missions in some
cases during the day where they could
see where the churches were to avoid
hitting them and in fact we have photos
in the book
that i'm sometimes asked about because
it's somewhat of a departure from the
artwork about why do you use a photo of
frankfurt there's that one church there
in the center and everything else is
destroyed and i say well i use it to
make the point that that church might
also have been destroyed too but for
effort to try and avoid destroying it
i also asked bernie taper the question
is art worth a life i visited with
bernie in berkeley california and here's
what bernie had to say in his own words
i remember having a very boozy
discussion with stuart leonard and
berlin apartment one night
which is a more value a work of art or a
human life
and i would say human being
and we're saying we're lower
since we had no drink never done
everything
and i said
well would you give your life
to save
chartres cathedral
and he said sure
and then he said
and actually i had that choice to make
because
there were bombs placed around charlotte
cathedral but
i
as a bombing supposedly
we came in the shower and i was the one
that hadn't
had to take them and
disposed
he won his argument that way
i read a quote last year
and it was amazing how
providence sometimes seems to match you
up with the right piece of information
at the right time i was very very
frustrated because it was june 6
2006 42nd anniversary of d-day invasion
in the new york times sad to say the
paper in my city dallas morning news and
so many other papers across the country
made absolutely no mention of it being
the 62nd anniversary of the d-day
invasion
and this really struck me because of the
effort of my effort to try and get out
and recognize these monuments men and
women who've never been recognized or
honored by
this country on a formal basis and not
known by people throughout the world and
it's been a tremendous source of
frustration for me
uh
and i wanted to make sure
that um
this thing's jumped around again so
could you perhaps take a look and see
let me continue on i wanted to make sure
that this story was known
and in an effort to try and do that i
thought we're going to find every
possible way to communicate to people
this story using every medium we can
find and it started this effort to try
and uh make sure that
the story was told using film so we
started off with this documentary the
rape of europa which i'll tell you all
about briefly in a minute and
i mentioned this quote by john kennedy
and the fact that it was an important
issue for me because i'd spent time in
normandy it was one of the first places
i took my two-year-old son when we went
over there in 1996
and i tried to explain to him as much as
you can a young boy nine 9 387 americans
gravestones there and the important
sacrifice that was placed and it was
important for me to make sure that that
memory wasn't forgotten from my son
and it's been equally important with
respect to the role of these monuments
men to make sure that people know about
what they've done not just americans but
people throughout the world
so it's led us into these various areas
of beginning with trying to create an
accurate list of all the monuments men i
think during the war no one had any idea
what they were faced with in the first
time experiences of finding artworks
hidden in all these various places so
we've developed a list we took the list
that existed and have updated them we're
writing biographies on each one of these
people we have about 150 we haven't
identified yet but the research goes on
day by day uh i mentioned we've found 15
living monuments men i've interviewed
all of them but we are really in a race
with time and it was underscored for me
on november 11th of all days when lane
fazin who was a member of the oss art
looting investigation unit aliu someone
who interrogated gehring who was in
charge of
he and two other officers two other oss
officers writing reports to explain this
whole theft and try and unravel what the
motivations were and i met with lane a
week before his 99th birthday he was a
great art history professor at williams
college where he educated so many of the
museum directors in this country and he
died 10 days later on veterans day
november 11th and then craig hugh smythe
who was the monuments officer
responsible for setting up and creating
the very first collecting point in
munich germany which was in ironically
the nazi party headquarters that was the
building they used and all these
artworks were brought in from places all
over the
uh areas of germany and austria where
they were finding them and i met with
craig in december and he died a couple
weeks afterwards he was 91 years old
we've worked with several people in
congress i'm proud to say congresswoman
kay granger from fort worth and louise
slaughter from new york to introduce a
resolution into congress resolution 48
to formally recognize the monuments fine
arts and archives section and the
officers and we've now begun discussions
uh and working on targeting the same
type proposal for the senate it's the
first of a number of steps i'd like to
see take place but it's the first and
obvious place to begin and this was a
recent meeting we had to announce this
resolution in december of last year in k
granger's office with monuments harry
monument harry etlinger of course i
wrote the book rescuing da vinci which i
had to self-publish because the various
publishing companies that i spoke with
felt like people don't want to hear this
story it's an old story it's not a
modern day story and i said
you don't see the parallels with what
we're dealing with in iraq and anyway
they didn't really want to have anything
to do with it but i felt it was
important and i believed people not just
in this country but throughout the world
would be fascinated if it could be told
in terms that we're so used to using
today which are visual and there were so
many photographs out there that hadn't
been pulled together and it was an
exciting part of the adventure for me i
mentioned the rape of europa which uh
actually will be shown at the national
gallery this upcoming sunday uh in the
afternoon
it's been an effort in mind to try and
make sure we have showings for free at
various museums these monuments men had
such an important role in helping to
build after they came home from the war
and i think it will be in theaters
sometime in the late spring
and will run its course from a
theatrical standpoint so we're very
excited about that the film's narrated
by joan allen it was shot in seven
countries five languages uh and was a
labor of love by the filmmakers actual
films and i'm a co-producer of the film
we spent a lot of time in europe and all
these places in the salt mines so
imagine in closing if you will a world
with no paintings by leonardo da vinci
uh museums without artworks libraries
without books and this was the very real
circumstance that the allied forces
confronted in germany during world war
ii
and it has led me to
be focused on trying to find ways to
educate and help illuminate the message
about what took place during world war
ii so we can try and learn from it so
we're in the process of setting up a
foundation called the monuments
foundation monuments men foundation for
the preservation of art and i wanted to
do several things including get a copy
of this book in all the libraries and
school libraries throughout the country
i'm also interested in creating a
monuments men award each year to
recognize both people and
groups that go to extraordinary work to
try and protect artworks as well as we
have a role in trying to help as an
interlocutor and introducing people that
are looking for missing works of art or
people that have works of art or other
important documents that don't know how
to go about getting those things back
home so it's a important role and
something i'm excited about continuing
on this is such a current day story
because there's hundreds of thousands of
works of art still missing worth
billions of dollars restitutions are
announced practically every week
but people don't understand the broad
context in which this is all happening
and this is a chance for all of us to
have a front row seat as we watch this
final chapter of history be written this
is perhaps one of the most famous
paintings that's still missing a
painting by raphael portrait of a
gentleman which was stolen from the
museum in krakow along with leonardo and
this is the frame in which it was taken
out of that hangs on the wall hoping for
the day that this painting is returned
to the museum now i'll briefly mention
iraq we know in 2003 there was a report
of looting of the museum of iraq and
baghdad the initial reports where there
were 170 000 missing items and sadly uh
our country's response to that by people
on the ground was really and it evolved
to secretary of defense regardless of
who it was in this case saying bad
things happen during war people do loot
and of course that seems somewhat of a
given but the impression that it created
was very devastating and in the course
of time as the research continued
after we had our people there on the
ground this is colonel bogdanus who was
a real hero in the process he brought
together a group that was tried to track
down many of these missing works of art
and had a success but in the course of
researching it we discovered in fact
there were more like fifteen thousand
works of art stolen fifteen thousand of
course is not an insignificant number
and these are very very important works
of art not just to iraq but to the whole
history of civilization but at the same
point in time it begged the question for
me of how is it that during world war ii
in the face of a truly world war over a
six-year period
this 350 men and women of the monument
section were able to help find
locate and ultimately return
millions millions of cultural items to
the countries from which they were
stolen and clearly it underscored for me
that the lessons were lost and uh it's
my commitment to try and maintain this
legacy
and help others understand that during
world war ii we got it right and that
americans do care about these things and
that protecting these cultural treasures
are important for all of us
so i want to just say back to the
question i ask is art worth a life to me
when we think about these things the
history of these things such as this
british monuments officer standing
looking out over the destroyed bridges
in florence are important because we
want to go there with our kids as i do
with my son who still lives in florence
today
you know the great uh museums of the
world i think museums uh private
collections
churches these works of art don't exist
and aren't owned really i think they
exist for the benefit of all mankind
they're there for the fruitful enjoyment
of everybody and as such i don't think
it's just a responsibility of the people
that have possession of them it's all of
our responsibilities to try and protect
these things and i think we do it
because we want our kids to be able to
enjoy those creative moments that
fantastic uh spark of curiosity and
creativity that we've been able to enjoy
as we go and visit these museums i think
art serves as a guidepost for who we've
been and helped provides instruction
about who we're becoming as a
civilization so when i think about that
question is art uh worth a life in my
view their inseparable art is life
thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions
yes sir
the post of nefertiti that you put up
raises a question in my mind
what's the flip side of this about the
art that was in germany during the war
was there any what happened there was
there an attempt to plunder that was
there another
uh set of forces at work that made sure
that things didn't go wrong on that end
as well because that bust i think is now
back in berlin in fact you're absolutely
right it is in berlin and ironically was
just returned to the museum where it was
originally housed prior to the war on
museum island which is now reopened as
the german government's been able to
restore these museums to their pre-war
glory
the
works of art from many of the museums in
germany were placed in salt mines in
some cases mixed in with other works
that were stolen by german museum
directors ironically the great works
from the berlin museum such as best of
nefertiti and that painting you saw by
eduard manet were works that were sent
there only a few months before the end
of the war
the museum directors in germany had made
ongoing requests to the fuhrer to
evacuate those works and he considered
such conversation defeatism
and i'm convinced at the last minute
they finally just decided we're going to
put them in trucks and send them anyway
and many of the works of art that were
too large to fit into the mine entrances
had to be
tried to sit out the war in berlin some
were placed in these flak towers or or
artillery towers
later
which had fires and many of the
paintings if not all of them were
destroyed so i don't think there was
looting on the part of of the german
museums but for the experience with
russia at the end of the war and
certainly the russians uh coming into
the eastern part of germany uh went home
taking everything that wasn't attached
light bulbs toilet seats paintings file
cabinets and everything in the file
cabinets which is why so many of these
secrets are starting to come available
today because now with the fall of
communism one of four key reasons that
these mysteries are going to start to
get solved people are going through
those file cabinets that are sitting in
storage facilities and opening them up
and looking to see what's in them and
documenting them and making them
available i'm asked frequently by people
about what my view is about the fact
that russia has paintings they for a
long while called them hidden treasures
now if you go to the ufc to the
pushkin museum in moscow or the
hermitage museum in st petersburg they
call them treasures revealed but they're
out hanging
and the other artworks that are not of
that caliber are in study galleries
available for people from any country to
go and take a look at and i say this
here's my view about this there were 290
000 americans killed in world war ii in
europe
and contrast that with 25 million
russians killed during world war ii 25
million 17 and a half million civilians
seven and a half million soldiers so i
think it's very hard for us or anyone to
appreciate what the russian view about
this is and it gets clouded by the fact
that stalin wasn't a good guy
there were lots of horrific acts by
russian soldiers in berlin but the fact
of the matter was they didn't have a
country to go home to um i saw the order
hishu hitler issued to literally it says
wipes white they called it st petersburg
white st petersburg off the face of the
earth
and as they left as they went into the
russia they stole the few things that
they considered a value and on their way
out
um gutted everything that they could
burn destroy etc so
it's a active debate in russia among
people there it's obviously a very
popular subject for nationalists
hardliners about the restitution and
return of these things i think it will
work itself out over the course of time
and my role is frankly not in that
situation to take sides i've spent a lot
of time both in the hermitage and out at
their cemetery piscario scoya cemetery
where
750 000 people from st petersburg are
buried so many of whom starved and
there's this extraordinary
quote on the wall along with this
inscription that says sooner death be
scared by us
then we'll be scared by death
and so i think it's very hard for us to
opine as to what russia should or
shouldn't do from the perspective that
we're through so that's my thought on
that
yes sir
yeah um it seems with so many pieces of
art that were stolen
i'm wondering about what's happened with
some of the other
pieces that are remain missing obviously
you talked about some have been
destroyed others may still be uh held in
the families of you know people in
russia or germany is there any people
still think that there are sites that
paintings have been hidden that still
haven't been found today well i think i
think what we're going to see i mean i
as i said earlier i think we all have a
front row seat to watch the final
chapter of this story be written and
it's written plays out every single day
i get calls and emails from people that
have elements and i think there's four
key reasons and i'm going to come back
to where i think some of these things
are the development of the internet now
we have the world's largest bulletin
board so people all over the world have
information they don't have to go sell
something to flea market and be taken
advantage of they can send an email to
softbees or christie's with an
attachment or whatever it is they've got
and ask them what is it and softbase and
christie is happy to tell them because
the more value to it the higher the
commission that they get for selling it
so from that perspective the free
exchange of information the ability for
people who perhaps have secrets to tell
someone and not have a bullet to the
head for doing it because it can be done
anonymously has created an all sorts of
access to information as well as second
reason the fall of communism so many of
the records are in the eastern countries
and
in some cases it's not going to result
in the discovery of works of art it may
provide answers specifically on how some
of these works were destroyed as an
example
there's some people that feel like in
those records we have answers to
big mysteries like the loss of the amber
panels from catherine palace and uh and
just outside st petersburg but that's a
second reason the third is be it a good
or bad development it is a fact of life
art has become synonymous with money and
now there's a huge financial incentive
for people to find these things
that's got good aspects and bad aspects
there are law firms in this country that
have created restitution branches much
like class action lawsuits where they do
work on contingency the family of maria
altman that recently had a restitution
of five paintings by gustav klimt that
they battled the austrian government for
for seven years
hand and nail
were returned to the family and they
ultimately sold them for about 300
million dollars these five paintings one
of which at the time was the most
expensive work of art ever sold um the
portrait of her aunt adele blockbauer
the gold portrait as they referred to it
sold for 135 million dollars and the
contingency fee to the attorney was 40
percent
so part of our role in this foundation
will be not to get into private
restitution cases because that's not a
way i'm interested in in participating
i'd like to help where there are
documents or works of art that have a
home in a museum or a church or
something like that and we find people
that have these things not because they
were involved in the bad doing but they
don't know what to do with it which is
the fourth category which are the
participants the age of the people that
participated in world war ii or were
involved and were there are now roughly
82 like harry etlinger on the young side
to
of course
well lane fazin who died 98 years old in
the next five to ten years we're going
to see many of those people die and as
they do information is becoming become
available and kids are going to inherit
things and they're going to go through
boxes that have been in attics and find
things that they don't know what it is
they don't know what to do with it in
many cases you know they may be trinkets
or they may have seemed like tricketts
at the time there's a nazi swastika a
luger and
a
thing in a frame you know well maybe the
thing in the frame turned out to be an
important work of art i don't think
people sat there and thought that at the
time they just picked it up and took it
they were different times and of course
the number of displaced people in europe
were measured into the millions so i
think we'll see many of these things
start to surface because there's now a
process in place as people sell these
things people vet them they check and
see where they came from what's the
background on them and they're going to
become in some cases
priceless and worthless because you
can't sell them
yes sir
what wasn't there a um famous altar in
quentin borg and east germany was that
um yes
they knew it or they didn't know what i
don't know what happened there was a guy
that took it uh
and he shouldn't have and i think he
knew very well he shouldn't have most of
these things that were shipped home the
uh post and sensors went through and
checked and you know they were trying to
remove ammunition that was being sent
home and guns and other things like that
and certainly works of art you'll see in
the book over and over again we found
orders issued by general eisenhower
general uh bradley issued my favorite he
said we are a conquering army not a
pillaging army and they issued these
orders over and over and over again to
the other generals to make sure that
they were enforcing these rules that
these weren't just words but they were
rules to be enforced by the commanders
to make sure there was no sale of art no
transportation or trafficking in art or
anything until we could get on the
reconstruction side and start to figure
out who were the bad guys and and really
allow that whole business to resume on
some basis so there was an enormous
effort to try and avoid that yes that
work of art surfaced in all places sad
to say the great state of texas
and uh and it was an effort to try and
sell the thing and be rewarded for bad
behavior and i think that was a
departure in time from what would happen
today where if something like that
surfaces i don't think anyone's going to
get paid for bad behavior and the work
of art hopefully will find its way home
yes sir
this is an extraordinary story and i as
i hear you and so much of it is new and
i'm a
history aficiondo but i wonder whether
you ought not to think about
a reach out to public
broadcasting
through some
program series such as the american
experience because this is really the
story of that but in some way
to broaden
the reach of this because
i think people need to know about it
well and right here in washington weta
is an extraordinary
venue for that and in some way
to begin to make that happen because
it's a story that needs to be told as
you indicated you're in a race against
time in terms of the people who were
with this group well i wholeheartedly
agree with you and that's part of our
efforts here to date um i've spent about
two and a half million dollars of my
money to tell this story i'm tired of
hearing the number of times people that
counsel me on investments take me inside
and say you can't afford to do this you
really can't afford to do this you have
got to stop doing this but i started
something and i as i'm sure you all can
tell i'm passionate about it i believe
it's i really believe it's the most
amazing story of my lifetime and i think
it's a story americans and people
throughout the i mean our traditional
allies in europe having lived in europe
are going to love to know what americans
did to help rescue the patrimony and
didn't beat their chests about it they
just did it and as some of these
monuments guys will tell you we did it
because it had to be done and that was
our job
so one of the things that will happen
with the documentary film after some
theatrical run is i believe it will show
on pbs that's i believe in the cards but
there are a lot of other efforts i'm in
the process of trying to set up both for
congress and the senate a private
showing of the documentary is the
easiest way i can think of for me to
make contact with policy makers to help
them understand i have a friend who's in
contact with various people in
government who's adamant about having
this book translated to farsi and arabic
and given away throughout the middle
east rather than having the state
department be trying to make films about
how we love uh people in that part of
the world a more material hands-on easy
to document example so
people are coming to me with ideas which
i'm so eager to have are our great
challenge and the reason i've started
make a lot more effort to get out and
talk about this aside from my my great
affection for doing it is i'm trying to
balance ongoing research of finding
these people with literally a staff
that's about five people
i've been home i don't know a dozen days
or so in the last few months
because i've been moving around anywhere
i need to be to try and bring profile
and visibility because i know
the answers to so much of the
information we need are out there with
people and we need to know what they
know and what's starting to happen now
is it starting to come back faster than
i can keep up with it so we're trying to
enlist the help of more people to get
involved and that's what gave rise to
the foundation was to be able to have a
funding mechanism as we start to
generate revenue to recoup the monies
that i've spent to be able to then fund
the ongoing research and fund the
foundation so
it that's what it has is its goal and i
think that the
lessons that we can
learn are uh not only of invaluable
benefit to us in the future but if ever
in my view 50 year old man
in my lifetime we needed some good
things to talk about that we've done
that's just black and white simple this
is it and this is the subject to do it
with
extraordinary story go ahead thank you
wonderful thank you thank you very much
thank you all for being here
robert edsel author of rescuing da vinci
hitler and the nazis stole europe's
great art america and her allies
recovered it
learn more at robert edselblog.com
22 year old
rescuing da vinci is the name of the
book robert edsel is the author
it's author's night at the national
press club in washington dc
mr edsel what is the painting that's uh
being carried on the front of your book
it's a painting by leonardo da vinci
called lady with an ehrman it's one of
only 14 commonly accepted paintings by
leonardo da vinci and it's a great photo
because you see these monuments men
men and women from 13 different nations
that volunteered for service to try and
protect all these great works of art
during world war ii
and recover them
returning this painting to krakow where
it was stolen by hitler in the nazis
during world war ii
how widespread was the uh the stealing
of paintings fine arts etc by the nazi
regime it's the greatest theft in
history and what it unleashed was the
greatest treasure hunt because these men
and women from these various countries
that were museum directors curators art
historians that had volunteered for
service to try and find these things
ended up finding them hidden more than 2
000 hiding places salt mines castles
caves and ultimately within five years
at the end of the war returned more than
five million cultural items to the
countries from which they were stolen
how many are still missing hundreds of
thousands of works of art uh worth
billions of dollars and so this chapter
this final chapter of world war ii has
just now really being written
every once in a while you see in the
paper where a painting has been returned
who governs them
well the laws of different nations uh
our our judicial system here has a
slightly different interpretation than
say napoleonic code in europe but today
for example uh i donated along with the
foundation the monument foundation
two uh hitler albums that were recently
found a very very significant discovery
that we donated the national archives
this morning at a press conference uh
these had never been seen people didn't
know that they existed and these are
albums that were found at his berkoff uh
in burke's garden uh and uh they're part
of a set that his group that looted
these works would send to him and much
like mail order catalogs he would flip
through them to decide which paintings
he wanted to have in his collection
and how is it that you got a hold of
those well we were with all the work
that we're continuing to do to try and
discover who these monuments men and
women are and write their biographies we
also have a lot of people contact us in
the foundation
with things that they may be concerned
that they have that they shouldn't have
or things that they may have seen
somewhere else and they're really
looking for guidance they don't want to
be in trouble they don't want to get in
trouble they're not sure that they're in
trouble and nor are we and our focus is
just to make sure that these things
aren't destroyed or lost and that they
come out so we had someone place us into
contact with some heirs of a american
soldier that was in barracks garden and
picked these things up not having any
understanding of the value or
significance of them and they sat in a
in an attic for many many years until
they finally surfaced so how did you
find an interesting interest in uh
rescuing art
well i think writing about rescuing art
i think it's uh it plays to all of our
uh childhood fantasies we grow up
hunting easter eggs we all are
fascinated with lottery winners uh
spanish galilean discoveries and i have
people frequently say to me this is like
hunting for barry treasure and i said
it's not like it it is
and um to be able to not just hunt for
for for these works of art but important
documents like these hitler albums that
are going to help us learn a lot more
about the theft and perhaps locate works
of art or other belongings for people
that are missing and it also helps us
hunt for other things that are important
for instance who are these people on the
photo that you just asked me about we
don't know the names of these soldiers
on either side of the photo and we're
appealing to the public for help to come
forward and tell us and someone's going
to say well that's uncle bob and that's
how we'll find out who they are where
this painting the lady with the norman
is in the charter rescue collection in
krakow poland and these monuments
officers arrested one of the nazi
generals that was ultimately tried and
found convicted and and hung in
nuremberg and are returning it to the
museum after having taken it off his
possession
robert edsel rescuing da vinci is the
book
[Music]
the book tv bus is traveling the country
visiting world war ii 85 large art
albums were stolen by the nazis fewer
than half have been recovered one of
those found was received by art
aficionado robert edsel who talks about
it in this event hosted by the national
archives this is a half hour
good morning
i'm alan weinstein archivist of the
united states
i'm pleased to welcome all of you to the
national archives
we're here today
because a very generous and patriotic
american
robert hitzel contacted us a few weeks
ago
to say that he wanted to donate to the
national archives some materials related
to art looted by the nazis during world
war ii
i think that is fair to say
that this material is one of the most
significant finds
related to hitler's premeditated theft
of art and other cultural treasures to
be found since the nuremberg trials
it is exciting to know
that original documents
shedding light on this important aspect
of world war ii
are still being located
especially so because of the hundreds of
thousands of still missing cultural
items stolen
from victims of hitler and the nazis
documents such as these may play a role
in helping to solve some of these
mysteries and more importantly in
helping victims to recover their
treasures
the national archives is grateful to mr
edsel
and the monuments men's foundation
for today's donation
robert edsel was a very successful
independent oil and gas producer in
texas
until 1995
when he sold his company and moved to
europe
while abroad he became a serious student
of the art and architecture of the great
masters
this led to his deep interest in
learning how and whether
and whether the artistic treasures of
europe survived the pillage of world war
ii
edsel's research led him to write an
important book on the subject
rescuing da vinci and to produce a
documentary film the rape of europa
mr edsel is also responsible for
establishing the monuments men's
foundation
monuments men foundation which preserves
the legacy of the heroic work by men and
women from 13 nations who comprised the
monuments fine arts and archives section
known as monuments men during world war
ii
many were museum directors
curators
art historians
and educators
in a few minutes mr anton and i will
unveil this material
but before we do i would like to provide
you with some context for the donation
it will become part of one of the most
active and most important collections at
the national archives
this collection is a key element
of the holocaust era asset story with
well over 15 million pages related to
the looting location recovery and
restitution of assets during and after
world war ii
these records have been gathered by more
than 30 federal agencies
in the past decade the national archives
facility in college park maryland
has welcomed more than one thousand
researchers
interested in these records to assist
the researchers and to assist them a
senior archivist who is here with us
today dr greg
rancher compiled
and
an 1100 page guide to relevant records
where's
greg
over there welcome
after the unveiling greg and assistant
archivist michael kurtz another
preeminent scholar of nazi looted art
will explain a bit more about these
records and their significance
the documents that mr edsel and the
other speakers will discuss this morning
provide another piece of the puzzle that
researchers will be able to use in their
work
and the national archives stands ready
to assist them as we have in the past
and now it's my pleasure to introduce a
modern renaissance man robert edsel
[Applause]
good morning
today i'm the
an author
a co-producer of a documentary film
and most importantly the founder and
president
of the monuments men foundation for the
preservation of art
however 11 years ago when i sold my
business
i had no educational background or
training in art in fact like many people
i spent very little time in museums
what i knew about world war ii history
was a result largely of
the experiences of my father who was a
world war ii veteran in the pacific
and from books like those written by
stephen ambrose and others
that all changed one day
while i was standing on a bridge in
florence italy
wondering how all the great cultural
treasures and monuments how so many of
these great works of art survived the
most destructive conflict and the
greatest theft in history who were the
people that saved them
what began as a simple question launched
a journey that's consumed my life since
then
and it's brought me to washington today
to stand here before you
along the way i learned a lot about the
greatest villains in history adolf
hitler and the nazis
and i came into contact with a group of
unknown heroes known as the monuments
men
men and women from 13 nations
about 70 percent of whom were american
museum directors curators art historians
who volunteered for service to try and
protect these great treasures and
chase them down after the war in what
became the greatest treasure hunt in
history
first the villains
adolf hitler and the nazis perpetuated
this
premeditated theft
as part of hitler's plan to construct
the world's greatest museum in his
hometown
and then fill it with the most important
masterpieces
nazi organizations were formed to
systematically rob individuals churches
and museums
this was not
this was not incidental to war
rather it was planned years in advance
albums filled with photographs of the
most
precious items seized from victims were
presented to hitler to both document the
effectiveness of the looting operation
and to allow him to peruse the
catalogues at his leisure to select
works of art that he wanted for his
fuhrer museum
in the closing days of the war 39 of
these albums were located
and ultimately placed in the possession
of the monuments men
they were subsequently used at the
nuremberg trials
not just as evidence but as the smoking
gun to a theft that took place over
eight tragic years
i direct your attention to the
projection screen
next
refer
to the stacks of leather-bound volumes
in front of me some of them are here
to which the justice referred
in his opening statement
these 39 volumes which are before me
contain photographs of works of art
secured by the einstein star
and our volumes which were prepared by
members of the rosenberg staff
all of these volumes bear our number
2522
ps
and i offer them in evidence all your
honors attention to
the inside
cover page most of them have an
inventory
in german
of the contents of the book
and then follows
a true photograph
of each one of these
priceless
objects of art separated by fine tissue
paper
there are 39 of these volumes that were
captured
by our forces
when they overran
a part of southern
occupied
german area
these books were found
by our staff
in connection with the group of us army
people who have assembled these objects
of art and are now in the process of
returning them to the rightful owners
their statement that 21
903 artworks have been seized
does not furnish an adequate conception
of their value
i refer again to the statement in the
document just quoted quote
that the extraordinary artistic and
material value of the seized artworks
cannot be expressed in figures unquote
and that they are objects of such a
unique character that their evaluation
is entirely impossible i shall take the
liberty during the requested audience to
give you my fuhrer
another 20 folders of pictures
with the hope that this short occupation
with the beautiful things of art
which are nearest to your heart
will send a ray of beauty and joy
into your revered life
uncle
after the war and trials the world was
busy rebuilding
new dangers emerged
the unfinished work
so remarkably performed by the monuments
men was lost in the fog of history
however with the fall of communism
the rise of art prices and international
accessibility to the internet
all that changed
great scholars
several of whom we have among us
including lynn nicholas greg bradshaw
michael kurtz
nancy have invested years studying
the mind-numbing volumes of documents
concerning this period so many of which
are in this magnificent national
archives
their work which began to tell this epic
story laid the foundation for increased
interest worldwide
rarely does a day pass without news of a
major world war ii restitution case
even with the increased pace of claims
we are just seeing the tip of the
iceberg in my view as people gradually
awaken to the fact that hundreds of
thousands of items are still missing
worth billions of dollars
but this is just a part of the altered
cultural legacy
left us by adolf hitler and the nazis
also missing are millions of documents
of inestimable value
not just to history but to our
civilization
among the missing documents are more of
these albums
until now thought to have been destroyed
at war's end
earlier this year as part of our ongoing
research into the monuments men i was
contacted by an organization and
subsequently introduced
to an heir of an american soldier not a
monuments man
who was stationed near berk's garden in
early may 1945.
this soldier removed these two albums
the hitler albums from hitler's home
known as the bear cough
these albums albums six and eight of the
series contained photographs of some of
the earliest thefts of works of art from
the most prominent collectors and
dealers in paris at the beginning of the
war
names such as wildenstein
khan
seligman
rothschild
we worked closely with the heirs
to explain to them the importance of
these albums based on our understanding
at the time
and subsequently to acquire them
we are here today because of the
donation to the national archives
under separate terms album eight will
enter the collection of the national
archives today
and album six will remain in our
possession available to scholars and
researchers
so that we can use it to bring more
visibility to this story and encourage
others who perhaps have albums and
documents and perhaps even works of art
to come forward and work with the
foundation
to help them find their way home
i founded the monuments men foundation
to honor the legacy of the monuments men
and women by resuming the job they so
remarkably performed more than 60 years
ago
in addition to our research on the
monuments men
which includes writing biographies
tracking down photos
and gathering information on each member
of this amazing group we also intend to
act as a clearing house
for people who believe they may have
works of art
that were taken or even stolen during
the war and that of course includes
documents
the monuments men foundation wants to
illuminate the path home for these
important treasures
but we need the help of the public to
identify and locate all of the heroes
and to work with us to preserve not
destroy perhaps seemingly worthless old
documents such as these albums
we're in a race against time
while we are working on the past
we remain focused on the future
by putting the great legacy of the
monuments men to work we hope to not
only help people recover
their precious belongings
but perhaps more importantly use all
that was learned through world war ii to
do a much better job protecting cultural
treasures in future conflict
it is an ambitious undertaking no doubt
but anything less would diminish the
historic achievements of the monuments
pin
professor weinstein would you join me
for the
unveiling
on my behalf and on behalf of the
monuments men foundation it's an honor
to present to you this album eight and
in the course of time album six as a
gift to the national archives and the
nation and we're grateful to receive it
thank you very much
shall we
here we are
there he is
i think
we want michael to say a few words
really
well
the only the only words i want to say
right now are thank you
we're grateful we'll treasure it we
deal with it the way we do with all of
our documents here
but i would like michael kurtz to come
join us and say a few words on behalf of
those who work so hard and greg why
don't you come up so people can know the
work that you've done as well
thank you michael
thank you very much professor weinstein
i'd like to add my word of thanks and
appreciation to robert edsel for this
magnificent uh donation
it uh supplements and complements the 39
volumes that we just saw in the film
it adds to our knowledge and
understanding of the works of art
that were looted much of which was
restored a great deal of which is yet to
be to be located
the national archives is really one of
the premier
places the building blocks for trying to
understand what happened
during world war ii whether we're
talking about battles and diplomacy or
in this case what actually happened
during the holocaust
and as professor weinstein noted we have
over 15 million pages of documentation
they're absolutely critical and many
researchers
use our records to be able to
begin the process of doing the art
provenance research that's necessary to
locate missing art missing family
treasures
we also our records are absolutely
invaluable
in trying to understand and trace what
happened with nazi gold
with insurance claims
with slave labor any any issue
and that relates to the very complex and
terrible holocaust era you have to come
to the national archives and so it's our
mission to preserve these records
and we're taking it we have a special
project uh to preserve these records uh
records created during world war ii were
created on on very poor paper
and so we have a major microfilming and
digitization program underway to make
sure
that generations to come have access to
these records
and i really do want to pay tribute to
greg brancher
who has worked who has labored really
for decades and years
on developing and
compiling that fantastic finding aid
that the archivist mentioned
anyone who wants to do research
can go to our website
find that guide and it's an absolute
road map to everything that we have
and so we have some conservation work
that we're honored to be able to do
on this volume is going to enter into
our our reference arena
and be a tremendous asset to uh to all
those who do research here thank you
thank you michael i i would say only
that
these are not our records these belong
to the american people
as everything in this building belongs
to the american people we will guard
those with every
every bit of our favor
i'd like i'd like to take some questions
now but greg before i do you may want to
say something
i don't think susan cooper our press
person had me on the agenda but uh
thank you
um
just two basic things
up until the mid-90s i like most people
thought of the holocaust as the greatest
murder in history which it was
but it only came to us through the
writings of dr kurtz lynn nicholas isn't
lynn here
who couldn't be here who lives here
locally and other people that that
started pointing out that world war ii
and the holocaust was also the greatest
theft in history
and
over the years thanks to michael's
support
allocating resources including my time
we have spent the national archives and
his staff has spent a considerable time
on trying to get trying to get a handle
on this massive amount of documents
these 15 million pages at least
related to this greatest theft in
history
and it's uh resulted in a sort of a
cottage industry
of
of researchers attorneys litigants
claimants that all come to the national
archives
and we're also lucky to have here nancy
yeah
who's back up against the wall who works
at the national gallery who's also yet
another expert
and while i might be an expert on the
records and michael might be an expert
on the subject
nancy was pestered by so many people on
how to use our records she wrote a book
that was published by the american
museum
association
so she didn't have to deal with all the
all the people coming to her
so
because of the national archives being
in the central location and having a lot
of qualified knowledgeable and most
importantly interested in the subject
we've accomplished a lot
but as mr etzel said there's a lot more
to be done and as michael said
the paper that was used during the war
was the lowest quality and you can pick
it up and it crumbles in your hand
so there's a lot to be done a lot to be
done sooner than later and uh we're very
lucky that we have such great leaders
here at the national archives and such
great experts on art art looting here in
the washington area and people like mr
etzo who want to play an important role
in this
well it's the role of memory and we're
here to remind people that we don't
forget
questions anybody
these albums how many are missing and
many have been raised
this is a very good question can
everyone hear the question
uh how many works of art are in these
albums and how many were recovered uh
there are about 50 or so images in uh
the album eight uh a few more in album
six
and our work uh which we really started
delving into
in addition to to making arrangements to
get these to national archives was to
begin to try and answer those questions
how many of these things have been
recovered
it's my
working
estimate at this stage that
most of them if not all perhaps were
part of the
treasures found at the castle of
nishwenstein by the monuments men in
fact by jim rohmer
who later became the director of the
metropolitan museum of art in
new york city and this is him standing
on the steps of the castle in
mishwinstein as american forces under
the supervision of the monuments men
walk out of the castle with some of
these thousands of artworks that were
found there and ultimately loaded onto
trains
and shipped directly back to paris
okay next question
yes so there are no works on these
albums that are uh disputed prominence
that you're aware of
well no none that we're aware of i think
that a lot more research needs to take
place that's part of the reason of
getting them out there in the public
domain for people to hopefully see if
there's something they can track down
and resolve disputes yes
we had your hand up before no
can you talk a little bit about where
you recovered these two um
there was an american
heir of an american soldier that was
stationed in the barracks garden area in
the time period he would have had to
have been there first few weeks in may
1945
and uh tossed these in his rucksack
uh as a souvenir of war
and uh there they sat in the family's
attic many many years and uh that
soldier's
deceased
and
they didn't know what to do with it they
knew there was
they they had some idea of
of it having value but not understanding
the importance and significance of it
and in fact at the beginning while
i was able to determine some idea about
it was and understanding the importance
there was a lot of confusion a lot that
we've all learned about the 39 albums
that are at national archives that was
researched that evolved from
uh these things
surfacing okay anybody else yes
of the 39 original albums how many are
known
how many do we have in hand here or
elsewhere
we have 39 albums here
uh that were used in the nuremberg war
crimes trials from the documentation we
believe there may be have been as many
as 85
and so that's why this is so
particularly important because here
another one has surfaced and it really
shows i think illustrates the sweep of
the nazi uh looting operation by 1942
it's from the pyrenees to the euros and
so
that's one of the reasons i think this
is very significant
yes
well i was going to ask the same
question about the
39 albums from the trial
you've had them constantly since then
yes the the 39 albums are at the college
park facility
where i imagine this one will
will join them and someday within the
next five years
album six will also
find a home there and i wouldn't be at
all surprised if by the time that
happens
we hope perhaps some of these other
missing albums may show up
what's the distinction between six and
eight regarding one being donated now
and one in the future
uh that's a good question album eight
was uh certainly the one that was in the
greatest need of attention and i think
the national archives facilities
unparalleled in the world concerning
document preservation
album six has some particularly
interesting stories that
we believe will allow us to bring great
profile not just to the work of the
monuments men but also
allow people that
are kids like this fellow that contacted
the organization that contacted us i say
kids my age
uh
who
have things and what we found is a
concern for
uh perhaps being in trouble about having
them people don't know in the arena that
we're dealing with very very complicated
a lot of difficult questions and our
role was to try and help them understand
uh work with us we know where this thing
belongs we know what to do with it uh
and so it's to try and inform people and
help them understand these things are
important and something that may have
been picked up as a souvenir may have
great historical importance don't toss
it don't try and sell it on ebay without
uh trying to check into it and we're
trying to make ourselves a clearing
house where people know pick the phone
up send us an email let us know what
they've got perhaps we can help
kids hey
i'm sorry yes but why wait to donate
number six is there a reason is there
something you're going to do with it
that you can't do while it's in our
package why are you doing
i don't have plans to do that at this
stage my focus is really
someday your soon to get some sleep
and thereafter uh continue the research
on the monuments men
i believe that the interest in seeing
this document the documents and records
at national archives are there for a
reason
and it was my judgment that the ability
to have the freedom of travel
very limited but the freedom of travel
to allow others that don't have the time
or the opportunity or familiarity with
going to college park or coming to this
magnificent facility to actually see
this document firsthand and hopefully
be inspired to come forward those people
that have these things and contribute to
the database with other things that are
missing
uh actually we're not we're not waiting
we've provided a letter of intent as i
mentioned it's under separate terms
it will be here it's just a matter of
when it when it arrives and we will make
the information in those albums
available to researchers and scholars
right away so that there's no delay and
and the benefit of the information being
accessible
i can assure you that the archives is
not not forgetting about
book number six
and we'll keep in conversation with mr
excellency where this leads
also this is an extraordinary
opportunity for for others who
watch this story in some fashion read
about it see it on television
to think about whether there is but
whether there is something in their home
in their family's kit bag something that
uncle joe or
a dad or grandpa or someone brought back
from the war that's just been an addict
somewhere for decades and decades that
maybe now's the time to think through
but there are materials that we'd like
to they'd like to contribute to us so
that we can give them to the american
public any other questions
i think we've done let me add one other
thing just for clarity i'm not working
on another documentary at this stage i
am working on a second book that will be
more narrative about the monuments men
uh that's been ongoing long since before
these things surface so there's a lot of
work that we're continuing to do to tell
the story
i think we've done it thank you very
much for coming and thank you mr edsel
for your
would like an work to uh interview mr
etzel or doctor weinstein
foreign
[Music]
um yes
good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats we're about to begin the next
session
wonderful i'm going to get started and
good afternoon to everyone
and welcome to miami book fair
as i look out um i see many of you who
have been with us all morning
and i'm sure there are many who have
been with us
since last sunday am i right who who
opened the fair with us last sunday
wonderful
i am malu harrison and it's truly a
pleasure to welcome you to miami book
fair 2017
and as
other guests are coming in
let me also pay a special welcome as
always
conveying our gratitude
to the circle of friends of miami book
fair
and with your support we are able to
continue this outstanding cultural and
literary event for the community
and also for the visitors that come from
near and far for this book fair
during the month of november
as you may know the book fair is really
year-round
so i hope that you do visit us all year
long but particularly for this seven-day
extravaganza
of wonderful authors booksellers
presenters
chefs
and
and many other literary
enthusiasts so thank you for being here
i also want to at this time
ask as always that you silence your
devices
so that we can all enjoy the program
and so to help me introduce our speaker
please help me to welcome mr javier
granda who's the general counsel of
south motors javier
[Applause]
good afternoon
on behalf of south motors miami dade
college and of course the miami book
fair we welcome and we're very pleased
to have you here
south motors is a family company it's
been around for over 60 years with a
commitment to treating every customer
like family
another commitment that the family made
from the very beginning was the
commitment to give back to the community
through events such as this
it is our pleasure to have someone like
walter isaacson here uh it is a
pleasure to have someone of his
magnitude and of his knowledge and
wealth of experience to have someone
like you here
my notes are blanking out
walter is the university professor of
history at tulane
a former ceo of the aspen institute
chairman of cnn and the managing editor
of time magazine
he is the author of the innovators how a
group of hackers geniuses and geeks
created the digital revolution
kissinger a biography
steve jobs einstein his life in universe
benjamin franklin
on american life and of course now
walter brings to life
leonardo da vinci for us
and without further ado
walter please
thank you javier
thank you eduardo padron thank you all
from the miami book fair i've been here
for every book and it's always a great
pleasure to be in this city
one reason it's great to be in miami is
that like so many other cities of this
world
it has now become a mix of very creative
people with a tolerance for all sorts of
people and that was what made leonardo
da vinci
so creative
you know i've written about a lot of
smart people and at a certain point it
occurs to me
that smart people are a dime a dozen
they don't usually amount to much right
it takes being innovative imaginative
and creative and one recipe for that
is being able to stand at the
intersection of arts and sciences to
love both the humanities and engineering
i remember watching steve jobs give his
product presentations he would always
end with that street sign of the liberal
arts meeting technology and say that's
where creativity lies
and i thought yeah that's what ben
franklin did even einstein
would pull out his violin and play
mozart when he was having trouble with
his equations saying that music and art
helped connect him
to the spirit of the cosmos and the
harmony of the spheres
but the ultimate of that
and the person i decided should be the
capstone of a series of books about
creativity
and how to achieve it
is leonardo da vinci now leonardo had
the great good fortune
to be born out of wedlock
had he been legitimately born he would
have been a notary like his father
grandfather great great-grandfather and
great-great-grandfather
leonardo
loved as he grew up in the tiny village
of vinci there
to blend
fantasy
and reality
he loved to think out of the box
he loved to do things different
all the things you do not want
in your notary
but it did help them
become a creative artist and engineer
who loved the patterns of nature also by
being born out of wedlock it meant he
wasn't sent to one of the universities
or latin schools to have his head
crammed filled with this dusty
scholasticism of the middle ages and so
he got to become what he called
a disciple of experience
meaning
he did experiments he always questioned
whatever he was told
and
decided he was going to see if it was
right he wasn't going to accept received
wisdom so even as a little kid in vinci
those streams running down to the arno
he put rocks in him and see how the
water rippled and the swirl of water
becomes one of the many patterns in
nature
that become his passion and we see it
throughout his life
he looked at things that you and i saw
when we were age 10
and ask questions about like why is the
sky blue and when a bird takes off does
its wings go up faster or down faster
but leonardo unlike us
never outgrew his wonder years he was
the most insatiably curious person in
history
and that is key number one
to his creativity
we can see in his notebooks every week
weird questions he decided he needed to
know not just why is the sky blue but
why does water swirl the way it does
when it goes into a basin or a pond
or
what is the size of the sun and how
would you measure it and my favorite
what does the tongue of a woodpecker
look like
i try to imagine what it'd be like one
morning and put in your notebook
describe the tongue of the woodpecker i
mean why would you even care how would
you even know you know open up a
woodpecker
but that's leonardo
if it struck his curiosity he put it in
his notebook and he tried to learn
everything
by age 12 his father brings them to
florence a town like the towns i've been
talking about one of those creative
cities
in which all sorts of people work
together leonardo was lucky he was born
the same year that gutenberg opened his
print shop and spread it to florence so
in his notebooks we see leonardo saying
go down to the stationers by the bridge
and by the translation of euclid or get
the anatomy book all these things he
wanted to learn
also constantinople fell that year he
was born so people are coming from the
arab world bringing mathematics
and leonardo is quite a misfit
besides being illegitimate he's
left-handed he's gay
he's a vegetarian he's a bit of a
heretic
and they love them in florence it was
under lorenzo de medici and the medici
family one of those places where people
of diverse backgrounds
all fit in a live and let live place
leonardo worked in a workshop of andrea
verrocchio
and some people call it an artist studio
but it was much more than that
and that was another secret to leonardo
he loved to do everything look at the
famous duomo you all know the duomo
there the dome that brunelleschi builds
on the top of the florence cathedral
there's a copper ball on it
and leonardo when he was a very young
apprentice in the shop of verrocchio
helps solder the copper ball and he
draws all the mechanisms they use to put
it on top of the dome it is
the ultimate connection that he makes
his whole life between art and science
between beauty and engineering
among the things that they do in the
workshop
are pageants and plays
and leonardo loves them he's a
good-looking
kid
and kind of proud of how good-looking he
is we know how good-looking he is
verrocchio did a statue of
david a young 12-year-old david and the
young 12-year-old leonardo is right
there in the center being sketched by
somebody else in the workshop posing for
david
and in the plays they do they do
costumes
and one of leonardo's first sketches uh
etchings a silver point there on the
left the craggy old warrior another
uh drawing that he liked
juxtaposed with the angelic young
warrior something we see leonardo doing
his whole life but he's doing it as a
set of costumes for the visit
of the duke of milan verrocchio did the
relief on the right leonardo did the
drawing on the left but you can see how
they mix fantasy in reality dragons had
yet also the wings of a bat that are
scientifically accurate and everywhere
in it those curls and swirls that
leonardo liked he even does it for his
engineering the curls and the swirls
he's sort of famous people say didn't he
invent the helicopter this drawing here
is a famous drawing
well yeah except for it was done too for
a play
it was done to bring the angels down
from the rafters and one of the plays
that leonardo produced
because sometimes we don't focus on the
fact that producing plays and doing
pageants
was a big job back then they didn't have
tv they didn't have movies so there were
pageants and plays each night and
leonardo loved it because it blurred the
line between fantasy and reality in fact
he so much loves blurring that line
between fantasy and reality that once he
does drawings like this of the
helicopter
he decides well maybe i'll make a real
flying machine
so as you know for a long period of his
life he's trying to design
flying machines and he makes a great
glider he also can never make a
man-powered flying machine that will
take off
so he studies birds in the flight of
birds to figure out why they have a
different weight ratio to their muscles
realizes it's impossible
another small lesson from leonardo
sometimes
you should try to do the impossible
because at least you'll find out why it
can't be done
but two he is a painter because that's
one of the things they do in the
workshop
and he become such a good painter that
the legend is verrocchio got so awed by
him that verrocchio decided never to
paint again just have leonardo handle
the painting in the studio in this the
baptism of christ
we see one of the patterns we'll see
throughout leonardo's life this is when
leonard is very young
verrocchio does most of the painting but
leonardo does that river the river
jordan coming from the ancient eons of
time
and flowing into the bodies
in this case literally as john the
baptist pours the water over jesus and
if you look carefully and i thank simon
and schuster my publisher because they
use such high quality paper that you can
see the color reproductions throughout
if you look at the ripples next to the
ankles
of jesus
you see how scientifically accurate is
the kid who loves that rippling water
knows how to turn it into both
engineering and to art
but most importantly in his notebooks
around this time leonardo
is saying
the goal of a painter should also be to
express the inner emotions through
outward gestures and outward expressions
and so the angel on the far left is
leonardo's the one next to him
verrocchio did you look at leonardo's
angel there's all sorts of deep emotions
as we see the twist of the neck and the
expression of the face
things that he had sketched in his
notebook as he walked around town seeing
how people
express
different forms of awe and other
emotions
the one that verrocchio painted next to
him
about the only expression on that
angel's face as you can see is
how did i get here next to this far more
beautiful
angel
we see two even in his first portrait
that ability to show emotions on a face
as somebody turns geneva de vinci this
is the wife
of a cloth merchant in florence and
three quarters profile with a river
again
coming down and connecting us to nature
connecting from the ancient mountains
the river curving the way he loved those
corals into the blood of humans
connecting us to the world
this is not
the mona lisa
even though it's a cloth merchant's wife
and three-quarter profile with
expressions and a river
he wouldn't paint the mona lisa until
the end of his life
and it was only after doing a lot more
anatomy and a lot more science and a lot
more geology that other art historians
say it's a shame he wasted his time
doing all this math and geology and
science and anatomy because he could
have painted more paintings well that's
true
but if he hadn't done all those patterns
of nature and been so enriched about
being curious
about everything
i don't think he ever would have gotten
from geneva da vinci to the mona lisa
which is the culmination of a lifetime
spent finding the patterns of nature he
also used his theatrical
knowledge to do paintings here in the
adoration of the magi also done when he
was young
and in florence we don't just see a
scene we see that swirl he loves a
curving spiral and it's a drama it's a
stage drama
in perspective as if it were on a stage
with the second king offering the gift
at the very bottom swirling up to the
first king who's already bowing down and
each person in the spiral
their expression
is reflective of the person before them
it was very complicated
and leonardo doesn't finish the painting
and that happens to leonardo often he
puts things aside flying machines that
don't fly tanks that don't roll
paintings
that he puts aside he actually gives it
to the family of america vespucci the
guy who's about to go discover america
at the time
and i don't think he just gave up on
paintings but i think he always thought
that maybe he would learn more and he
could apply yet another brush stroke
whether it was a mona lisa which he kept
for 16 years
or
the adoration of the magi which he gives
to the friends to hold for him
and he never fully gets back to it
this notion of always finding another
brushstroke we see in saint jerome a
painting he did around the same time
saint jerome in the wilderness
and it's unfinished but you can see that
about 20 30 years later after he had put
the painting aside he does some more
anatomy experiments and he dissects
human corpses and gets the neck muscles
exactly right in his anatomy drawings on
the far right here
and he goes back to a saint jerome
painting and redoes the neck muscles of
that painting so what you see in
leonardo is somebody who procrastinates
which makes them a bad notary somebody
who sometimes will let the perfect be
the enemy of the good like steve jobs
who wouldn't ship the original macintosh
because the circuit board inside wasn't
pretty and so they held it up until they
could make the circuit board that nobody
would ever see pretty likewise leonardo
often just holds on to his drawings and
says i will learn something more i'll be
able to make it better
the way that i sort of understood that
was not just by looking at his paintings
which other people have written about so
brilliantly but i decided to use as the
foundation for this book
his notebooks
i didn't realize about 20 years ago when
i was wandering around my wife had
studied in florence art history
and we saw all the paintings we go to
italy quite a bit but i kept stumbling
across in the archives and bibliotechs
in italy
his notebook pages and i realized that
that was the clue to how his mind danced
around different subjects just take a
simple not simple but a page like this
first of all marvel how good of a
technology
paper is for the storage and retrieval
of information
500 years later we can still see it
50 years from now your facebook posts
and your tweets fortunately are not
going to be retrievable but paper it's
really good the operating system never
goes
out
so in the center left you see that
craggy warrior that he's always drawing
but you see a tree
trunk branching into the torso of the
warrior as leonardo's mind goes through
something he's been thinking about which
is the analogy between nature and humans
and especially what we could call
leonardo's law of branching which is
when there's a branch of a tree
or branches
the cross section of the areas of the
branches totals up to the cross section
of the trunk and that's true of rivers
and their tributaries it's true of our
arteries and so leonardo is making those
connections and the top left he's making
the connections between the swirls of
water he loves and curls of hair he
writes about curls of hair have the same
spiral form
and by the way he even makes a stab at
the math of fibonacci's equation as for
math he's always trying to transform one
shape into
a different shape but with the same area
a problem sometimes called squaring the
circle which is to make
a square the exact same area as a given
circle using only a ruler and a
protractor an ancient mathematical
puzzle that's not actually totally
solvable because pi
is a very irrational number but leonardo
tries all sorts of visual ways
throughout his life
to square
the circle
and you can see it up there
and finally on the left there's his mara
script he's writing from right to left
because he taught himself the right and
he's a left-hander
and so he doesn't want to smudge the ink
so it's in manuscript and you see the
list of things he wants to learn that
week weird things like inflate the lungs
of a pig and see whether they expand in
length as much as in width and you go
you got to be kidding
but he's turning 30 when he does this
and at the very bottom left is a recipe
for using the husks of certain types of
nuts and boiling them
[Music]
in oil
in order to make a tawny
in other words
uh blondish hair dye
and suddenly you say man the guy is
human kind of vain about his appearance
those beautiful curly locks and he's
worried about going grey
that's our leonardo
around that time too he finds the
companion of his life salahi a nickname
for the little devil
salahi is able to be sort of a bit of a
petty thief and everything else but
leonardo likes him and that's how he
gets his nickname and throughout his
life we can watch salahi with his
beautiful curly hair age and see him in
the notebooks
and as part of leonardo's life but at
that period of turning 30 maybe starting
to turn gray
his father the notary had notarized the
contracts for two of the paintings he
hadn't delivered the adoration in saint
jerome
and so you can kind of imagine that
maybe it was time to move on time to
leave
wonderful florence
and what he does is he goes as part of a
cultural delegation
to milan
because florence
was not a great military power he was
even able to lose battles to pisa which
was probably hard to do
but it had a lot of influence because of
what you might call we might jonai calls
soft power
cultural diplomacy it would send its
engineers and architects and artists to
do things like the sistine chapel or
build buildings in venice and in 1482
there's a big delegation that goes from
florence to milan sent by the medici
family to the duke of milan that is led
by a playwright and a poet
it has an architect archie's
artists engineers and of all things
leonardo goes as a musician
because he does everything especially
because he loves theater so he has
invented musical instruments including
one called the lyra de braca a liar for
the arm like a violin but he made it in
the shape of a horse's hat and so he
brings it to milan as a gift as part of
that cultural delegation
but he kind of wants to stay there needs
the new horizons and he's a little bit
tired of being just a painter he's been
blocked on the last couple of paintings
he's done so he writes
one of the coolest job application
letters in history
to the duke of milan and it's 11
paragraphs long
and the first 10 paragraphs all about
engineering and science he says i can
make great weapons of war something he
hadn't really done but he had sketched
out a lot of them including the large
crossbow
he says i can build great buildings i
can divert rivers
it's only in the 11th paragraph almost
as an afterthought
when he says
and i can also paint as well as any
person
now of course he could
but he revels in the fact that when he
gets to milan he eventually earns
a position as the engineer and painter
to the duke of milan and he works on
projects collaboratively because once
again i want to emphasize that
creativity
is a team sport
innovation comes from collaboration we
think of leonardo as going to a garrett
somewhere in the castle in milan
and maybe doing his great drawing like
vitruvian man or his paintings but in
fact he worked with a lot of other
people
especially in the court of milan
his really close friend luco pacioli the
great mathematician leonardo does
the drawings for his math book on divine
proportion and leonardo gets a feel for
the divine proportions useful in art he
also works with architects and engineers
and his first real big thing that he
does is work with three or four friends
on helping fix up
the milan cathedral
like steve jobs
leonardo believed that simplicity
was a soul of beauty
as you're looking in this milan
cathedral you're probably thinking this
is not the soul
of beauty this is a gothic monstrosity
but leonardo and his friends are asked
to help design the tiberio this i can't
quite show it but the little lantern
tower on top and they come up with a
simple geometric design of a circle
octagonal and square and as you can tell
the authorities in milan
don't build it they build a gothic
monstrosity instead
but in working on it leonardo has become
very close friends with three or four
other architects and engineers most
notably donato bramanti
the cool thing is bramonte painted a
picture of the two of them together
that's bramante on the right
round-faced balding
and there's leonardo on the left his
short purple tunics that he loved to
wear the notebook in front of him with
the mirror script going from right to
left
the he was always said to have had a
muscular well-built well-proportioned
athletic body
that chiseled face and of course
the wonderful flowing curly locks
of blonde or maybe dyed blonde hair
and so they go off and they decide to do
church design and what they like is the
very symmetrical very simple designs
these are leonardo's drawings in his
notebooks of how you really should do a
building or a church it should be
proportional to a human
he wants to connect the human to nature
but also
to the spirit
and the renaissance as you know was
partly a rebirth of classical knowledge
if you've read the great book the swerve
by stephen greenblatt you know that the
rediscovery of lucretius is part of the
renaissance well for brahmonte and his
friends and leonardo there was a
manuscript that had just been
rediscovered by the ancient
roman architect vitruvius
and vitruvius writes
about how buildings especially churches
and temples should reflect the
proportions of a human and vitruvius
gives page after page line after line of
the exact proportions of the human body
which leonardo will say as vitruvius
says here are the proportions but one
thing i discovered in leonardo's
notebook is that
ever
since his childhood
he doesn't accept received wisdom he's a
disciple of his own experiments
so what he does in page after page of
his notebooks is do
proportions working with his assistants
to measure the chin to the cheekbone to
the nose to the breast
sitting standing running
dozens and dozens hundreds of
proportions that he does
and with his friends he's still geeking
out
totally obsessive on the issue of
squaring the circle there's page after
page of ways to do squares and circles
get them all the same area
and so having done that
they go down to pavia
a town very close to milan
where they're building a cathedral
that's more to their liking
a very simple cathedral
and they all decide to go to the castle
in pavia
and look at the manuscript there because
there's a copy of the manuscript of
vitruvius
but it's unillustrated so they are going
to illustrate vitruvian man
now we know leonardo but
his friends also do it there it is the
man
in proportion in the circle in the
square in the church design all fitting
according to the proportions of
vitruvius
we see francesco di giorgio's drawings
giacomo d'andrea who had a nice dinner
where they were doing it and salah
solidi came leonardo brought his
companion sale who spilled wine on the
table we know this from the notebooks so
we can imagine these guys doing it
looking at salai hoping that he doesn't
spill wine and then leonardo
he does his version
yeah right
it's in a totally different league
as you look at leonardo's vitruvian man
you can see it's a work of brilliant
science he takes the foot and puts it
sideways to be the measurement and
everything in there is scientifically
proportioned according
to the measurements leonardo made and he
gets it exactly accurate but it's also a
work of great math
vitruvius had said that the navel should
be at the center of the earth but he
also implies that the genitals are at
the center of creation so leonardo puts
a circle
and the square on the same base but as
you can see the circle
goes up a little bit higher so the navel
is at the exact center of the circle the
genitals are at the center of the square
circle goes up
and he's squaring the circle making them
the same area
but besides being a work
of great science and great math
it is a work
of unbelievable art
unnecessary beauty i mean remember what
his friends are doing you know stick
figures a little and there's leonardo
with his left-handed cross hatchings
making it awesomely beautiful i went to
the fourth floor of the academy in
venice where they keep it in storage
because it can't be exposed to light
my wife and i and the translator who was
working with me we
had talked them into showing it to us if
you look at the dust jacket of my book
the author's picture in the back there i
am
leaning over vitruvian man having walked
up four flights of stairs in july
in venice in a an air-conditioned
building so this sweat and i'm thinking
if i drop some sweat
onto this picture 500 years from now
people will be saying i wonder what
leonardo meant by that blood so
i was very careful but you see
the sharply in size lines he knew
exactly what he was doing it's not some
sketch
the protractor right in the center of
the navel there and you get a chill
almost because you feel you're in the
presence of the hand of the master
and then you look at the face that face
staring at you with emotion
and intensity
and as you stare at it
your mind should go back
to the things you've seen about leonardo
you can look at that picture
yeah and you realize
that this
to some extent
is leonardo
drawing himself
standing naked spread eagle
in the earth
and in the cosmos
and in the center of creation
asking how do i
fit in
this is what makes it the greatest
drawing connecting the art
the sciences the humanities and the
spirit
all
in the curious mind saying what am i
doing here how do i
fit in
he does throughout his time
anatomical drawings
but they're not just great of great
anatomy they also combine
art and science the visual display of
information as somebody who thought he
could do weaponry this is a map of a
amola
he
and nicolo machiavelli his friend and
caesar borgia the warlord all spin the
winter of 1502 a few months in a mola
and what would be a great scene in a
movie if i may say
as leonardo realizes that the greatest
weapon of war is understanding where you
are and he paces off the streets with
salahi and then is able to do an aerial
view even though he doesn't have
airplanes or balloons or drones
and it looks like a current map you
would have of a military map and if you
read machiavelli's the prince what he
says of borgia is that one of his great
weapons was surprise he always knew
where he was and where the enemy was and
what the terrain was better than any
adversary and all of this is part of it
and leonardo and machiavelli even cook
up a scheme because leonardo loves water
in its flow ever since he was a little
boy
of diverting the arno river
so that florence would go right to the
sea
why well
this is right after
the 1490s
suddenly after america vespucci and
christopher columbus it becomes
important to be a seaport
if you're going to be part of the age of
exploration and also if you can't beat
pisa militarily you can divert the river
so
you can sort of uh starve them out
so it was one of his other great things
but all of the science the art and in
the engineering
and the theater
come together
in his paintings
in milan he does of course the last
supper on the refractory wall of a
monastery
and
one of the things that's very noticeable
is that it's the work of a theater
designer i mean it's almost as if jesus
is saying
all right everybody get on this side of
the table if you want to be in the
picture the way you would on stage
but also the perspective lines are
mathematically correct all going from
the vanishing point on the forehead of
jesus
outward you can see them radiate out but
the walls go back in an accelerated
perspective way
why
well imagine look on stage here look at
the scenery that you imagine a leonardo
would have done the scenery comes in
that way to make
it look deeper
and it's not just a moment in time some
art critics
have said it's a little eerie because it
seems like a frozen moment not to me
it feels like a sequential drama a
narrative drama the monks coming in from
the right
and jesus saying
one of you shall betray me
and you see it rippling out the sound
waves that he loved because he thought
sound waves were like water waves they
rippled out so the first group of
apostles on either side of jesus they're
already reacting with the next verse the
next part of the narrative is it me lord
is it i who will betray you and then it
ripples further out as they're first
hearing it and almost seems to bounce
back the way ripples do as jesus says
he that dippeth his hand
and you see judas there
sort of on the left our left
dipping his hand
and then finally
as the narrative goes on there's jesus
reaching for the bread and the wine and
the institution of the eucharist so even
in a still painting we get a dramatic
narrative
there are a few curious things about it
like the windows or in the way back
those three windows and yet if you look
at the light on the right wall or the
front of the table or the shadows on the
table
they're not coming from that back
windows you think did he get it wrong
how could he have messed that up
and then you go visit the monastery
in milan
you go into the room where it is and you
marvel at the picture and then you look
up to your left and there in the real
room is the only window
and you'll realize
that it's a light coming in in midday
from that window
that leonardo is using to light the
right wall of the painting and the table
with the shadows from it directly
that science of art and engineering also
came together very very famously
a few days ago
with the half a billion dollars almost
uh of a sale i write about this quite a
bit in my book i did not know it was
going to go on sale but i was mesmerized
by this painting went to see it in
london
then as you know it went on sale at
christie's
it's called salvador monday
and the reason i was mesmerized by it
was it shows how leonardo in the face
blurs lines knowing because he studied
optics that we don't see at a distance
like that sharp lines because we have
two eyes and our retinas
see at various points of the retina and
so there's nothing really sharp about
the lines but as things get closer to
you they get sharper look at the curls
of jesus the spirals
that leonardo loved and the light luster
and as it gets to his chest
they get a little bit clearer and then
there's that right hand that's blessing
us and it is sharply
delineated something leonardo didn't
usually do some people said maybe this
he didn't paint the whole thing because
he wouldn't have painted a hand that
sharp
but as i looked at his notebooks he's
writing a treatise on perspective
and he talks about perspective like in
the last supper and how
distance perspective works
and even how you do artificial
perspective in a big painting like the
last supper but then he has a section
called acuity perspective or sharpness
perspective and he writes about how
if something's at a distance it's not
perfectly easy to see
i mean that the lines are blurred
but at a arm's length or so it's a focal
point of our eyes and so lines are very
sharp so in doing it that way with the
sharpness he's making it look like the
hand is coming out off the panel
to bless us
he is doing one of his great
contributions to art which is making
something look three-dimensional
on a two-dimensional panel
and there's the crystal orb
very scientifically accurate with the
inclusions on the bottom or bottom right
of that orb
but there's something strange about it
if you think of a lens or solid crystal
even a bottle of dasani water i guess
and you think of your hand behind it
like this or whatever
you can imagine you can see it's
distorted
inverted a bit like any lens
and yet there or if you look in my book
because it's a high quality reproduction
or i want to see it and look very
carefully there is not the tiniest bit
of distortion in jesus's robes
why is that well it could be well he
just didn't know
that's ridiculous uh even as a kid he's
doing that copper ball and showing how
light waves hit curved objects how they
back then he's doing lenses he's
studying crystal for isabella death day
so we know he knows
it could be he knows it but he thinks
it'll be too distracting you have a
beautiful picture all of a sudden the
robes are bit off and people be
distracted so he doesn't do it
maybe
the other thing is it's salvador mundi
and he's showing the miraculous quality
he's showing a miracle that nothing he
touches is ever distorted
the good thing about leonardo is you can
be your own
thinker of the mysteries and figure out
what was in his head
he was not very close to michelangelo
in fact when michelangelo's statue of
david is done leonardo is on the
committee to figure out where to put it
leonardo wants it put you know sort of
under the arches of where to down the
ufc but you can see in leonardo's
notebook he also draws
the statue if you look carefully there's
what leonardo calls a de chante
ornamente a decent ornament i.e a fig
leaf covering up the genitals now this
is odd because leonardo was not that
prudish about nudity we have enough nude
pictures and sketches of his
but there's something about michelangelo
that
and so
the first 40 years that david is
displayed it has a brass
fig leaf ornament covering it up because
leonardo wanted it that way
one of the things that leonardo does is
see the patterns across nature as i said
and this is
from his heart drawings
he dissected the human heart and then
dissected pigs hearts that were still
beating because
his dissections had begun to figure out
things like how do i paint saint
jerome's neck whatever it may be but
being leonardo
it devolves into curiosity
for curiosity's sake he just wants to
know everything so he's dissecting the
heart
and he discovers a major discovery in
science which is how the heart valve
works people thought that the blood
pumps from the heart into the aorta and
it pushes the valve open and then the
pressure from on top when enough blood's
in there pushes it close and on this
page on the left leonardo is saying no
that would crumple it
what happens is when fluid moves from a
size chamber to a smaller one and hits
the friction of the walls it creates
those spirals the swirls of water that
he so loved and he says it's by the
swirling water
it spreads out the membrane and that's
why the heart valve membrane spreads out
and closes he even there has a glass
device
that he has shown that you can use
to prove this
and indeed he's right that's how even
our artificial heart valves now work
because of this but the thing about
leonardo is every now and then you're
reminded that he's human
he's doing more and more drawings of
heart he gets to his last page he's
doing another cross-section on the
bottom
and then he gets distracted as he often
does his mind wanders and he draws
solaie with the heart inside of him
which i think is kind of sweet
and it reminds us yet again how human
the guy is but in all of his anatomy
it's always a connection of art and
science it's always the beauty
of how we
fit in to creation
and it always has from its earliest
drawings to the end
this wonderful patterns of nature like
the water flowing into the bowl
in the pond and causing swirls the water
going past an obstacle and becoming
swirls when he was a kid when he's
diverting the arno river in middle age
or trying to
and as an old man looking at the swirls
and patterns of water
and it all comes together in one of the
greatest pictures ever done
on the left you see him dissecting the
human eye to discover that the very
center of the retina the cones or the
phobia
see black and white detail and he knows
from his own experiments and judgments
and
the sections that the edges of the
retina tend to see color
and shadows better
he also dissects the human face so he
knows every muscle
and every uh that touches the human lips
and every nerve that controls every
muscle
makes all sorts of discoveries about the
muscles of the lips and the way they're
shaped even ones that you and i could
have discovered had we
retained
our wonder years
of being curious and being observant
such as the bottom lip
is a muscle all on its own you can pout
it and move it on its own
top lip is not a separate muscle it only
you can't pout it alone
because it's connected with other
muscles
i see people trying it
if you're on c-span you are now looking
ridiculous
wait till you get home do it in front of
a mirror when you're alone
but all of that anatomical knowledge
despite what the kenneth clarkson others
said about being a waste of time
i think culminate of course
in the greatest smile ever painted
with the mona lisa you see the river
again coming from the eons of time
connecting to the roads of civilization
and then to us
as humans how do we fit in
but you if you want you look at the eyes
they're amazing but start with the lips
16 years he spend
putting layer after layer of the tiniest
brush strokes of glaze oil which is the
tiniest bit
of pigments in it because the light will
go all the way down to the primer coat
and then bounce back and he knows he can
make it look interactive
and as he does the lips he gets the
muscles and the movement and the shadow
exactly right
but he also
makes it so that the tiniest black and
white details especially on our left but
even on our right go straight
so if you're staring right at the corner
of the lips close up
the smile is elusive it kind of
disappears on you
but if your eyes go back to her forehead
or chin or cheek
suddenly the smile lights up again
because you're seeing it with a
different part of your eye you're seeing
it very so she's somebody who has
emotional reactions
but they change and as our emotion
changes she seems to interact with us as
if it's augmented reality
it is a deep mystery of emotions being
expressed
by facial and other gestures
and changing interactively with us
that's why
among many other things it is a great
connection of art to science
and a great masterpiece
he brings it with him after 16 years to
france where he's dying
his patron is francis the first gives
them a manor house next to the chateau
and thereby his bed or three or four
paintings including the mona lisa saint
john the baptist
he's still perfecting them
when i did einstein i looked at his last
notebook page because i wanted to see
what did he what was he doing that night
in princeton when his aorta is burst he
knows he's dying he does
two-thirds of a page of equations
even though he's dying he's still trying
to get us a step closer to the unified
theory that will connect
electromagnetism to gravity even though
he knows he's not going to be able to do
it he's still trying to do it
and leonardo
on his last notebook page that we know
of
he's still trying to square the circle
using a trick of euclid of a right
triangle with different length legs and
explains how maybe this will make a
shape that you could then make a square
and then make a circle and he has a
chart in the middle showing how to do it
but the very last line
it pauses
and then he writes but the soup
is getting cold
you can imagine him
up there in that bedroom
with
meltzee and salahi and his cook madarine
and the rest of the entourage downstairs
and he's still struggling to get us one
step closer to the spirit
manifest in the laws of the universe but
the soup is getting cold
thank you all
[Applause]
thank you appreciate it well thanks
thank you
thank you so much mr isaacson
and uh audience if you would like to
have a book autographed uh you may do so
on the other side of the elevators right
on this floor thank you so much once
more thank you very much
next on the presidency margaret leslie
davis reveals first lady jacqueline
kennedy's political and diplomatic coup
in bringing the mona lisa to the united
states despite opposition on both sides
of the atlantic leonardo da vinci's fame
painting was seen as a symbol of the
free world at the height of cold war
tensions and president kennedy used its
exhibition to promote american relations
with france and democracy itself
two million people saw the mona lisa in
washington dc and new york city during
the winter of 1963.
miss davis is the author of mona lisa in
camelot how jacqueline kennedy and da
vinci's masterpiece charmed and
cultivated a nation
the white house historical association
hosted this event and provided the video
now this evening it's a pleasure and an
honor to introduce a friend to the
association and a friend of mine
margaret leslie davis she is an
award-winning author of books about the
history of the west a region that she
lives in but also refers to as the
pastel empire
the author's books
have been praised by reviewers in the
los angeles times washington post
publishers weekly npr and the new york
times davis's most recent book is the
lost gutenberg the astounding astounding
story of one book's 500-year odyssey
published by penguin random house
in a starred review kirkus described the
book as an engrossing read a read for
any book lover davis work has been
featured on abc's good morning america
and excerpted in vanity fair magazine
the author has appeared on c-span book
tv the history channel's modern marvels
as well as documentary scene on
discovery channel and annie's biography
she is a california lawyer a graduate of
georgetown university and joining us
these this evening from the hills of los
feliz in los angeles county thank you
for joining us margaret thank you rhett
it's such a joy to be here for your
week-long virtual celebration in honor
of first lady jacqueline kennedy
i'm so delighted to share with you
a story from my book called mona lisa in
camelot a kind of forgotten story it
took place in 1963
when jackie kennedy masterminded one of
the greatest art exhibitions in american
history let's jump in shall we
our story opens with a whisper
a whisper between the young first lady
jacqueline kennedy and the charismatic
brilliant and eccentric minister of
culture
andrea melro
at a spectacular white house dinner on
the evening of may 11 1962
it was a whispered promise that would
set in motion one of the most unusual
and extraordinary art exhibitions of all
time the triumphant american exhibition
of leonardo da vinci's mona lisa
painted scholars believed sometime
between 1503 and 1506
the visit of the mono melisa produced
the greatest outpouring of appreciation
for a single work of art in american
history and pioneered the phenomenon of
the blockbuster museum show
it was one of the most daring
elaborate art exhibitions ever staged
and the painting's unlikely romantic
journey to america captured the
imagination of the world
following the president and first lady's
tour of the french capital you might
remember this in 1961 there were just
throngs of people on the streets
cheering the first couple as they
triumphantly made their way through
paris
the cultural minister of france andre
melro took mrs kennedy on a tour of the
great museums of paris
and one year later when melrose came to
washington to visit the kennedys uh
jackie kennedy pulled out all the stops
to show andrea melro some of the great
artistic treasures of america
minister melrose deep interest in art
his acclaimed books on cultural issues
were already familiar and much admired
by the first lady she had studied at the
sorbonne in her student days she spoke
flawless french and considered french
literature and art her ideal
by 1962
international relations between france
and the us had become seriously strained
with charles de gaulle insisting that
the security of france required the
development of an atomic arsenal
into this
tension-filled diplomatic morass glided
none other than jacqueline kennedy and
arden francophile
the mona lisa would play a pivotal role
at this decisive moment in u.s history
the first lady was the mastermind behind
this 1963 exhibition
when the painting it's called la jacond
as it's known in france the mona lisa
was transformed into nothing less than
an icon of the free world at the height
of the cold war
mrs kennedy had worked for weeks
planning the evening she invited the
very best of america's great artists
writers and intellectuals she even
enlisted arthur schlesinger to write a
toast for the president to offer during
the elaborate state dinner in minister
melrose honor she insisted that melro be
entertained by america's best talent and
she managed to cajole virtuoso violinist
isaac stern to entertain the assembled
guests
this gathering of the most accomplished
men and women in the american cultural
scene not only underscored the kennedy's
support for the arts but also
demonstrated how adept jackie was at
employing the arts in order to add
prestige to the jfk presidency
i love this photograph it shows jackie
with mel rowe sharing a mutual delight
and close conversation
seated for the evening's entertainment
jackie is seated very snuggle close with
her right shoulder nearly tucked under
his arm melrose leans towards jackie and
whispers something
a whisper pledge between them we only
learned later what she said
apparently
and this was covered in the parisian
press and impressed in the americans
we only learned later that it was a
whispered promise that he would loan the
first lady the mona lisa
for exhibit to america quote i will send
you the mona lisa elijah cohn he said
softly that night
well the two conspirators considered a
u.s exhibition of the painting a
convincing emblem of friendship between
france and america
a well-chosen gesture of amity goodwill
and international diplomacy
jackie astutely
understood that the relationship of the
president to the american people was one
of the most closely watched
relationships in modern life and she
recognized the unveiling of france's
supreme national treasure
the mona lisa was an unmatched
opportunity to burnish the american
image at home and abroad
she was a deeply attuned to the power of
symbols and the exhibition of france's
cultural prize was carefully engineered
by her to amplify the domestic and
international popularity of the american
president and at the same time bring an
important cultural exchange to the
american people
but not everyone shared jackie kennedy
and melrose enthusiasm for sending da
vinci's masterpiece to the u.s it was
not a popular idea with the french
populist and even more disconcerting
curators at the louvre and international
art authority saw it as an act of
american hubris a preposterous idea that
risked harm to an important masterpiece
the intricacies of the negotiations to
bring the painting here are a story in
itself and i hope you have a chance to
take a look at some of the wild capers
that happened during um
the mona lisa's travels to america
and
all the while this was at the height of
the cuban missile crisis there was the
intractable hostility of de gaulle as
well as the opposition of major figures
in the art world
the story also includes many
complexities for the kennedy
administration that i will leave you to
read more about
but the arrival of the mona lisa was a
political coup for the administration
illustrating the glory of art
and the culture of the west as compared
to the sterile art
and life of the soviet regime in the
cold war it is clear from the record
that andre melro and charles de graal
saw the unprecedented exhibition as a
shrewd gesture of diplomacy during the
touchy conflict over de gaulle's desire
for an independent nuclear force in the
face of fierce opposition by president
kennedy
well
one of the figures most opposed to the
exhibition was an american
he was
national gallery director john walker
the patrician
harvard educated
connoisseur of art who ran the nation's
most important museum
he was vehemently opposed to the idea
and in fact shocked aghast at the
concept of moving a fragile 450 year old
masterpiece one of the greatest
paintings of all time
and not a painting on canvas but one
painted on flimsy poplar wood that was
already starting to buckle
move this precious fragile painting
across the ocean at the height of winter
walker was hard-pressed for ways to let
jackie know
that he under no circumstances wanted to
be responsible for the mona lisa when
she came to america it was a clash of
wills and a test of their decades-old
friendship and soon the mona lisa became
the real issue of contention between
them walker begged her to repeatedly
change her mind he emphasized the danger
inherited in the venture to john walker
the idea of moving a fragile masterpiece
thousands of miles across the atlantic
ocean tempted fates that should never be
tested
for him the whole scheme reeked
of american arrogance and he urged
jackie to abandon the plan
but to walk her surprise instead of
reacting with apprehension
jackie responded with mild amusement
there were hazards she said but the
risks were exaggerated
and to prove the point she reminded
walker that melro had determined that
the painting was in good enough shape to
travel and the trip had been approved
and sanctioned by french officials
including president charles de gaulle
well
the exhibition of the mona lisa was the
perfect expression of jackie's interest
in intermingling
art with politics she had somehow
constructed the ideal union of culture
and diplomacy as first lady she saw the
loan of the masterpiece as a source of
pride for both herself and the nation
alone that would lift the image of
america abroad and elevate interest in
the cultural arts at home in her mind
the exhibition was the ultimate cultural
statement about the power of the u.s and
her allies it further bolstered the
president's cold war efforts to portray
america as the epitome of a free society
that advocated widespread support of the
fine arts
but
in the world of john walker
objects of art never had a role in the
gritty grimy world of politics
if the painting arrived safely it would
be a defining moment for all americans
but if the painting was damaged it would
cause an irreparable rift with the
french people and destroy one of
history's great artifacts
to jackie the exhibition was a generous
gesture of amity by andre melro the
leading cultural figure in france and an
intellect she deeply admired a national
policy that supported international
exchange in the arts strengthened
international alliances and played a
critical cultural role in fighting the
cold war
in the end mrs kennedy's wish came true
and despite walker's vehement objections
she got her way in this photograph the
mona lisa is whisked off the gangplank
following her trip across the atlantic
ocean
andre melrose had ordered the mona lisa
to be packed and prepared for her
journey to america
and despite riots in the streets of
paris imagine so severe that charles de
gaulle was forced to impose a mona lisa
news blackout
all in the middle of angry protests from
art experts and artificials around the
world
in this photo you can see the mona lisa
packed inside her specially designed
traveling crate temperature controlled
waterproof and fire resistant
also designed to float should the ship
capsize and sink
in fact mona lisa's bodyguards were
instructed that in the event of a fire
aboard the ship the crate was to be
immediately tossed overboard
and curators insisted the french flag be
painted on the outside of the container
in the event the painting were to be
lost in international waters
the ss france arrived at the new york
harbor pictured here in the morning of
december 19 1962
and she's whisked down the gangplank
photographers snapped pictures as french
stevedores carried the box and secret
service agents hand-picked by president
kennedy
wearing little tiny machine guns under
their wool overcoats to protect their
vip charge a 450 year old very famous
lady
she's carried off the giant ship the
famous 80 million dollar luxury super
liner the ss france on her arrival to
new york city
december 14th 1962
following its five-day journey across
the atlantic ocean bound for new york
well in many ways it was a mission
impossible to get the painting safely to
the national gallery of art in
washington dc
imagine this the french insisted that
the temperature at all times both inside
the special box and later at the museum
was to remain precisely the same as it
was in the louvre at 72 degrees
fahrenheit
the french made it crystal clear
that should the temperature change one
iota the painting would be wrenched back
by french officials and immediately
returned
john walker's task was to keep the
temperature constant all the while
protecting the painting from robbers
kidnappers or just plain old maniacs
in its 450 year history the painting had
been hidden in wartime attacked it had
been stolen and john walker was
determined to do everything in his power
to make sure that the mona lisa would
remain safe under his watch
walker worked frantically with gallery
engineers and delicately adjusted the
ventilation system so that the
atmosphere the mona lisa's temporary
home would simulate the air she had
breathed for centuries
walker later wrote in his memoirs and i
was so touched when i read it that he
was out of his mind with anxiety and
worry over the safety of the mona lisa
and the fear of causing heartbreak to
both the first lady and president
kennedy
he confided in his book that
he was so terrified over the fate of the
mona lisa that he even had his doctor
prescribe him what he said were mona
lisa anxiety pills
he was so concerned and so consumed with
fear
that untoward harm would come to the
famous painting
but for the sake of this great artifact
of
western civilization
and for the first lady's dream walker
was determined to keep the lady safe
until its grand debut pictured here
on january 8
1963
on the evening of the debut the entire
leadership of the us was to be present
for the unveiling which really
was more like a queen's coronation
than the opening of an art exhibition
ah jackie kennedy elegantly quaffed in
her strapless pink chiffon gown
embroidered with brilliance and pearls
designed by ola cassini
she was simply at her glowing best she
stole the spotlight diamond drop
earrings designed by harry winston
sparkled against her face as a flood of
flash bulbs popped inside the great
marbled hall
press coverage readily found a
connection between the mona lisa and
jackie kennedy quote the mona lisa first
lady of the world among paintings and
jacqueline kennedy
first lady of the nation came face to
face reported the washington post
it was a long awaited reunion exclaimed
life magazine and both ladies were at
their beautiful best
jackie had returned with her husband
from christmas vacation in palm beach
in time to dress and have her hair done
before the occasion both she and
president kennedy look rested youthful
and tan whereas the melrose by contrast
is seen in this picture here i'm afraid
look a little pale and exhausted
but nothing could mark such an occasion
as mona lisa's triumphant debut
inside the rotunda of the national
gallery in washington dc
and that night
the kennedys shared also a beautiful
secret
information known only to the president
and first lady and a handful of
intimates mrs kennedy was pregnant
guests who were present that night said
that she simply looked radiant
well americans did not miss the
political and diplomatic significance of
the loan of the mona lisa and once the
doors to the national gallery opened
thousands streamed inside to see the
painting for themselves the kennedy
administration would utilize the
exhibition as a tool to shape influence
and manipulate public opinion
the exhibition of this cultural prize
would be carefully engineered
to amplify the domestic and
international popularity of america's
engaging articulate and media savvy
president
and the timing coincided with the
introduction of television into the
political mix
the spectacle
of the mona lisa's unveiling would be
telecast to a huge american audience so
to make an indelible impression
once the overflow audience was more or
less quiet kennedy read from his
prepared address a finely crafted
tribute to the painting
its artists
and the two nations shared aspirations
and beliefs written with great skill by
august texture and arthur schlesinger
quote
the life of this painting here before us
tonight
spans the entire life of the new world
we citizens unborn at the time of its
creation are among the inheritors and
protectors of the ideal which gave at
birth
for this painting is not only one of the
towering achievements of the skill and
vision of art but its creator embodied
the central purpose of our civilization
we here tonight
among them many of the men entrusted
with the destiny of this republic
also come to pay homage to this great
civilization we share the beliefs which
we protect
and the aspirations towards which we
together strive unquote
the unveiling of the mona lisa coincided
with the opening of the 88th congress
and because nearly everyone from both
chambers was present the speech was
infused with brilliant political
underpinnings
the president astutely utilized the mona
lisa to rise above the issues of
difference to stress the profound
historic and political ties between
france and the us
and his speech highlighted the way in
which both nations had fought side by
side and not one two three but four wars
and how their respective revolutions had
come to define the very notions of
modern democracy and liberty
it was an oration that shrewdly
transformed the mona lisa into a symbol
of the cold war
representing western progress in
contrast to the repressive regime of the
communist bloc
kennedy's closing line would become the
single most quoted line by the world
press he said quote
politics and art
the life of action and the life of
thought
the world of events and the world of
imagination
are one
will the crowds queued up outside the
national gallery
pictured here look at this amazing
enormous amount of people who lined up
in the cold freezing january
for many it was the very first time they
had visited an art museum and many would
return for subsequent visits they waited
hour upon hour for their chance to see
the mona lisa with their very own eyes
the exhibition as jackie kennedy had
hoped triggered a renewed appreciation
for culture and the fine arts that had
been dormant in the post-war years the
gray gold cold eisenhower
years were suddenly replaced with the
vibrant cultural and artistic interests
brought to national attention by the new
youthful and exuberant kennedy family
mrs kennedy was very much the prime
mover in this new feeling and
sensibility
people from every facet of american life
came to the museum father and mothers
with their children and in washington dc
many residents of the less privileged
neighborhoods brought their children and
stood in long lines to see for
themselves one of the greatest artistic
treasures of mankind
this is my absolute favorite picture
i love it so much groups of school
children arrived with their teachers to
share an experience that would be
remembered forever
the painting's american debut coincided
with president kennedy's escalating
international and domestic prestige
and it was superbly utilized
on the heels of the cuban missile crisis
to help solidify the president's image
the succeeding weeks
during the mona lisa's visit to america
were an exhilarating time described by
arthur schlesinger as a golden interlude
in which washington engaged in a
collective effort to make itself
brighter gayer more intellectual
the first lady was at the heart and
center of this new sensation
arthur schlesinger contended that the
things people had once held against
jacqueline kennedy the unconventional
beauty
the un-american elegance
her taste for french clothes and french
food were no longer liabilities but
assets
he went on to state that quote she
represented all at once not a negation
of her country but a possible
fulfillment of it a suggestion that
america was not to be trapped forever in
the bourgeois ideal but instead achieve
a dream of civilization and beauty
schlesinger tells us that
mrs kennedy had dreaded coming to the
white house fearing the end of family
and privacy
but life for herself and her children
was never more intense and complete
it turned out to be the time of the
greatest happiness
well here we can see a marine guard is
taking very seriously his job to guard
the painting
if you look closely behind the green
ferns you'll see a piece of equipment
it was called a high growth thermograph
and this was the machine that was
monitoring the air quality and the
temperature the entire time the mona
lisa was inside the national gallery
french curators were literally standing
by to seize the painting should the
temperature drop below 72 degrees or
sail above 72 degrees
it was john walker's charge to keep that
temperature constant
and the hydro
thermograph was hidden behind the ferns
the mona lisa generated the first modern
blockbuster exhibition in the national
galleries history only one other
exhibition the famous 1948
exhibition of the famous paintings from
berlin
had generated
similar acclaim but nothing nothing
could compare to the lease of fever that
had swept through the capitol as nearly
1
million visitors poured through the
museum doors
as the exhibition gained unprecedented
attention walker directed guards to
route visitors through other galleries
so they would be forced to view
other important works of art before they
left the museum following their
encounter with the mona lisa on their
way out walker declared quote let them
see a little rembrandt too
the famous lady completed her washington
tour with no apparent damage
no tears were shed however over the
departure of the glamorous feminine
guest by the national gallery guards
who
happily anticipating an end to the
unusually large crowds
the guards had written on the blackboard
in their locker room mona go home
well once again
the mona lisa was packed and readied for
her return trip to new york and her
exhibition this time at the metropolitan
museum of art
and it remained to be seen whether every
prayer and every precaution by john
walker would be enough to keep the lady
safe
mrs kennedy personally asked walker
specifically to travel alongside the
painting during its trip to new york and
after 27 days at the national gallery
with record crowds so much so that john
walker kept the gallery doors open each
night until 9 pm to accommodate the
masses of visitors
the mona lisa departed washington dc for
new york city
the mona lisa was lifted up the steps of
the venerable metropolitan museum
and after she was uncreated she was hung
inside the large medieval sculpture hall
under the direction of james rorimore
the museum's director
just as in washington d.c new yorkers
came in droves to see the painting
at 10 a.m on thursday february 7th
1963 the exhibition opened amid a
city-wide newspaper strike but it still
generated a cultural phenomenon
traffic was jammed and lines of museum
goers waited for hours in the bitter
cold just to get inside you know i
researched this carefully and discovered
that the very first person in line
was a new york taxi driver
from brooklyn named joseph latsky a
quote self-admitted lover of the finer
things who arrived at the museum at 4 40
a.m to be the very first to see the mona
lisa
by the time the doors open a line
extended down the museum steps and all
the way along fifth avenue
the city had fallen crazy in love with
mona bars and restaurants got into the
act by generating a new cocktail in
honor of the famous visitor
called simply the mona lisa the
scintillating concoction was made up of
cognac on the rocks with a dash of dry
vermuth
shopkeepers sold mona lisa knickknacks
by the box load and the famous name
suddenly appeared everywhere in cartoons
and advertisements suddenly all things
mona lisa were terribly in vogue
i had to share this newspaper clipping
see the little girl on the shoulders of
her dad
she
emailed me and said after she read my
book that seeing the mona lisa was one
of the most precious memories she had as
a young tiny child with her father and
the best part she said was when the line
got long and it got cold and they were
waiting three four five hours to get
into the museum
her father said he would take her to
tiffany's
and at tiffany's she said she was
allowed to purchase anything she wanted
as long as it was ten dollars love the
story
well after the mona lisa was hung inside
the large medieval sculpture hall
under the direction of museum director
james worm or
john walker undoubtedly felt a tinge of
envy
rora moore had more to work with in the
sweeping space of the mets huge medieval
sculpture hall pictured here then walker
had in the noisy barrel vaulted
loud west hall at the national gallery
at the metropolitan
the painting hung at the perfect
eyesight line not too high not too low
it was displayed against a hanging of
stunning french brocade of red and green
it was beautifully lit from the top
the bottom and both sides
and the bulletproof glass protected the
painting surface
but somehow in new york at the
metropolitan the glare from the custom
spotlights did not reflect as much as it
had in the marble hall
national gallery distorting the
visitor's view
and unlike the national gallery to walk
a chagrin the presentation was hailed by
critics as flawless
even the typically brutal art critics
of connoisseur magazine remarked on the
stunning display noting its beauty
simplicity and importance
more than symbolism was involved the
crowds who lined up outside the met were
proof enough that the blockbuster show
had ushered in a new era in which fine
art was no longer the province of the
elite
future museum shows would encompass
activities that enriched the visitors
experience attracted new audiences and
encouraged return visits
the record crowds that descended on
washington dc and new york to view mona
lisa proved that jacqueline kennedy
understood these principles and through
her adept staging
she
set off a national love affair with the
arts
it was the first time an exhibition of
art had been an official duty of the
white house
and it was the first time that a
painting would serve as the icon of the
free world
it may seem utterly inconceivable in
today's world but not one credible
threat was made against the mona lisa
from the moment the masterpiece left the
louvre until it was returned 88 days
later
nearly 2
million americans came to see her
jacqueline kennedy was proven right
no harm came to the mona lisa and the
exhibit contributed to a widespread
cultural awakening for many americans
six years after the exhibition john
walker wrote that he was wrong about the
likelihood that the portrait would be
damaged and it was the honor of his
lifetime to see
if guard the painting for the benefit of
president kennedy and the first lady
the painting was returned to france
on march 8
1963.
only eight short months later everything
came to a grinding halt of deep
and intense grief
in dallas
on november 22 with the assassination of
president john f kennedy
also lost following the assassination
was president kennedy and jacqueline
kennedy's deep interest in fostering the
possibility of a cabinet level arts
director
to their way of thinking the
centuries-old tradition of public
support for the arts embraced in europe
was a missing ingredient in american
life
jackie kennedy had used
her rapport with french minister of
cultural andre melro to explore what
would be realistic and feasible for
america
for jackie mona lisa's trip was her gift
to america awakening a deep enduring
interest in the cultural arts
and it was a grand pursuit which
jacqueline kennedy as first lady so
passionately inaugurated
margaret thank you for that presentation
um i'm happy to tell you that one of our
viewers this evening uh i think we
should start with this
um carlene from new york
was was among those
who went to the met to see
the exhibition of the mona lisa so she
was
delighted to hear your presentation
tonight
one question she had was related to the
expense of the exhibition did you find
anything in your research about how mrs
kennedy or the museums or galleries were
able to do they have to raise a lot of
funds to be able to showcase the mona
lisa
the funds to
safeguard the painting
and to launch the exhibition were
provided by two donors
and i go into detail about the book one
was bunny melon
um
who after the exhibit
sent quite a few gifts to mrs kennedy i
think
i think it was one of those rare moments
where art culture and politics infused
into this remarkable happening i mean it
was such a
positive and beautiful experience just
triggering uh sort of a
new appreciation for the great cultural
treasures around the world
and it it is the most surprising thing
to know that mrs kennedy was not only
the master mastermind behind the
exhibition but she also carefully
orchestrated its staging
press interviews she even edited
speeches that arthur schlesinger wrote
for kennedy
and her pencil
handwriting and editing is very clear on
the speeches and you kind of watch the
progression she was hands on 100 with
this and uh the entire exhibition
was financed privately through donations
one thing i will say uh president
kennedy hand-picked his favorite secret
service agent a man by the name of john
champion to safeguard the painting and
in fact president kennedy asked him to
sleep with the painting so
i'm sure his family had an earful when
he came home about what it was like to
sleep on a cot next to the mona lisa
well excellent one question we have from
kevin in washington dc is that
um when you began your research on this
particular book
it sounds as if you had started uh with
the idea that you would talk about the
tour of the mona lisa but then as time
went on um you began to gravitate
towards the story of how jackie kennedy
was the impetus that brought the
painting to the united states can you
talk more about at what point and why
did you decide to take that uh focus in
that direction
i was really astounded how involved she
really was i mean this was not uh just
casually showing up at the exhibition to
be photographed alongside the painting
she coordinated
pages and pages of details of the
negotiations with the french for the
painting safe arrival all the security
precautions um
really a my rate of details that added
to the pizzazz and excitement of the
painting's arrival and its safety um
poor john walker though can you imagine
being entrusted with caring for france's
revered cultural treasure possibly the
most fainting most famous painting of
all time
how he stumbled on the story
was at the time i was working on a
biography of franklin murphy who was
chairman of the national gallery and i
was lucky enough to be in the archives
and
i found
some small
letters on blue white house stationery
which i recognized immediately as jackie
kennedy's handwriting
and as i started to dig into the letters
she was in an argument with john walker
over an art exhibition
but in the series of letters
no one mentioned the name of the
painting
so i had to jump on a plane fly up to
the jfk library and
within a few days i figured out it was
the mona lisa and realized what an
incredible story it really really was
and that these letters have been
forgotten and i really think a large
reason the exhibition had been largely
forgotten is because of the
assassination
the other most remarkable thing
i learned was how
how intent the kennedys were in creating
a cabinet level position for the arts in
america much like we have uh in europe
and in france with andre melrose the
french minister of culture this was a
sincere effort on their part and in fact
plans had been made for later in the
year to announce a cabinet arts czar
excellent i want to ask you um in terms
of of the actual presentation there's a
number of questions in the queue here
about whether or not the
mona lisa ever left france for
another exhibition like this to another
country or back to the states what do
you know about that
you know it's so amazing you would think
after this
uh amazing 88 trip to america the french
would never let the painting leave again
but in fact they did and the painting
traveled to tokyo
it traveled to tokyo for a two-week
exhibition
and it was meant with great reverence by
the japanese people
some of the pictures of the exhibition
are so dramatic and beautiful and of
course the day the plane arrived it was
raining and you know a whole parade of
cars and vans and art curators came with
their black umbrellas and mona lisa was
whisked in her special traveling crate
another shocking detail is
as the mona lisa was traveling
to
tokyo
um
there was a
satellite uh
launched into orbit
which was unknown by the pilot that he
was going to encounter this whisking um
satellite just uh in his eye view and
i'm sure it was uh quite a frightening
moment for him i i tell it in the very
end of the book but you know what i
loved the most was of course the mona
lisa traveled by herself
in the entire giant
jetliner strapped to the floor
well thank you thank you for that i i
think the other question is and you'll
appreciate this as an angelino
why didn't the painting make it to the
west coast
ah good question
i think of course it was probably too
risky to you know fly it for one more uh
exhibition and of course our east coast
friends think the national gallery and
the
metropolitan museum may exceed our
provincial los angeles museum in 1963
and in fact we didn't even have the los
angeles museum of art in los angeles
until
later we have another question from a
west coast person diane from san diego
asked who influenced jackie kennedy's
interest in the arts do you think
you know i think it was her mother
her mother uh took her on frequent
field trips to museums and in fact
that's how john walker got to know
jackie kennedy is when her mother
brought her to the museum of course
they were personally led through the
museum by the gallery director i mean
this isn't just an ordinary uh field
trip to the museum
and i think that her mother influenced
her
greatly and i i can honestly say from
reading
some of her private correspondence
regarding the exhibition that she
thought about her mother quite a bit and
what a triumph she would have thought it
had been
to bring the mona lisa so america could
see her
excellent
we have a question from meg from santa
fe she would like to know what role did
president kennedy play with uh in
regards to first lady jack and kennedy's
initiative to bring the painting to the
u.s
i'm sorry what role did
did president kennedy play oh
you know
it's really remarkable in all the um
uh paperwork connected with the
exhibition there are a few things where
president kennedy's own hand is there
where he's check marks or he says okay
or this or that but it really was
jackie kennedy who masterminded i mean
this is an astounding amount of evidence
actual primary
records that document her day-to-day
activities regarding the exhibition
there's no question though that
president kennedy supported this bold
idea and considered it part of his
effort to ease tensions between france
and the united states i know many of us
know from our history class the famous
force they frappe uh conflict over uh
the french nuclear arsenal something
which kennedy was vehemently opposed to
so i think he appreciated mrs kennedy's
bold idea and backed her 100 percent
let me ask you margaret we had a number
of questions about this um
do you think there was a difference in
terms of um of
people being able to see the painting
was it available to all people was there
was segregation involved
uh in terms of visiting the painting
when it was at the national gallery do
you know anything about that versus the
met
in uh john walker was insistent that it
was just
first in line first in so it was as
people arrived they were just queued up
there was no vip access although you can
imagine his phone was ringing day and
night uh for people who wanted that
personal tour the mona lisa but no this
was really an exhibition for the people
and anyone who showed up and waited in
line sadly though the lines were quite
long and i'm sure some of the school
children you know after a five or six
hour wait were quite exhausted but i
don't think anyone who actually had a
chance to see the mona lisa during the
88-day period it was in america would
ever forget it
well last question of the evening uh
margaret is going to be on the
transportation mode of uh mona lisa a
number of folks have asked why did she
travel by ship versus traveling by air
isn't that amazing
you know there was air force one
airplane travel was commonplace by 1962
1963
it was a safer
better option for the painting to fly
but the french insisted
grand manifestations
they wanted the most
opulent
arrival for the mona lisa that they
could imagine and they wanted it to come
on the ss france the great
uh 80 million dollar luxury super liner
and there are these tremendous pictures
that are in the book of the moment the
ship pulls into new york harbor and all
the boats sort of
surrounded and the big sprays of water
and basically fireworks of celebration
when the painting arrived
uh it does astound me that the french
would consider that
a safer
safer
mode of travel for such a fragile
masterpiece i mean imagine
you know painted on poplar wood
practically buckling 450 years old by
this time
um
but no the french insisted that it
traveled by ocean liner
well margaret thank you for joining us
tonight i i just want to say a special
thanks to you because your work as an
author really aligns very much with the
white house historical association not
only because we publish the second
printing of your book but also because
you're really focused on
keeping culture uh in this psyche of the
american public helping people
understand
why different things in our culture are
important and if folks want to look at
some of the other books that margaret
leslie davis has written you'll find
that a number of them are on historical
figures in the west but also your more
recent one on the gutenberg bible is uh
is also of that that same help so we
appreciate that and being a partner with
us also at the white house historical
association thank you
thank you rhett was a joy to join you